Okay. Good morning, Linda.
We're live. Good morning.
All right. Good morning, everyone.
We are going to reopen the July 2020 board meeting and Karen, can you take the role? Yes.
Linda Darling-Hammond.
Here. Cynthia Glover-Woods.
Here. Jim McQuillen.
Here. Brenna Pangelinan.
Here. Kim Patio-Bronson.
Here. Ida Rodriguez.
Here. Eileen Strauss.
Here. Okay.
Matt is here. Matt is here. Matt's in. Matt, welcome, Matt.
Here.
We missed you.
We're still working the problem for Ting and for Patricia, but hopefully we'll join us shortly.
Right. So we've had some technology problems and a couple of our board members couldn't get in. We have a couple more who will come.
But we are going to begin this morning by reopening item one, which is our state board priorities item.
And hopefully our other board members will join us before we get to the end of that item.
We're going to take action on the draft May 2020 meeting minutes and report on our liaison assignments.
So there should be a public comment slide that will go up.
Nope. Yes, we're putting that up now.
There we go.
So this is on the draft preliminary report of action minutes for the May 7th, 2020 meeting.
We'll open the phone line for public comment.
Members of the public wishing to provide comment on this item may do so by calling a 712-432-0075 entering the access code and following the instructions on this slide.
And while we are waiting for any members of the public to call in, do I have a motion from a board member to approve the May 7th, 2020 State Board of Education draft preliminary report of action slash meeting minutes?
I'll motion.
I hear member Navo. And is there a second? Second.
Was that, who was that?
Thank you very much. I can't see everyone at once. Great.
And are there any public comments?
No, we have public comment, but they're for the charter items.
Okay, so there's no public comments. Is there any further discussion of the board meeting minutes?
Okay.
Board members, please raise your hand in the participant panel of Zoom. Karen will keep track of the raised hands.
And I believe our new board members will abstain from voting on this item.
Correct.
Okay.
And Karen, can you please call the roll?
Okay, let's see.
No one's raising their, no one's raising their hand. Did you want them to raise it in the participant list?
That's what it says in the script.
Why don't we just do the roll call? It's easier. Yeah.
Matt. Yes. Thank you, Matt. Okay. Brenna.
Yes. Kim. Yes.
Eileen. Yes. And Ting. Has Ting joined us? No.
Ting should be in. Let's see if she's, Ting, are you there?
Hello, Ting. Okay. Hi. I can't see anything or anyone though.
We can hear you. That's a step in the right direction.
We can see you.
Do you see us, Ting?
I don't. I can't see, and my camera is, well, let's see. Okay.
There you are. We see you. Okay.
You look great.
Okay. So Ting, we're voting on the minutes.
Okay.
I need you to say yes. Yes. Okay.
Thank you.
But no pressure. No pressure.
What about Patricia Rucker? Is she with us? Okay.
And then I need to fix this whole thing. Yes, I am. Okay.
Patricia, we're voting on the minutes.
Oh my gosh.
Patricia, can you say yes? Yes. Okay, good. All right.
So the minutes have been approved.
All right. That was quite an accomplishment.
We'll see how the rest of the day goes.
Now I want to invite the state board members to report out on any
liaison activities that are not related to any items on our July
agenda.
And because of our three new board members who were just sworn in
this morning,
they have not yet received liaison assignments,
but we'll be working together after the board meeting to discuss the
various opportunities they may wish to get involved in.
So let's begin by calling on other board members based on their last
name. I'm going to start with member Navo.
In the middle.
There we go. Can you hear me? Yep.
Okay. I think I speak for everyone.
Ting, that was the most stressed. That took years off my life right there.
Trying to get on.
That took years off my life.
So I got a couple of computers of trying to work this thing and we'll see
how we do here.
So the system of support to say the least has been very busy.
And just for those in the audience that when I say system of support,
I mean, California department of ed,
the California collaborative for educational excellence, the state board,
the county offices, the LEA, the geographic leads, the scope of leads.
So it's, it's a composite of many entities across the state that are doing
the work of supporting schools.
I'm going to highlight, there's a lot to share,
but I'm going to highlight very quickly a couple of big items.
But I think are important.
CD and CCE have just awarded the 21st century California school leadership
academy grants.
I think that's a very important,
it's going to be providing training across the state to eight awardees to do
that training.
And those awardees to provide administrative and other school leaders
throughout the state training and support is university of California,
Berkeley, Los Angeles County office of ed, Sacramento County office of ed,
Los Angeles education partnership, Chico state, Madera County,
superintendent of schools in Sonoma County office of ed.
They represent seven of the,
of the county offices and local entities that are going to be providing this
training of providing high quality professional development.
And I think this is a huge move in the right direction for the system of
support training,
our leaders and providing supports to up and coming leaders in the state,
how best to serve students and meet their needs.
In addition,
CCE and CDE are jointly charged with selecting both the county office of
education to administer the new dyslexia initiative by September 1st and a
county office of education to serve as a lead expert in literacy within the
system of support by December 1st.
So that I think that's going to be,
that's another joint project between the CCE and CDE.
That is a great example of the system of support working together and
providing resources across the state. For the CCE,
highlighting the distance learning that's went on.
CCE has provided technical assistance with regards to distance
learning.
They've done that with a multitude of collaboration between CDE state board
and county offices as long as, as well as community organizations.
And they've done 318 virtual sessions that were completed with the system of
support regarding hybrid learning,
distance learning with over 16,000 views to the website and a rating of 4.5
or higher on the value of the training.
So I think that says a lot about the quality of the training and support
that's going out across the state. In addition to that,
you have the continuity of learning playbook that was highlighted.
That was, that has 19,000,
over 19,000 views and helps the system of support to support students
and with their social,
emotional learning and building capacity of English learners,
supporting students with special needs as well as resources about how to
return. So I think that that's going to be incredibly helpful and has been
incredibly helpful. And last but not least,
the system of support has engaged in the community engagement initiative.
The community engagement initiative is part of the support that's expanding
the professional learning networks.
And those were awarded to Chino Valley Unified, Marino Valley,
Pajaro Valley, Riverside, Upper Lake and Val Verde Unified School District.
So there's a lot going on in the system of support right now,
as it pertains to awarding entities across the state to do the good work.
And there's also a lot going on around distance learning. How do we,
how do we return? And the CCE, CDE,
County Office of Eds are right back, right in the middle of all that.
And I think to go into the details of board president,
we could talk about an hour about it,
but I think that highlights the most high level things that are happening across
the state at this point.
All right. Thank you. Thank you so much and welcome. We're glad you're here.
Glad you got in.
Me too.
We're going to go to board member Pangalina.
Hi, nothing really.
I'm just excited to support the next student board member once they join in
any way that I can.
Terrific.
We will look forward to your doing that and to your checking back in with us
regularly. Member Patil Bronson.
Good morning.
So there's a couple of things I was going to provide an update on.
One is the early childhood policy council has had a couple of meetings
since we have last been all together.
And much of the conversation has been around the master plan for early
learning and care.
That is a master plan that is due to,
for its public debut on October 1st.
There is a research team comprised of Wested, Child Trends,
Stanford School of Ed, Rand, LIF, AIR, Neiman Collaborative,
and social policy partners,
all of whom have been working together to both assess the current state of
the system of early care and education,
and then also to make recommendations for the plan moving forward.
They've broken it out into a couple of meta categories that they're making
recommendations around in finance,
in expansion of access around facilities, quality improvement,
and universal pre-K.
Also in this last year's budget that was just recently signed,
there's been some movement of programs across various departments.
And so the four-year-old programs are staying with the Department of
Education and the younger child care wraparound programs,
and a number of other sort of more health-related programs are going to
stay under Health and Human Services with the Department of Social Services.
But obviously,
CDE having state preschool is,
I think,
signaling and an opportunity to create more cohesion and sort of alignment
and articulation between the early learning and K-12 systems,
which is,
I think,
something for us as a board to continue tracking.
In addition,
I also wanted to report out on the early math symposium,
which I was able to attend part of, which was really fantastic.
And it was both,
I think,
very much geared towards educators and actually informing classroom
practice,
but also sort of went between the 30,000-foot level,
as well as the sort of individual adult-to-child interaction levels,
and very much addressing this idea of how to integrate
and make early math skills,
applied learning opportunities in the early years,
everything from business planning for four-year-olds,
for how to host a lemonade stand and bake sale,
as well as physical education integration with PE and counting of steps
and such,
but to essentially make learning active, integrated,
and project-based,
which obviously is something that many of us are thinking about,
not just for the early years,
but wanting the math curriculum to be something that lives in children's
minds,
in their sort of pencil and papers,
but also in their activities and how they understand and absorb
all of the learning.
There was also a really clear focus on making sure that children with
disabilities would also be brought into this
format,
and I think maybe the top line where I should have started is that
we oftentimes, I think,
when focusing on early years and the sort of initial year of testing,
focus on third grade reading as the year where the achievement graph is
most readily apparent in the beginning,
but third grade math scores also show some significant need for improvement
and those are our achievement gaps that once settled as early as age eight
are really difficult to get around.
There's also interesting gender implications where girls tend to do
better or as well as boys in the early years,
and then there's a flip around fourth and fifth grade,
which need not be.
So in any case,
it was great learning and I heard from a number of participants about how
beneficial it was.
Great.
And you just taught us a lot.
Thank you very much.
Member Rucker.
Patricia, are you there?
Can you unmute yourself?
Yes, can you hear me?
Yes.
Okay.
I'm on my phone,
so this is going to be a different kind of,
this will be an interesting interaction for the whole day.
And I'm with the board member novel.
This was, this took a few,
this took a few minutes off my life getting in on the call today.
I want to thank you all.
First of all,
for taking the time to be with us today.
It would be a mistake to imagine that the impacts of our separate and collective
works on this board absent and acknowledgement that something fundamentally
has taken place in our world,
as well as the controversies and traumas that have interrupted life and
schooling for millions of California students and their households.
So as we talk about all the work that we've done,
it's important for us to understand that the opening of school this year is
going to be like any other school year in our careers.
I also,
along with member Patil Bronson and board member Strauss,
I'm sure you'll hear from her as well,
participated in the early math symposium.
I had the honor of giving,
giving the opening address to welcome the conference participants.
And it has always been a wonderful session.
I've had the opportunity and the thrill of supporting this conference from its
inception and its beginning conference activities.
I also, sir, speaking of math,
I also am the liaison for the math curriculum framework committee.
They had a virtual meeting,
a two day video conference on June 24th and 25th.
The agenda covered new content in chapter four,
exploring and discovering and reasoning with and about mathematics,
chapter five, data science,
and chapter 10 assessment in the 21st century.
There's a great deal of interest about what California is doing and developing
this new content.
The reasoning and discovery chapter gives a new frame and interpretation to the
instructional shifts for teaching math.
The data science is literally the expression of what's happening in the world.
And it lets students become the discoverers of knowledge.
And then finally,
the concerns and ideas expressed by the members as they discuss the assessment
chapter and state assessment policies will have far reaching impact on the
understanding in the field on what it means to build a more holistic system,
systemic approach to assessment.
It was really important at this meeting to hear feedback from stakeholders
during the public comment section about the importance of culturally relevant
instruction,
asset based instruction and assessment opportunities where students can show
what they know.
Clearly what they were asking for is culture is, was plain,
culturally relevant contents,
not about watering down the presentation of content or creating artifice in
scaffolding lessons for English learners. It's what the stake,
it's about the background,
the context and the relevance of the material stakeholders are looking for in
the learning experiences,
the play materials and the activities that will be provided to students.
I'm also looking forward to the significantly disproportionality stakeholder
meeting.
It will be a virtual meeting on July 15th.
This has been a long standing concern of the state of California.
We are in compliance and doing our reporting.
Providing services to students with exceptional or special needs as required
by federal mandate.
But in the area of how we make reports or make referrals for special
education,
there is we are out of compliance because there is a significant over
reporting or over referral of students of color,
particularly African-American students.
And so this will stakeholder work group works to address not only what the
standards or criteria are,
for significant that defined significant disproportionality,
but also providing guidance in developing plans to address this over
identification at the local level.
There was an IQC meeting held on May 13th.
This was in the week right after the May state board meeting.
As you know, yesterday,
the state board took action to adopt two frameworks recommended by the IQC,
the world languages framework and the arts framework.
At the main meeting,
the IQC subject matter committees began the work of instruction materials
adoption.
Both the world languages committee and the arts committee looked at the
content maps.
The standards maps and the evaluation criteria.
So as excited as we were to see the framework come to fruition yesterday,
their work is laid out in front of them to begin the process of guiding the
students.
And so we are very excited about that.
And then finally,
I had the opportunity to apply for,
and I was accepted into a national work group that's being sponsored by the
national association of state boards of education.
They selected 20 state board members from across the country to participate
in a whole child policy study work group.
It's being launched.
And the first meeting will be first virtual meeting will be just the
first virtual meeting.
There will be one meeting a month through the end of the year.
The purpose of this work group is to provide support in the development of
policies and strategies.
And leadership for the state board to meet the social,
emotional behavioral and mental health needs of students and school
personnel.
In the wake of and recovery from COVID-19.
So I'm looking forward to being able to share with the board.
I'm excited about that.
I'm going to close my report by taking just a moment of personal privilege.
We all witnessed with great pain and horror.
The murder of an African-American man named George Floyd.
Every black leader.
And in fact,
every black person I know from the bond James to my own brother has tried to
make a difference in the lives of our students.
And I'm going to close my report by taking just a moment of personal
privilege.
We all witnessed with great pain and horror.
The murder of an African-American man named George Floyd.
Every black leader.
And in fact,
every black person I know from the bond James to my own brother has tried to
give some rationality or explain this cause in this problem.
I will use this pulpit to add their words because they said it better than I
could.
To the public record.
There's this thing called the black tax.
It's not an IRS thing.
It's the added burden that comes with being black in America.
It's routinely paid no matter how much education you have.
The black tax is more than the added stares,
whispers and suspicions when you're out and about.
It's about the many instances of disrespect and incivility.
Your color seems to engender and being expected to somewhat,
somehow always restrain yourself.
Lest you not be what white Americans are never asked to be a credit for the
race.
That experience includes not being afforded the same privileges as others,
as well as not being treated the same in the eyes of the law.
It's about living a life that included both of your parents growing up in
rural Mississippi and recounting childhood memories of lynchings,
the Ku Klux Klan,
the four jobs their parents were to send them to private schools in another
state.
It's about the fears that lead to decisions not to let me,
their child out of their site or the issues they had to think through and
deciding whether or not we could go away to college.
And then not being surprised when the campus police stopped and frisked my
brothers for walking or driving on campus while black.
It's the day in and day out fatigue of trying to explain the obvious to the
clueless.
It's about being asked to overlook blue failings and white failures so they
can conveniently be viewed as black issues.
It's about being asked by so many what they should do or say about race when
the easy answer lies in the privacy of each person's heart.
It's the black tax.
It's paid by me and every person of color on this panel and across the
country.
And frankly, I have been paying that tax long enough that I shouldn't have to
ask others to simply accept one basic reality that black lives matter.
Thank you.
Thank you very much, Pat.
Vice President Strauss.
Let me just say that these have been incredibly and are incredibly
challenging times for students, for their families, for teachers and
leaders.
And everybody I know in the field is working really, really hard and
everyone's tired and trying their best to do for students what students need
to be connected.
So the theme and all the liaison work that I did that I've done since the
last board meeting in May really had a whole theme of really connecting to
students, trying to help teachers, trying to build community and a lot of
collaboration.
That's the theme of all of the work.
And I think that this is our opportunity to do things differently and really
make it better and not to just tweak it, but to really shake it up.
And so I just want to say that I think that isn't all the liaison work.
I do liaison to the credentialing commission and as part of that, I'm
invited to attend the CSU California Center for Advancement of Instruction and
Quantitative Reasoning.
And while Member Rucker is the liaison for the math framework, the work that
CSU is doing with K-12 school districts is to try to help students in their math
pathways and try to get students to be successful in a fourth year of math.
And so they convened on Friday, May 8th, right after our board meeting.
And they highlighted some of the projects that are going on in the state that I
think will be really helpful and could be included in some of the strategies in
the new math framework.
But there's some exciting ways they're rethinking the fourth year of math for
students in high school in quantitative reasonings.
They're also looking at new courses that would help students who struggle with
Algebra 2, which is really a challenging course for many students or what we
call integrated math 3, depending on which district you're in.
And so the collaboration from CSU campuses and school districts, they're also
looking at ways to help teachers get supplemental authorization in computer
science, which we really need, especially as we've adopted our computer science
standards.
So I think that their resources will be really helpful and I've asked them to
make sure they connect with CDE and the IQC as far as the framework work.
Also, the core school districts, which are Fresno, Garden Grove, LA Unified,
Long Beach, Oakland, Sacramento City, San Francisco, and Santa Ana, those districts
have been together working on trying to improve school and district practice and
their core advisory meets twice a year.
They were meeting, they met on May 21st.
They have two things.
One, they're looking at night freshmen on track program to help students be
successful.
Those of us who've worked in high schools realize that you've got to really
focus on 9th and 10th graders if you're going to make sure they don't get lost
in the process to make sure they complete high school.
So they've been working with a breakthrough success community through
improvement science and they're also looking at back to school analytics,
getting students back to school.
So I think the core districts have been very helpful to us in helping to advise
some of our work around accountability and improvement of practice.
So I felt that their data tools are available and it was a really collaborative
time.
Then the California Collaborative for District Reform, that's a group one
meets three times a year with school districts and researchers.
Many Stanford faculty and they've been working for 15 or 16 years now.
I think that's part of it as well.
They worked on June 15th and 16th on the issues of reopening schools, which is
obviously a real priority for all of us.
They talked about distance learning, social, emotional, and relationship issues
leading through crisis and what the big picture presentation and several
districts presented on Long Beach Unified was actually quite impactful in their
stakeholder group and what they're sharing.
And they offer lots of resources and thoughts.
So I just think everyone is trying to put their best thoughts together.
You might know that we have and sponsored through, I see the Bechtel Foundation
that sponsors math and science collaboration in the state, the California
Partnership for Science and Mathematics.
The science collaboration meeting group met on June 8th and they're working on
professional learning, how to integrate next generation science standards and
help to build alignment.
So the CDE has reached out to the science collaboration committee and they are
helping to run some of the remote and webinars that we're offering.
So our communities of practice around the state of math and science are really
helpful in trying to improve practice in these really challenging times.
Let's see.
Then the special advisory commission, that's not normally a liaison position for
me at all, but the position is vacant.
And so I did attend June 17th to make sure that we had state board representation
there.
We have a new chair and a new vice chair, David Thompson and Havanya Hayes-White
are selected as our chair and our vice chair.
They had updates on state assessment, the annual report for special ed.
The special ed division did an update on what's happening during the coronavirus
pandemic.
And really a shout out to Marin County Office of Education.
They brought students back and they presented how they're dealing with on-site
instruction during the pandemic.
They really collaborated with community agencies.
They just been doing really quite, sharing the successes and lessons learned.
They also, at the special advisory commission, talked about the parent and family
perspective on distance learning and what that's meant.
And then a very, very heartfelt thank you to Kristen Wright for all of her
service as the state director of special ed.
When I first met Kristen almost 10 years ago, she was on the advisory commission
of special ed.
So she really has served us well.
And as you know, she's moved on to Sacramento County Office, so not too far away
and still a resource for us in special ed.
Two more.
The credentialing commission met on June 18th and 19th.
And Ida, you actually probably, Ida was sitting there because she's a commissioner.
But basically there's a lot of updates that credentialing commission has tried to
do in light of the pandemic to make sure that teachers can teach in the fall if
they didn't finish their hours because the school was closed or if they couldn't
take their test that was required because the testing center was closed.
So along with what the credentialing commission could do and along with what
governor Newsom would do with executive orders, they did everything they could
so that we would have teachers available to teach in the fall for where our
needs are.
And the credential commission is also looking at their accreditation system.
They have four years of implementation of the current system and they believe
that there's some changes and edits that need to be made.
So we'll probably be hearing more about that.
And then they're also looking at the teacher performance assessment and
comparability study between all the different assessments for youth to assess
teacher performance, TPEs, Cal, TPA, Ed, TPA, and FASTA best.
So there's lots of them and Ida might want to add any more context to this.
They also, we have a bilingual authorization workgroup that began in late May to
analyze and look at program standards.
So that's a really important issue as we continue to implement more and more
dual language programs.
And then a lot of discussion of teacher preparation programs and then handing
off to induction programs and how to support mentors with new teachers.
And there's continuing work on child development permit, which I'm sure you're
probably aware of as well.
So you might want to add to that.
I'll just add just to support, the early math symposium was amazing.
I don't know if I did my job describing it, but I believe there were over 5,000
attendees because it was remote and it was free.
We had people from all over the country and a credit to Carolyn Fister from
State Board and Fresno County office for an amazing remote conference with
full sessions, breakout rooms.
It was amazing.
And those resources are available.
But I just was so proud of the opportunity that was provided.
And then this is my last one.
The concurrence commission is the commission that is the subject matter
projects.
The subject matter projects have been very important to us in California in
providing teacher professional development.
And many of the heads of the subject matter projects actually are the
writers on our frameworks.
Like the arts writers that we have for the arts framework that we adopted
yesterday.
So we had our update remotely on what the subject matter projects are doing
and what they've been doing during the pandemic.
And they are going to be a great resource for us going forward with I think
President Graham and Hammond can share.
But just some highlights.
They're talking about subject matter projects are based at different
universities.
But because things are remote, they're actually able to reach teachers in
remote areas that didn't have access to some of the training before.
And so that's been an actual plus.
And so they've also done things like lunch groups an hour once a week at
lunchtime.
They've been doing remote trainings.
They've been doing conferences.
And so I think they're going to really help us a lot in our professional
development going forward.
And there are book talks.
And they have some new budget to address some of the learning loss,
which I'll let President Garlingham and share.
So that does end my liaison report.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
Member Sun.
Thank you.
All right.
Always a pleasure to follow.
Member Stroud here.
All right.
So the only item I really want to report on is the,
the career technical education.
I'm a liaison to that.
And the California workforce pathways,
advisory joint advisory committee is meeting tomorrow.
So we always have meet for another day after the board meetings.
We are in,
we do need an additional state board of education
representative to take the place that a member,
Felisa Ortiz-Lacon had occupied.
So we, now that we have some new board members,
we may hopefully have someone to replace her very soon.
So we are meeting tomorrow.
As this board knows,
we had approved the Perkins five federal applications.
And in May,
and that has gone through its rounds and gone through the governor's
office and has been submitted to the education department in
Washington. And they have, from what I've heard,
they have provided some feedback.
And so there's a little bit of an iterative process going on right
now.
In the meantime,
we are working on the local application for the federal for the
Perkins.
Now that we have the Perkins application done,
what the committee will now be focusing on is a couple of things.
One,
streamlining the different funding sources we have for career,
technical education.
And we have the CTIG grant.
As some of you are aware of,
we also have are working with our community,
California community college partners on the K-12
grant for, for schools as well.
And we also have now this Perkins grant.
So we're hoping to look at different funding sources and streamline this
for LEAs.
The other piece is aligning the different applications and grants
towards our guiding principles.
We have developed the guiding principles to support student centered K-14
plus pathways.
And that is going to be our foundation from which to look at applications,
look at quality programs and,
and actually also collecting data as along those elements and,
and whether our programs are making progress with student achievement along
those elements.
So that's essentially moving forward.
And we are also looking at developing more of a California plan for career
pathways.
So the Perkins application was only a federal grant application.
In that process,
a lot of additional issues and topics we need to continue to explore has come
up. And so one of which is credentialing around CTE teachers and educators.
So we'll continue working on those issues as well.
So much going on. I'll just add,
I'll add a brief couple of additions to all of that amazing reporting.
As you might imagine,
it's been very busy over the last few months legislatively as we finally got to
a negotiated budget.
And a lot of questions come to the state board staff during that time.
I just want to give a special shout out to Judy Sias and Deborah Brown and
Karen Staff Walters for all of the
ball catching that they did and contributions that they made to their
process.
We together were involved with sort of helping the various offices figure out
how we could get from here to there in terms of the kinds of strategies that
will support the schools in this very complicated time.
I gave testimony before the assembly on learning loss.
And as you saw in the budget,
there's quite a bit of legislative language about how we heard about that
over the last day or so about how districts are expected to think about a
continuity plan, how to put in place formative assessments.
We now have some guidance on that to figure out what kind of learning
strategies are needed and then have to support more accelerated.
I'm going to get rid of the thank you.
There's little things popping up on the screen.
More accelerated learning.
I think it's really important as we think about the questions and the fears
that people have about learning loss to remember a few things.
One is that kids are always learning every minute of every day as we are as
adults.
And so the question is how do we organize what they're learning in a way
that will move them forward in the curriculum.
But there's clearly huge inequalities that emerged during this time because
some kids were in context where there was just a great deal more ready support
than was available for other kids.
And it will be very important to pick up the phrase that member Rucker used
around asset based instruction,
which is one of the ways that our math frameworks folks are thinking about it
that we go into the school year with asset based instruction in mind rather
than identifying deficits and labeling kids as below and behind and sticking
them off into remedial courses where they do drill and kill, you know,
around, you know, getting ready for test scores in the spring.
We really need to figure out where they are in their, you know,
along the learning progressions in reading and writing and mathematics and
quantitative reasoning and so on, using good formative assessments,
activating the learning resources that are available to them,
helping them see what they can do, what their strengths are,
using those strengths to move them with accelerated progress.
We will get much, much further that way than we will if we go into the school
year with a deficit orientation about the kids.
So we've been working hard on trying to put the tools together and the
framework together that help people think about coming back to school,
welcoming students, also piggybacking on member Rucker's comment about the
National Association of State Boards of Education social emotional learning
workgroup, which I'm working with NASB on.
The social emotional elements of this are going to be very, very important.
So that's been a very big theme in the work that the department's been doing.
The CCE and the state board is figuring out how to provide the tools or
resources for that way of coming back to school.
I hope everyone will spend the first couple of weeks really welcoming kids
and helping them create a community, whether it's online or in person,
enabling them to share what their experiences have been in private ways,
as well as in, you know, communitarian ways,
and then figuring out how to help each of them move forward.
And I finally would like to just close by also thanking member Rucker for
calling us in to the conversation about what's been happening in the civil
rights arena.
George Floyd was not the only African American man murdered by police just in
that little window of time.
Breonna Taylor, Tony McDade, Rayshard Brooks, we could go on with the naming.
The broader equity issues have been focusing particularly on issues of
policing, and we've had a lot of conversation about policing in schools.
But we do also have to take up the ways in which systemic racism has led to
tracking in schools, a lack of qualified teachers in the schools serving
students of color, which, by the way, about four times as many
uncredential teachers are in schools serving predominantly students of
color, the weaker curriculum that's often available.
So those are on our plate as members of the state board.
And while we think about the issues of policing and of safety and of the
treatment of adults and children in our society, we should also be thinking
about the ways in which we can dismantle the systemic racism that still exists
in our systems.
So on that note, I will close out this part of our agenda.
I would like to ask, there's some screen that keeps coming up.
Whoever is inadvertently sharing their screen, try to be alert to that so
that we can continue to see each other.
With that, we're going to go into our public hearings.
And we're going to have three public hearings today, items 19, 20, and 21.
Spanish translators are available for these items during the public comment
period.
If the comments you would like to make are in Spanish for items 19, 20, and
21, please use the same phone number and access code provided on the
PowerPoint slide and inform the phone operator that you need a Spanish
English translator so that your comments can be translated.
Members of the public wishing to dial in for public comment should view the
live stream of the meeting to know at what time we'll be asking for public
comment for each item on the agenda.
A public comment may be provided by dialing the phone number and participant
access code and then following each of the prompts.
And then upon dialing in, callers will be added to a caller queue.
The operator will notify callers when it is their turn to provide public
comment.
We will also ask the public calling in for public comment to please turn
down the speaker volume of their computers if they're following the live
feed to avoid an echoing effect.
There is a delay between the live feed, between what we're doing and the
live feed and what people receive.
So we're trying to accommodate for that delay also in the way that we get
people into the queue and able to comment.
Public comment will be limited to one minute for each speaker.
For board members, please mute your microphones when you're not speaking and
keep your cameras on at all times except during the scheduled breaks to
ensure that we maintain a quorum throughout today's virtual meeting.
I saw that yesterday when people had to leave for a few minutes, they put that
notice in the chat box.
Thank you for doing that.
I think that's a good practice to continue if you need to excuse yourself
for a couple of minutes from the meeting.
For each item on the agenda, there will be an opportunity for you to raise
your hand using the Zoom participant window if you'd like to ask a question
or make a comment.
I think pretty much everybody figured that out yesterday, so congratulations
to you.
We'll continue to build on our success and take an assets-based approach to
our board meeting this morning.
Item 19 is a public hearing regarding the petition for the establishment of
a charter school under the oversight of the State Board of Education, the
PIME Community School, which was denied by the Montebello Unified School
District and the Los Angeles County Office of Education.
The CDE recommends that the State Board hold a public hearing to deny the
Time Community School petition.
This item will be presented by Stephanie Farland of the CDE.
Stephanie, please begin.
We don't see you yet, but I'm hoping you're there.
So, Linda, they're changing over here, so you need to give us a minute.
Okay.
This is a day for technology.
Apparently so.
It is a technology day.
So we will take a few minutes.
Why don't we take a five-minute break and let people get their coffee or
whatever, and we'll come back at around 950 and hope that everything is ready
to roll.
Great.
Thank you.
Okay.
But I announced the break, so we'll take the break.
Get your coffee.
Finally ready for takeoff.
Okay.
So, good morning, President Darling-Hammond, board members, Chief Deputy
Gregson.
Today we are, right now we are going through item nine, which is a petition
for the establishment of Time Community School.
Stephanie, you meant item 19, correct?
I'm sorry, did I say nine?
I'm sorry.
Item number 19.
Time Community School, with Time as an acronym, Teamwork Individualization,
Mastery and Extension Community School, is seeking authorization from the
State Board to establish a grade nine through grade 12 charter school within
the boundaries of the Montebello Unified School District.
The petitioners previously saw authorization through Montebello and LA
County Board of Education.
They were denied by Montebello Unified on October 23, 2019.
They went on to Los Angeles County Board of Education where they were denied
on January 14, 2020, and they appealed to the State Board on March 6, 2020.
The CDE recommends that the State Board hold a public hearing to deny the
request to establish TCS, a grade nine through grade 12 charter school,
under the oversight of SBE.
The time petition was considered at the June 9, 2020 Advisory Commission on
Charter Schools.
The ACCS moved to approve the TCS petition with a delay in opening for one
year and with the understanding that TCS would be in operation for four years.
They moved that vote on a vote of seven to two.
The department's basis for recommendation of denial is that the petitioner is
demonstrably unlikely to successfully implement the intended program,
and the petition does not provide reasonably comprehensive descriptions of
all required 15 charter elements.
A little background on this school, their mission is to develop pupils'
academic, social, and political skill sets necessary for lifelong learning,
critical thinking, and positive contributions to the community in which
they live.
They intend to open in 2021, 2020 to 2021, that always messes me up a little,
with 110 pupils in grade nine and grow to serve 600 pupils in grades nine through
12 by 2024-25.
It is a college preparatory program.
So the findings from the California Department of Ed.
I would like to, you'll see this similar slide in all of our appeals, as we
mentioned yesterday, because of the impact of the COVID-19 pandemic and the
variations in the governor's proposed January budget, the proposed May revision,
and what we finally got in the actual budget that he signed in this month.
So I just want to reiterate, sort of after yesterday's conversation, I want to
review how we analyze budgets in the charter schools division.
Petitioners send in their budgets with their appeal.
We take their budget numbers and their projections and we do our own analysis
of it to determine if a school will be fiscally viable and remain so.
This is what you see in the items.
So we do take their numbers, we do our own analysis, and what you see in our item
is our analysis of that.
You can see their own budget numbers through the petition that they submitted
and any other materials that they submit up to the meeting day.
We are consistent with how we review budgets and fiscal projections to ensure
we are being fair.
It is understandably confusing right now because of everything going on and its
effect on our state budget.
So just as a little background so we're not confused when we have conversations
and when charters are having their time, their 10-minute time, we did ask all of
the schools for a new budget after the May revise was released.
This was before the ACCS meeting.
We did an analysis of that budget.
We did an analysis of the May revise budget.
You don't see that in the state board items because the May revise projected
budget no longer exists and it's not what we ended up with with the state budget
that was signed.
So that is why you don't see that and that's why there was some confusion yesterday.
We did do an analysis of the time budget.
After the May revise and we found that they were fiscally unviable.
Since then, as you know, the state budget has been approved without the immediate
budget cuts but with deferrals.
We went back to the original budget time submitted as we did for all of the charter
appeals before you yesterday and today.
We went back to their original budget submitted with their appeal petition.
And while, and I'll move on a little bit.
So while they are viable for the first year, not with the reserves that the state
board recommends or requires, but they are viable for the first year and their
viability is predicated on a lot of borrowing and no startup costs.
When we originally reviewed their budget, there was, they had no startup costs
that they projected to have.
So that was a big issue for us.
To be fiscally solvent, the petitioner needs to rely upon heavy borrowing, which can
be exacerbated by the new budget deferrals.
And as I said a minute ago, they do not maintain the appropriate level of reserves
for their first year of operation.
So while we understand that many charters start off this way with heavy borrowing,
it seemed irresponsible to recommend for approval with the information we had and
with the knowledge that we don't know where we're going to go in the next year or
two in terms of state budgeting and what districts and charter schools will be
receiving from the state budget.
Also, the petition does not provide a reasonably comprehensive description of the
following.
Element two, measurable pupil outcomes, 10 suspension and expulsion procedures,
and 14 dispute resolution procedures.
With measurable pupil outcomes, they do plan to reside within the Montebello Unified
School District, which is comprised of 25,000 pupils, 85% identify as
socioeconomically disadvantaged, 33% identify as English learners, and 0.8%
identify as foster youth.
The petition does not outline measurable pupil outcomes that address increases in
pupil academic achievement, both school-wide and for all groups of pupils,
which is a requirement.
Suspension and expulsion procedures and dispute resolution procedures.
The petition does not include all the necessary language required for each of the
charter elements that we traditionally recommend and require.
So the CDE recommends that the SBE deny the petition to establish time, as they
are demonstrably unlikely to successfully implement the program and they do not
provide reasonably comprehensive descriptions of all required elements.
So in this particular case, which this next bullet is a little different than what
we have seen in the past with the State Board of Education.
If the State Board decides after their deliberation to approve the time community
school petition, the Los Angeles County Board of Education has agreed to be its
authorizer under Ed Code section 47605K1, which is the Ed Code section which allows
for the State Board to request that a local agency take over the oversight of a
State Board approved school.
In the L.A. County, we did ask the L.A. County Office of Education and they have
agreed to that.
And that is the conclusion.
And I will put up the screen for call in.
Public comment.
Thank you very much, Stephanie.
Okay.
So we are going to now I'm going to open the public hearing at 10 o'clock a.m.
First we'll hear from the petitioners.
The petitioners will have 12 minutes.
Then we'll hear from the district and county that are opposing the petition.
They'll also have a total of 12 minutes after the presentation from both sides.
There will be an opportunity for public comment from any individual who is not
already presented for one minute each.
So I'll invite the petitioners to come to the podium.
Thank you very much.
And maybe we can take the public comment slide down so they can show whatever
they have to say.
Good morning, President Darling-Hammond, members of the board, Superintendent Thurmond.
My name is Dr.
Gabriel Ramirez and I am honored to have this opportunity to speak with you about
Time Community Schools, the highly qualified team that created and will lead it,
the students of Montebello who will benefit from the school and the innovative
elements of our petition.
Time Community Schools has one fundamental goal, to educate the historically
underserved high school students by providing an innovative model of learning
and better social justice.
I'd like to begin by sharing a little bit about my background and that of my
board.
I am a first-generation Latino college graduate committed to improving my
community through education.
I have been in education for 20 years as a nationally board-certified teacher,
an administrator, and a director at the university level.
As a teacher, I delivered culturally relevant and engaging lessons, maintained
high standards for my students that resulted in their ability to perform above
school and district averages.
In other words, I decided to develop a charter school designed to address the
inequities in education.
For me, my involvement in education is not simply a career choice.
It is my life's work to provide what I believe is a fundamental right to all
children, a quality education that leads them to achieve their dream and life
goals.
The TCS board is comprised of highly successful individuals.
Every member of the team overcame systems of race, gender, and or income
inequality.
We can each personally attest to inequity and justice and lack of access,
resulting in a difficult and challenging road to success.
Fortunately, each member can point to a mentor and or teacher who inspired and
guided them, a gift they intend to pay forward to TCS students.
Each board member individually and collectively is adept at deconstructing
problems and offering thoughtful and practical solutions.
Most importantly, they are able to transfer their undeniable professional
talent and skill to education.
Lamar Brown, TCS board president, is an expert in marketing and community
outreach.
He chose to leave a Fortune 500 company so he could use his skills at the
university to help recruit students of color so they too could benefit from
higher education.
In addition to his broad oversight as a board member, he will lead the
monitoring and evaluation of our outreach and recruitment initiatives.
As a teacher, administrator, and lawyer, Brandy Price, TCS board vice
president and founding board president, has devoted her life to those who have
been marginalized and disenfranchised.
She will bring her vast experience to educational leadership, policy,
curriculum, and instruction.
Adrian Enriquez, TCS board treasurer, owns a mortgage company and is a co-owner
of United Trust Escrow.
He is committed to developing and supporting TCS to ensure that the school
has the fiscal resources needed to operate its innovative model.
Alexandra Soto, TCS board secretary, is a second generation Montebello business
owner who has been highly engaged in revitalizing the Montebello community
with a focus on business and education.
Her status in Montebello will continue to support the development of partners
for our student internships.
Lastly, Dr. Jorge Moreno has been practicing integrative medicine for 20
years and is chief medical officer of the Center for Wellness located in
Montebello.
Dr. Moreno's science background and connections throughout the community
provide leadership that will support our holistic culture of social justice
that will be rooted in educating the mind, body, and spirit.
Clearly, this team is exceptional.
We know that our backgrounds and stories will matter to our students and
combined with a high quality education can be used to guide them to achieving
their dreams.
TCS will prepare students by providing meaningful choices that reflect real
interests and that lead to fulfilling lives.
Our target population resides within the boundaries of Montebello Unified and
is 95% Hispanic.
Only 30% of MUSD students graduate meeting University of California A3G
requirements.
This means that only one in three Montebello district students are even
eligible to apply to a CSU or UC after finishing high school.
Only 44% of MUSD high school students meet ELA standards and only 13% meet the
math standards on CASP.
And to further add context, according to census data, only 10% of adults within
the Montebello community over 25 have earned a bachelor's degree.
This means that if TCS is approved, most of our graduates will be the first in
their families to go to college.
Our mission is to provide a college preparatory program to students in grades
9 through 12 that will develop the academic, social, and political skill sets
necessary for lifelong learning, critical thinking, and positive contribution to
the communities in which students live.
Our vision is to positively impact all facets of society.
Research from the past 20 plus years overwhelmingly attests that students need
an engaging and rigorous curriculum, instruction that is individualized, a
positive socially just school culture, qualified and caring staff, and a sense
of belonging.
We will use project-based learning because studies repeatedly show its
benefits.
Our project-based curriculum is designed to encourage students to become
passionate about learning by taking CTE courses that help prepare them for
college while exploring career paths, making them both college-ready and
career-ready.
We will use career-based classes and internships because we know that real
world scenarios not only help students better master content but also fosters
the intrinsic motivation needed to become successful at learning.
In addition, our courses are all UCA through G approved and our graduation
requirements ensure that students are UC CSU eligible at the time of
graduation.
Briefly, the time learning model has four components supported by research and
best practices.
These components are teamwork, individualization, mastery, and
extension.
Combined, they support a student's development towards mastery of content and
the ability to problem solve.
They develop the right habits of mind essential to being successful in any
environment.
Whether a student is gifted, an English learner, or has an IEP, the time
learning model provides for differentiated instruction, maintains rigor,
and individualizes the learning experience.
TCS is prepared to provide all students a free and appropriate public education.
On a personal note, my son had an IEP throughout his K-12 education, and so I
have personal experience as a teacher, administrator, and a parent.
My son is now 22 years old in college and a success story.
As the ED and principal, I am well informed and positioned to provide
appropriate leadership and support to my team to benefit students and to work
effectively with families and providers.
TCS is working with the LAC charter to ensure that students are identified and
served fully and has developed a budget to support a special education teacher
slash coordinator and contracted services.
Approximately 95% of our students will be Hispanic and approximately 20% will be
English learners.
After enrollment, TCS will conduct initial and annual identification and
assessment of primary and second language fluency, provide classroom support,
and employ effective communication strategies with parents slash guardians of
ELs.
Lastly, TCS is committed to serving foster and homeless youth and LGBTQ
students through support built into the time learning model, accompanied with
thorough and comprehensive training for administrators and teachers in alignment
with the McKinney-Vento Act and AB 490, allowing teachers and students to
develop close interpersonal relationships during which students' individual needs
and challenges can be addressed.
The environment that we have designed does not allow students to slip through
the cracks because of academic or emotional issues.
Rather, we have created an educational system that ensures that all students are
acknowledged and supported so that they may develop the strength of character to
advocate for their own success.
At the ACCS Commission meeting, the CDE staff stated they would have recommended
approval had it not been for the Governor's May revised proposal.
In its report to you, the CDE expresses some concern now about pre-opening
funding and the effects of deferrals.
So let me explain our plan that addresses those concerns.
Clearly, we, as does the ACCS, believe that it is ill-advised to open this year at
this late date and with the uncertainties of COVID-19.
But had timing permitted, we would have responded to the impact of deferrals and
reopening costs through requesting a deferral exemption, through utilizing charter
school loans and through receivables, which are common practices in the charter
world.
If we are approved for opening in 2021, we would use the coming year as a
development year to pursue startup grants.
The Walton grant invited TCS to apply as a result of a recommendation by Great
Public Schools Now, which gave us a $50,000 development grant.
Recently, we have submitted the Walton grant application.
Also, we were awarded the PCSGP grant in 2018, but was unable to access due to
district denial.
We will apply for the PCSGP grant again during its next cycle.
Lastly, the TCS Board is actively pursuing private grants and currently speaking with
several organizations who are interested in donating academic services and our
funds upon approval.
Our fiscal approach is conservative, and we will maintain this approach to ensure
our long-term viability.
We approach the budget as we have approached all components of school design with
great intentionality and purpose, consulting with our back office provider and
establishing full TCS Board approval.
We are thankful that the CDE finds our innovative academic program to be
educationally sound, our budget to be viable and sustainable, and our team to be
successful at implementing the program.
Montebello students need TCS.
The challenges facing our Hispanic students have impeded them for generations.
Every day that we do not address inequity, another dream is dismissed and
squandered.
The pandemic has highlighted and exacerbated these disparities.
This crisis has made it clearer than ever that our students need innovative schools
to help reform and reimagine a system that currently does not serve them well.
The ACC has voted seven to two to recommend approval of TCS.
We ask today that the SBE vote to approve Time Community Schools.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
We now want to hear from the district and county.
Good morning, I'm representing the county.
I can go, I can yield to the district to go first.
Go ahead, since you're up.
Okay, let me share up here really quickly.
Okay, am I projecting?
Yes.
Okay, great.
Good morning, honorable board president, board members, SBE staff and community.
My name is Darrell Brown and I will be presenting the Los Angeles County Office of Education
Findings on Time Community School.
The county board found that the petitioners are demonstrably unlikely to successfully
implement the proposed educational program.
While the staff report included additional findings, the county board took action based
solely on finding two in the area of finance.
The California Code of Regulations identifies four indicators to determine whether a
petitioner is able to successfully implement instructional design as stated in the charter
petition.
The Los Angeles County Board based its finding of denial on one of the four
indicators.
The county board found that the petitioners presented an unrealistic operational and
financial plan for the proposed charter school.
During the time of submission, at the time of submission, the school only had $190 in
their bank.
They also submitted a letter of intent to sell receivables.
However, that letter did not include an annual percentage rate, which impacted our fiscal
analysis.
And lastly, the petition calls for a very unique facilities design and at the time of
submission, the petitioner had not yet identified a facility to meet that particular design.
Our fiscal analysis concluded that to be solvent, the budget plan will require the school to
one, secure facility that does not exceed the school's budget, two, to meet its average
daily attendance, which would be 94%, and three, to meet its enrollment projections,
which projected at 110 students in year one and growing to 600 students by year five.
In conclusion, the county board found that the petitioners are demonstrably unlikely to
successfully implement the proposed educational program.
Thank you.
Any other questions?
Well, thank you to the State Board of Education and the State Superintendent of Public
Instruction for giving us some time to share our findings regarding the Time Community
School petition.
My name is Kaven Yun.
I'm the Assistant Superintendent of Educational Services with the Montebello Unified School
District, and we are recommending to the State Board to deny the Time Community School
petition.
We evaluated the Time Community School and firmly believes that it fails to meet the
criteria set forth under education code.
There are two areas that the district is highly concerned about in the petition.
Number one is the support for the English learners and compliance with state laws for
English learners, and two, support for students with disabilities and compliance with state
laws for students with disabilities.
English learners and students with disabilities are two of the most vulnerable populations
student groups in the Montebello Unified School District as well as in California.
And this presentation just shows a timeline of the events that took place with the Time
Community petition.
So summary of findings.
In the area of English learner instruction, there are concerns.
The Montebello Unified School District has about 33% English learners and their needs are
great.
In the review of Time's petition, we found, one, that it does not meet the legal requirement
for monitoring reclassified fluent English proficient students.
The petition states reclassified students' progress will be monitored for two years, but
RFEP students should be monitored for four years.
In addition, it does not include metrics for the redesignation of English learners.
While the petition does state the types of assessments to be administered, it does lack
the scores and or performance levels that would constitute redesignation.
And three, there's no clear delineation of when designated and integrated English language
development is provided and how.
It was also not clear how students will be provided designated English language development
during the school day that is aligned to the ELD standards and LPAC scores.
And we know that in California, English learners must receive both designated and integrated
ELD until reclassification, and this petition does not make that clear.
In the area of special education, the petition's description regarding the charter services
to the students with disabilities is insufficient.
It does not explain how the charter school will provide special education and related
services to its students in the event the SELPA does not accept it as a member.
There is no reference to extended school year and whether it will be available.
There's also no discussion of transition requirements for special education students.
And it also improperly asserts that low achieving students will undergo the student success
team within the framework of the response to intervention process prior to requiring
the charter school to assess them.
In addition for most vulnerable student groups who are English learners and with a disability,
the description of the individualized education plan team fails to include a participant
who possesses the requisite expertise in language acquisition for students duly identified
as both a student with special need and an English learner.
The special education plan included in the position does not indicate how the charter
will meet the needs of students with disability who have moderate to severe disabilities
or who require an alternative curriculum.
And finally, the petition is also flawed with respects to its discussion of measurable
pupil outcomes of the three goals listed in the petition.
Two cannot be measured and one does not relate to educational pupil outcomes at all.
The suspension expulsion plan does not address alternative methods of correction or restorative justice.
There is also no mention of physical education, which is a two year requirement in California.
So overall, there are numerous issues with the petition justifying its denial more than
the district could identify here and now.
And that like Montebello Unified School District urges the State Board of Education to deny
the time community charter school petition.
So we conclude with that presentation.
Thank you for your time.
Thank you very much.
At this point, I think we're going to go to public comments.
So we want to open the phone line for the public comment queue and we should put the
public comment slide back up there.
Members of the public wishing to provide comment on this item may do so by calling
712-432-0075.
And is somebody putting the slide back up?
Yes, they're putting the slide back up.
There we go.
And then entering access code 651905 pound.
Wait for the operator prompts to press star six.
Then another prompt to press one to enter the queue.
And do we have any public comments?
We have several public comments right now.
All right.
Thank you.
I guess I should say that we encourage you to state your name and affiliation for the
record.
Turn down your volume on your computer if you're listening to the live feed.
Speakers will be limited to one minute each.
And is the translator there to provide the instructions in Spanish for callers needing
translation of their input?
Yes, the translators are on.
Okay.
I will be the translator taking the first question.
I am ready.
Can you guys hear me okay?
Yes, we can.
Very well.
All right.
Are we ready for our first public caller?
Can we please get the Spanish translation of the public comments before we start?
Do you want to hear the instructions in Spanish?
Yes.
Translator, can you please read the instructions for callers in Spanish?
Absolutely.
For the public hearing, if you can please call the phone number 712-432-0075.
You will be asked for the access code 651-905 and the number key.
Listen to the message and when indicated, press an asterisk 6 and when indicated again,
press 1.
When it is your turn, an operator will ask you to say your name and affiliation in English
and your intervention will begin.
Your turn starts now.
Say it.
My name is represento and I need a translator.
Okay.
Let's resume public comment.
First caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record and begin speaking.
Your time starts now.
Hi.
I am a founder of Tom community schools.
Hello.
Your time starts.
Go ahead.
Good day.
I am a filmmaker with the LA based production company known for Sundance, winter, the birth
of a nation.
I am currently a writer producer director for our latest film project.
I am a co-founder of the Cleveland police working with the foundation.
I reside in Atlanta.
I am original time community schools founder and I worked with the youth policy institute
and Camino Nuevo schools.
I have to stress that time addresses a great need in the educational school system.
Touching the underserved communities of color to provide lasting impact that is so important
especially in these times of racial arrest and racial wrecking.
Thank you so much.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record and begin speaking.
Your time starts now.
Hi.
My name is Jorge Moreno.
I am a parent.
I am a parent, physician, board member of time community schools, a business owner,
and a Manabella resident for over three decades.
My wife and I have raised our seven children in Manabella.
We have been working together for more than a decade.
We have had the privilege of enrolling our children in private schools.
This choice is not available to the majority of our community in Manabella.
School choice is just unrealistic.
Time community schools offer school choice to families regardless of their income.
As a 30-year resident and Manabella business owner, our network is vast and solid.
Our team is well equipped with a broad array of resources.
We have connections to Rio Hano Community College and just a vast array of individuals and businesses.
And I'm thrilled to know that time community schools is here to make a positive difference in our community.
I urge you to vote in favor of our charter petition.
Thank you so much.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
Your time starts now.
I'm sorry, I'm on the queue for item 20.
Okay, we'll need you to call back when we're accepting public comment for item 20.
Sorry, thank you.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record and begin speaking.
Your time starts now.
I'll also send the list that Jackie, I believe, or Candice sent out, or was it Sandra, of what insurances do accept that we have,
We have insurance companies that do accept hospice patients.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record and begin speaking.
Your time starts now.
And board president of the Center for Elders Independence.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record and begin speaking.
They're a PACE program.
Caller, you have the wrong number, please.
We need you to hang up.
Caller, you have the wrong number.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record and begin speaking.
Your time starts now.
Hello?
We can hear you. Please begin your comment.
Yeah, I'm also for item number 20.
Okay, we will need you to call in when we are accepting public comment when it is announced that we are accepting public comment for item 20.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record and begin speaking for item 19.
Your time starts now.
Good morning. My name is Doug Paszkowski. I'm here for the Montebello Teachers Association.
I do want to thank you for your hard work supporting our students, and I do recommend that you follow the CDE recommendation to deny this charter appeal.
We do have alternatives in our district. We have the Advanced Technology Center, which provides pathways for our students.
There are some major problems with the time charter. First of all, it did apply two years ago as well.
They had never found a location. They do consider co-locating with the Advanced Technology Center, which would be a problem because they only have space in the foyers.
They also have some major problems with finances. As Lako said, they had $190 in the bank, and they were recommended by the commission just because they promised that they were going to fill out an application for a grant.
That's not enough. They don't have the funding to start a school. They don't have a place to start a school, and they're not ready to get a school started.
Thank you so much.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record and begin speaking. Your time starts now.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record to provide public comment for Item 19. Your time starts now.
Lorraine Richards, Community Parent.
Hello?
We can hear you. Please provide your comment.
Okay. Lorraine Richards, Community Parent. I'm speaking to deny the applicant. I attended Montebello High School, which gave me an opportunity as a first-generation Latina to a four-year college, then continue to earn my teaching credential and obtain a master's.
I attended MUSD from kinder through 12th grade, which did not hinder my education. I'm a parent of MUSD children. My daughter, a second-generation Montebello High School graduate with a 504, currently completed her first year at a four-year college who earned two semesters of straight A's at the university and my son beginning eighth grade.
The current applicant, Time, claims to be a better solution for students, although the poor financial stability of charter is not acceptable. Claiming to apply for a grant that has not been earned is not enough. A quality 21st education has a large budget.
Time gives the whole family, the whole community, a false hope. MUSD is overcoming previous financial mismanagement. The whole family and whole family will not endure another education model that is stricken by financial strife. Please deny this petition. Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record and begin speaking. Your time starts now.
Hi, can you hear me? Yes, we can hear you. Please begin your public comment.
Hi, my name is Tavina Quintana. I am an employee of Montebello Unified School District and I'm just calling in because of listening to the gentleman from Time Charter.
We do not need any more schools in our district. We have plenty of options. Our graduates are doing amazing things. All the employees are happy with what we have. We don't need any charter schools coming in and trying to take more of our funds than our students, which we're struggling with now.
I just want to say that I hope you guys deny the petition. Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record and begin speaking. Your time starts now.
Hello, did you wish to provide public comment for item 19?
My name is Vale Hernandez De Luna and I'm representing today's first charter school. I attended TFSS for three years. This school has changed me academically for the best.
I'm sorry, excuse me. We're taking public comment for item 19 at this time. We'll need you to call back when we're accepting public comment for item 20.
Thank you.
For today's fresh start. Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record and begin speaking. Your time starts now.
Good morning. My name is Lizette Romero and I'm here to lend my support for Time Community Schools. 16 years ago, I was a senior in Dr. Ramirez's English class. He was an amazing teacher who created a student centered class that validated the voices and experiences of a student.
Some of my best memories of high school come from the assignments, community projects, and activities he spearheaded. Dr. Ramirez has had a direct impact on who I am today. I'm proud to say that this year I'm receiving my credential in special education.
I've committed myself to helping those students who need the most support as I know Dr. Ramirez has committed himself as well. Also, I'm a parent and I'm excited to say that I want my child to attend Time Community Schools because I know he will receive the kind of education that I'm looking for.
Rigorous, engaging, and student centered. I ask the State Board of Education to vote yes because the Montebello community needs this school. Thank you for your time.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record and begin speaking. Your time starts now.
Hi, my name is Lamar Brown, co-founder of Time Community Schools and president of the board. I'm currently a change management and communications lead at the Top UC School. As a board member, I will work to ensure the school's success, particularly in the areas of student enrollment and community outreach, areas in which I have developed expertise.
In these unprecedented times, it is more important than ever to find safe and innovative ways to connect and build relationships with families. I will continue to provide Dr. Ramirez with strategies and best practices to engage all families with the goal of ensuring that TCS school's population is a reflection of the diversity of Montebello community.
I am honored to be a part of this highly capable team that is intent on equity and outstanding results. Today is a clear sign of our dedication and relentless focus to bring Montebello an innovative school not to ensure student success. I urge you to approve our petition. Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record and begin speaking. Your time starts now.
Hi, Ramel Antoine from the California Charter Schools Association, calling to speak in support of San Charter School. We want to say that this petition is a high quality petition. They have worked with our staff at the Charter Schools Association to ensure that they're implementing best practices and have a high quality document that meets the legal requirements.
We also want to say that the PDE did say at the HCCS that they would have likely recommended approval if it weren't for the projected budget cuts, but instead now are concerned with the projected startup funds. With SB 98, that would allow them more time to plan. They would have more than ample time to raise the funds.
Additionally, they have found suitable facilities that would house the school once they're able to open. And we want to say we recommend our support for San Charter School. Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record and begin speaking. Your time starts now.
Hello, can you hear me? Hello? Yes, we can hear you. Your time has started.
My name is Carlos. I'm urging you to please reject the time community school application. Mr. Ramirez and his associates have offered a very poorly developed educational program that would greatly affect the very same students that we want.
Can you please get closer to your phone or microphone? Yes. Is that better? That's much better. Thank you. We'll respect your time.
Oh, thank you. So my name is Carlos. Good morning. I'm urging you to please reject the time community school application. Mr. Ramirez and his associates have offered a very poorly developed educational program that would greatly hurt the very same students they say they want to help.
It was abundantly clear that time community schools rushed together a poorly developed academic plan to open up the school with very little awareness of the community or how to properly run a school and more importantly, how to educate students.
Their plan from the get-go has had many flaws and it failed to meet 9 out of 15 original educational guidelines to open a charter school. They have no expertise in their educational program.
They have no experience in managing a charter school. They presented an incomplete academic program to the Montebello school board.
They had no answer to how to address students with special needs or English learners leaving behind vulnerable populations.
Please consider the best interest of the Montebello Unified Community and reject their application. Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record and begin speaking. Your time starts now.
Hi, this is Angela DeRamos representing the California Teachers Association.
CTA recommends that the State Board of Education vote to deny the petition for the establishment of time. The association opposes time's petition for the following reasons.
They are fiscally unable, unsustainable given their lack of startup funds and the current state budget uncertainties.
Secondly, the petition does not contain reasonably comprehensive description of most of the required elements, including the item on pupil outcomes, on suspension and expulsion procedures, as well as dispute resolution procedures.
We urge you to deny this petition. Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record and begin speaking. Your time starts now.
Caller, did you wish to make a public comment for item 19?
Hello? Yes, we can hear you. Please state your name and affiliation and begin speaking.
I'm waiting for item 21.
One moment and we'll get you a translator.
Okay. Thank you.
Translator, can you please announce when you're on the line?
Sir, please state your name and affiliation and begin speaking when you wish.
Sir?
Hello, am I on the queue? My name is Christine Dimas.
Is our call manager here?
Did you hear that?
Hi, my name is Christine Dimas. I am a stakeholder in the Montebello Unified School District.
I'm recommending that you deny time charter. They sound very well-meaning.
However, the financial aspect of this particular charter is not in place for our community.
Our community has already suffered enough corruption based on what's been happening in the news with regards to Measure GS bond money.
We're still recovering. We do not need another organization or entity coming into our district ill-prepared to not just financially, but to teach our children. Thank you.
We have no additional callers in the queue at this time. We do have an additional 17 callers that are on the line that it appears may not have entered the queue.
We're going to check with them to see if they would like to provide public comments.
Thank you.
Hello, caller. Please state your name. I'm sorry. Would you like to provide a public comment for item 19?
Hello, caller. Would you like to provide a comment for item 19?
Please understand this is for item 19. If you've called in for another item, we respectfully ask that you hang up at this time and call back following the item when it's presented.
This is only for item 19 and callers should only be on the line for item 19. Thank you.
Hello, caller. Did you wish to make a comment for item 19?
Hello, caller. Would you like to make a comment for item 19?
Hello, caller. Would you like to provide a comment for item 19?
Next caller, would you like to provide a public comment for item 19?
Good morning. Can you hear me?
Yes, we can hear you. Would you like to make a comment for item 19?
Yes, yes. I'm calling in support of Time Charter Schools. Good morning. My name is Gabby Hernandez and I am a Montebello resident and a mother of two.
And based on my experiences and what I have witnessed with my own children and based on the data that I have read, the city of Montebello is in need of an alternative, innovative high school option for our families and students, one that is more career-based, hands-on, that's based on our students' interests.
I believe Time Charter will provide a more college-focused preparation program where students can actually begin to explore their interests and put their skills and strengths to use.
Time Charter's innovative teaching approach will better prepare our students for their future careers and will allow them to work in collaboration with teachers and other professionals within our community.
Our students deserve this opportunity to be better prepared for their futures. They deserve this opportunity to have access to better support systems.
I fully support Time Charter School. Please vote in favor of Time Charter School. Thank you for your time.
Thank you.
Next caller, did you wish to provide a public comment for item 19?
Hello caller, did you wish to provide a public comment for item 19?
Hello caller, would you like to provide a public comment for item 19?
I already provided my comment.
Okay, we're going to disconnect you from the line at this time, okay?
Okay, thank you. Thank you.
Hello caller, would you like to provide a public comment for item 19?
Hello?
Yes, we can hear you. Did you want to provide a comment for item 19?
Can you hear me?
For Time Community School?
Translator, we need you.
Yes sir, would you like to provide a public comment for item 19?
I didn't hear how they were talking. I don't know how it is. I just wanted to say a few words about the school.
I just wanted to say that I really don't want this school to be closed.
My son goes to this school. He's in 10th grade. It's a good school. He has learned here more than I have noticed in other schools. So from my heart, I just wanted to say that I don't want this school to be closed. That was all.
Translator, can you please ask what item he's called? What school?
My name is Alejo Salinas.
What school are you calling for?
John Henry.
Thank you. We will need him to call back for John Henry. That is the next item on the agenda.
To the same number you mean?
Yes.
Yes sir.
What time would that happen?
We don't know. It will be at the conclusion of this public comment and hearing.
Probably in an hour.
I just want to be sure that everyone who's on the phone line understands that we are only taking comments for item 19, which is the time charter school in case there are others who might be queued up for a later item.
And they would call back.
Translator, could you repeat that in Spanish that everyone on the phone line should be for item 19 only?
Absolutely.
Great.
I don't know if you could clarify that people should hang up and call back if they are for another school.
If they are already in line, they should hang up and call back.
We will resume with callers in the participant queue at this time.
Next caller would you like to make a public comment for item 19?
Hello caller would you like to provide a public comment for item 19?
Hello caller, did you wish to provide a public comment for item 19?
No, thank you, but I would like to remain on the call. Thank you.
I'm sorry, we have to disconnect you right now. You'll need to call in for the item that you're providing public comments on.
I'm not providing any comment. I just want to listen in.
Okay.
Hello caller, did you wish to provide a public comment for item 19?
Yes.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record and begin speaking.
Hello. Hi, my name is Aiden Colons. I am speaking on behalf of my full today's special total academy.
I would like to request that my flow stays open to the benefit of keeping our school site open in my opinion will outlay the risk of closing out schools.
It is my belief that...
I'm sorry, caller. You'll need to call back when we're hearing your item. Right now we are accepting public comment for item 19, time community school.
Okay, have they done for today's fresh start yet?
No, we are not on today's fresh start yet. That is, we've got one more item to go after this one.
Okay, sorry about that.
No problem. Thank you.
Do we have to call back?
Yes, we will need you to call back when we are hearing public comment for item 21.
Okay, thank you.
Thank you.
Next caller, did you wish to provide public comment for item 19 for time community school?
Hello, caller. Did you wish to provide comment for item 19?
Hello, caller. Would you like to provide public comment for item 19, time community school?
Okay, you will be disconnected at this time. Thank you.
Next caller, did you wish to provide public comment for item 19, time community school?
Okay, we will disconnect you at this time. Thank you.
Are we done with public comment then?
Okay, Linda, we're finished with public comment on this item.
Didn't hear that confirmation.
All right, so we are now going to close public comment at 10 51 a.m.
And commence board discussion in action.
First, I want to ask Ting's son as our state board liaison if she has any initial comments.
Then we'll ask board members if they have any clarifying questions or comments as part of our board discussion.
Hi, Sue. Yeah, a couple of things.
In looking at the the the documentation around this particular charter,
while there have been certain comments around lack of detail in some of the areas,
I do believe that they do have a strong educational program in it.
From looking at the documents, it's just like both CDE as well as the other as the county also felt that they had provided a strong program.
In this presentation, the the presenter or the petitioner seemed to focus more on the background of the of the people on the board.
And I think that was a way to help us understand more of the folks who are part of the operations and startup of this school.
I hope that they have an opportunity to maybe go a little bit more into their educational program because I did find that it was very innovative and that it was very much a rigorous and program that supports the student population that they are targeting.
The financial piece as well, we had some discussion on the budgets as well yesterday in looking at some of the comments and the additional information that has been brought forth around the the budget.
I also feel that the petitioners have the means and the resources to start up the school.
So I will have my fellow board members ask their questions.
But I do feel that this is a this petition and the petitioners are in a good place on this particular school.
And we also have heard that the Los Angeles County Board of Education is also willing to take on the oversight of the school.
All right. Thank you very much. So we are now open for board discussion.
And let me see if I can track our participants here.
Patricia Rutgers having some technology problems. So she is going to text us and let us know if she has her hand up.
Okay, I know I also had technology problems. This is a day for those problems.
I have a request to speak from member Strauss and member Navo. So we'll start with them.
Eileen.
Eileen, are you with us? There we go. Great.
Yes, I was trying to lower my hand down to not confuse you. I apologize.
I wanted to clarify. So I'm wondering what the and maybe members and you tell me if we need the petitioner.
There was a question about the facility.
Did that get discussed and clarified? That was a question about would they be using Prop 39 and requesting facility in the Montebello Unified School District?
Or how would they plan to address the facility issue?
We should, I guess, ask the petitioner to clarify that.
Dr. Ramirez, how are you planning to find a facility? Have you identified one? What's your plan?
Yes, ma'am. Thank you for the question. So we did apply for Prop 39 to Montebello and made the request in time.
When Montebello did send their response to that, the rate that Montebello was attempting to charge us for use of facilities was way above market value.
And so for us, in terms of our desire to be fiscally sound, we decided that we had to absolutely look for private facilities to lease because it just made most sense.
So right now we are in negotiations with two facilities to lease them for the upcoming school year upon approval.
My next question, Dr. Ramirez, is I know there was a question about your plan.
By the way, I think the college ready college preparatory mission really hits the target of what the state's goals are for students.
And I appreciate the commitment. I didn't hear as much specifics about your English learner plans and your students with disabilities plans.
So I wonder if you could at least highlight for us what I know a member song said there was more there, but we didn't hear it in the presentation today.
I'd appreciate you addressing those. Absolutely. Thank you.
Thank you. So, yes. So, you know, again, I appreciate you acknowledging our program.
We are happy that it's a CTE program because we believe that that in itself is very engaging and really puts that energy and motivation to students to want to invest themselves in this curriculum, particularly for special education and EL's.
Of course, we're very committed to serving all of our students in terms of our special education.
We are, of course, working with the LAC.
We are committed to providing a robust continuum of partnerships to ensure that all the needs of our population are addressed within the.
The program itself, the way that the time learning model works, there is absolutely time for the teachers to differentiate instruction, for we will be hiring a special education teacher year one to support students.
Also, we will have instructional aids available year one as well that will be supporting students in the classrooms.
In terms of our EL program, we're very excited about our EL program as well.
Twenty percent of the population within the high school population is EL.
Our time learning model also very much integrates EL standards within the program.
Teachers will be provided SADAY training, GLAD training to ensure that students have access to content.
We will have our counselor who will be our coordinator of our EL students who will work alongside me to monitor student growth.
Of course, we'll utilize our formative and summative assessments and utilize all our different resources to ensure that students are making progress.
We will use the state designations to ensure that the students are working towards proficiency.
Thank you.
Any other questions you're good Eileen.
I'll go to member Navo.
Thank you.
I have a couple of questions for the petitioner first.
So, and I appreciate board member Strauss your question that helped took some things off of the list.
But can you address the measurable pupil outcomes, the concern around staffing, addressing students with disabilities?
I know you talked about it briefly, but what's your staffing for the year look like for 110 students?
And then can you address element 10, the concern CDE had around suspension and expulsions and the placement of students in alternative settings?
Yes, sir.
Well, in terms of the first part of the question was staffing correct for special ed.
For the whole school for 110.
That was your first year.
All staffing for year one.
Yeah, for 110 students.
Yes, so I'm all staffing for year one.
We will have, I believe.
I'm looking at right now we will have, I believe.
Five full time teachers, three part time teachers, a sped, a sped, a full time sped teacher.
We will also have instructional aid year one, and a school counselor, in addition to our support staff.
Okay, and your budget that you're that you project covers that staffing.
Absolutely, sir.
And talk to me about the measurable outcome, the element 10 suspension expulsion procedures the finding CDE has there.
We do.
So what the findings said, my understanding of the findings is saying that we do not address growth for the subgroups.
But the way that it was written, and I think it's just a matter of clarification, what we wrote is that all subgroups will increase 2% annually.
And our rationale behind that was that we we feel that all subgroups, every student within the school should have the same expectation of growth.
And so the clarification would really be that we would just need to, like, instead of saying all subgroups, the way that we listed that also was increased by 2%, just to list them out.
I think that was the point of clarification.
Okay, thank you. That's helpful. But I was talking about suspension expulsion, where they were defining is that there's an automatic placement of pupils and an interim alternative educational setting.
Contrary to Edco.
Yes, so I'll answer that the best I can and then john Lemo who is also on the line can help clarify for me.
So my understanding is that when we submitted the petition, the language was submitted for, it wasn't submitted for the county.
And so that that language wasn't wasn't changed when it was submitted to the state. So it's my understanding that it's just a technical, it's a technical correction that needs to be to be made to reflect the state language.
Okay.
And then I have a question for CDE, maybe it's for Stephanie.
Stephanie, the petitioner made a statement that in the ACCS meeting, CDE would have approved the school.
If the budget issues weren't a result of, I guess, you know, COVID-19 and the May revise and all of the implications that you mentioned. Is that true?
So the only the only decision we ever had with this particular school was for denial.
Yes, we had some serious issues with and concerns, obviously, about their ability to fiscally implement the program and to stay fiscally viable.
But if you look at our summary of required charter elements in the a one, we did also have several nos there in terms of, as you mentioned a minute ago, the people outcomes, the suspension expulsion procedures, the dispute resolution procedures.
Their goals to address the state priority. So there were other there were other issues.
But I will state that their their design their educational program design was not was not an issue.
Okay, so that that that thank you, Stephanie. And then last last question.
Okay, there are over in the correspondence folder, there are over 20 letters to deny this charter, and many of them call out a 3.2 million dollar deficit.
They're they're they're essentially the same letter and I'm trying to figure out as I look through the documents where that's coming from, and I'm assuming these are not these are incorrect.
The amount is incorrect.
We did not we did not see anything about a 3.2 million deficit. When we did our analysis of their of their fiscal.
Okay, that's that's what I needed now. Thank you.
Okay, Member Glover Woods.
Thank you. This question is either for Stephanie from CD and possibly for the representative from Los Angeles County Office of Education.
Stephanie, when you were providing the overview, you closed by mentioning that the Los Angeles County Board of Education was willing to authorize.
I wanted to get a little bit more clarification as to why they are willing to authorize when the Los Angeles County Board of Education had recommended to deny just to get some clarification on what may have changed from the time the petition was submitted to the time we're hearing the information.
So just to clarify the LA County Board is willing to take over the oversight of the school not authorize the school, the state board would still be authorizing the school if they chose to move in that direction if they chose to approve this this appeal.
And so, in that sense, they're not actually authorizing.
You know, we can we can definitely ask the county as to why they agreed to do this. My guess is that the law has changed and the school will need to go back to the local level to be approved the next time around and it often helps if, if it's already at the local level
the benefit of being the oversight provider when that renewal comes up again, but we can definitely ask the county as well.
If there are any other reasons why they why they agreed to take the oversight of the school.
Thank you, that would be helpful and I appreciate the clarification. So if the representative from Lakeville could also speak to why the decision to do the oversight that would be helpful.
Absolutely. Thank you for the question. And I think it does it yields from the change in law in which oversight would go back to a local level, either the county or the district.
And I know my director had conversations with the state Board of Education regarding that.
But that was the intent is that knowing that the law is going to have the school come back to local more just a conversation in about what's what could go for us in terms of the oversight.
Thank you.
All right, Matt your hand is still up. Are you, do you have another question.
Okay, and is now down.
I don't see any other board questions at this all member Strauss.
There you go.
I just wanted Stephanie, I'm sorry don't go away yet.
So, I just want to the issue the budget came up, I actually think the 3.5 million from the letters is probably the Montebello problem because the district itself has had some budget trouble.
I want to know from the CD analysis now, is the budget physically found, if, if we recommend going forward. Do you believe the budget plan is solid.
Stephanie. Yes, yes, I would say that the budget plan that they're that the plan that they submitted with their original petition is solid in terms of if they, if they get all of the startup money that they hope to get.
None of that, as I could see is is finalized yet. So if they get all the startup money, and if the deferrals do not impact them greatly in repaying all of the receivables they have to sell in order to stay solvent for the first couple of years.
So, if that all works out for them. Yes, I think that that they could be viable but you know those are big gifts, and we're trying to be responsible here at the department with, with the fiscal outlook, because there's so much uncertainty over the next couple of years but I would put those ifs in before the viability.
That raises a question for me and I see Brenna that you also have your hand up I'll come right to you in a moment. There was some conversation here about 2021 versus 2020.
And I want to understand whether the questions of I want to understand I guess from the petitioner whether they were proactively preferring to be considered for 2021 as opposed to 2020 or whether you were feeling like the finances were, etc were going to be adequate sooner than 2021.
And then I'd love to hear from Stephanie on that as well.
Yes.
In our budget that we submitted that we submitted we do not include any grants in that so our viability is just based on
It's not it's not based on those outside sources those those things to come in like our viability is based on what we submitted and we do have a cash reserve on the adequate crash, crash reserve cash reserve for all three years so I do want to make that part clear in regards to the
The reason why we were actively seeking a delayed opening was because our instructional calendar year is very unique. Our school was slated to open July 1, 2020. So as of as of right now we're already a week past our school start time.
And so our instructional calendar so it's so key into the way that we provide instruction, the way that we do PD, the way that we look at data. And so we really thought that it was an important element that we would like to have opportunity to start the way that we have planned for it within our petition.
Obviously, the other part of it is the COVID part that did make other elements challenging in terms of being able to open up this year. So with all that said, you know, we, we would really appreciate that opportunity to have the delayed opening.
That would be a preference. Yes, ma'am. Okay. Stephanie, do you want to have, do you have any further comment on that? No, I believe that I hope you can get this right. SB 98 allows new.
Sorry, Judy's waving at me.
Sorry, this is Judy size with the State Board of Education. The education trailer bill allows a charter school that had a scheduled opening of the 2019 2020 2021 school year to delay opening for one year without a material revision.
They just need to notify the authorizer by July 15. So it'd be up to the charter school, whether or not they want to delay opening for a year. Thank you. That's very helpful.
Um, Brenda, you were waiting.
Yes, so I have a question.
So we just heard something a little different not sure if that messes with the question I was going to ask, but if we were to agree, kind of like yesterday to the one year, waiting one year to open up and the petitioner wasn't financially still by that time and there was still
What ifs would that make this with the school might open or would it be different than different than that?
Again, it depends on the conditions that you all put aside if you do decide to vote to approve it and the conditions.
All right.
I'm not seeing any more.
Hands raised.
Do we have a motion.
I'll go ahead and make the motion to approve the charter for a term of five years. And so I need a little assistance here. Do we designate this to start, or will they just have a choice.
As we did, I think this is Judy again you can designate them to start if that's your preference.
But I believe they said that they want to delay starting so I don't I don't think it's an issue. Yeah, I think given that that their school calendar would have started already last week.
So I will, I will make the motion to approve the time community charter for a term of five years with the effect of July 1 2020 with the beginning of instruction.
And this is similar to yesterday's between July 1 and September 30 2021 gives them that option.
We will want them to produce evidence by May of 2021 of their, that they are meeting their, their perspective enrollment for ninth graders of 110 or it could be a little bit more.
For the school year.
And then that they will to address the making sure that we have a corrected budget based on current information at that time of their startup, that they would submit to the Department of Education a revised budget with the updated information so that they are able to start up for that
So I would simply remind us that we had some information from Judy science yesterday that the enrollment projections have a standard sort of confidence interval around them.
So, yes.
So, whatever I think that should be the same as what we asked yesterday. Yes, I agree to that.
Is there a second for that motion?
Ting, do you have those conditions you just read in writing that you can screen share?
I cannot because I had to switch to my iPad.
You know, I did have so many people with technology problems. I know. So I don't unless we want to take a break I could try I mean I could maybe send something to staff or something along those lines to project but
I had originally intended to do that. I just am not able to because I had to switch.
Can I clarify a question? Is there anything in the list Ting that has facility on it?
It doesn't. I did not include facilities.
It sounds like they had facilities, but we do want to make sure that the facilities would still be in place a year from now.
So we could add that to the condition. This is Judy science I think what we had yesterday was something where they would have to have a facility in place by May.
In order to allow time for CDE to conduct a pre fight inspection like they do for all the charters in time, especially since they're opening July 1st or there's calendar started July 1st. I believe I heard him say.
So we could add something that they will provide necessary facility information to CDE in order to allow time for a pre opening inspection.
Can I read back what I wrote regarding the conditions just to make sure we have them correctly Ting?
That would be very helpful. Thank you. Please.
You would move to approve the charter for a term of five years. It would be effective July 1, 2020. However, they would start instruction for the 21-22 school year.
It would be a five year term with a delayed opening. They need to produce evidence by May 2021 of their perspective and enrollment for the 21-22 school year plus or minus the 25% as we discussed yesterday.
They will need to submit to CDE a revised budget with updated information.
I think I heard May 2021 to show that it is current for the 21-22 school year.
Is that correct? We could just make it consistent May 2021. Just as they would be for their enrollment.
May 2021 so that they have a budget for the 21-22 school year. Is that correct? Yes, that's correct.
And evidence that will add in evidence that their facilities will be ready to be occupied.
Yes, they would provide evidence regarding occupation of facilities including I believe they have the occupancy permits and all of the information that is necessary for CDE to conduct a pre opening site visit.
The facility inspection. Yes, yes.
And oh, yes, and if they could also correct any of the deficiencies that were identified in the petition by CDE. Yes, that's similar to yesterday. Yes.
And then if we could set, do we want to set a date of, I don't know, May 1st or May 15th, just so everything's consistent.
For all of these, that would be May 15th. Yeah, assuming that's a weekday, especially if they're going to open July 1st. Yeah, maybe May 1st since they're opening July 1st.
Yes.
Okay, so Linda, we still need a second on that motion.
Can I also, can I also ask if we should make that under the oversight of the county or will this just happen with the county's agreement after we make the approval?
We don't need to put that in the motion. No, I think, I think it would be good to put that into the motion since that is something the board has never done.
So I think that's a good point to delegate oversight to Los Angeles County Office of Education.
And Patricia tells me May 1st is a Saturday, so we will adjust it to the appropriate Friday.
30 days, 30 days, 30 days, 30 days, 30 days.
I was trying to sing it to you. Thank you.
All right, so we're adjusting to April 30th and then we were approving with those conditions and that the school be under the oversight of the Los Angeles County Board of Education.
Okay, so assuming folks have now followed that exchange about the various conditions, is there a second for that motion?
I'll second.
Or Jim, go ahead. Jim did it.
Okay, Jim has seconded the motion. Is there further discussion?
Patricia Rucker had a question.
Okay.
How are we going to get that from her?
Can she, can she come on?
Patricia, you need to unmute.
Go ahead.
Patricia, we can't hear you.
I can hear her. Oh, you can? We can't.
How many people are hearing Patricia?
Board members can hear.
Everybody on the Zoom call can hear, but we can't hear in this CDE room. So I don't know, does that mean the public can hear or not?
I do not know.
We need a technologist.
Well, maybe Patricia could ask her question and one of us could repeat it and then. Yeah, why don't we do that? Okay, go that way.
Patricia, go ahead with your question and then I just want to acknowledge that I see Cynthia in the queue, Patricia.
I'm getting texts from friends that people cannot hear her on the live stream.
She would like to have the conditions written down so that she knows exactly what she's voting for.
Well, she also would like to make sure that the conditions address all the areas that CDE identified in the petition that were not appropriately addressed.
Right.
So I think we're going to need to get this in some way and into writing.
I don't know if somebody can.
Do you know how to like send a screenshot or something to someone there, Judy?
Ting, if you will email to Chad Owens here, I'll give you his email address and then we can put it up on the screen.
Okay.
Okay, so give me a minute to do that.
We have some more conversation.
We have a couple of other board members to take your time to do that while we hear from Cynthia and Matt.
Cynthia, you're next.
Thank you.
It was a clarification question, which actually might get clarified from the written portion of the motion that we're going to see.
But I wanted to ensure that in the motion, if there are still fiscal concerns, once the budget is submitted to CDE that that would come back to the board before moving forward.
And I'm wondering if these conditions are very much like what we looked at yesterday, whether we could simply amend those conditions and have someone put it up.
I think Judy's been keeping careful track of the conversation.
I do think that Member Rucker is asking for additional President Darling-Hammond because she wants to...
Once we get it up on the screen, we can do a checklist, right?
I believe that that list did cover virtually everything, but if there's something left out, we could talk about it when we see it.
Okay, Matt, you're next.
I tried to lower my hand.
Oh, thank you.
Board member Glover answered my asked my question and I appreciate that.
I guess I will say that, you know, I understanding the initial proposal from board member Ting.
I appreciate it.
I reluctantly will support it, but I think that the concern for me is the volume of community members that have made the effort to say they don't support the school right now.
And I think that's the challenge for me.
I'm just putting that out there and I appreciate the proposal, Ting.
Yeah, I understand.
I understand and I have to say that this is serving a specific community and I felt
badly that I believe that there would be more community support if we were in face-to-face meeting because there is a large number of Hispanic and second language
support and it is very difficult on this type of this type of public comment for a population to come in and understand when they're supposed to call in what numbers are supposed to press.
I was going to actually ask the petitioners of, you know, were there other additional members from the public who would have called in, but for the some of the technical issues with this and I felt the same way with the AC2S meeting.
This is Judy Sias. I think we can't presume who would have would not have called in or who would not have traveled up to Sacramento.
I don't just I would like to clarify that for the record. I don't think we can.
Okay.
It was a wonder for me.
Brenna, did you want to your hand went up and down.
Yeah, I had the same question.
I think what might make sense would be for us to take a brief break and allow the staff to work together to get the conditions on a piece of paper that everyone agrees to that.
We don't know whether the board will agree, but at least the motion maker and the staff agree represents the intention, and we can come back and look at that and then make our vote.
So I was thinking if we went to 1130, which was when I was estimating we might finish, I would simply call the lunch break at that time until about noon and then we would, you know, go on to the other two hearings.
So I guess the question is, how quickly do we think we can do that should we just call the 30 minute lunch break now and come back and and do our vote.
I think we need that clarity we need the opportunity to talk about what conditions meet the concerns that people have raised. And I think we might need a minute to, you know, really be clear about that rather than.
I agree and I think rather than waiting for me to try to type something up I would rather have staff assist us with putting together the actual the motion as Judy.
Yeah, Linda, I would suggest we take our lunch break and then we'll bring this back up right after lunch.
Before we take the break, there was a clarification that the oversight would be by the LA County Office of Education not the LA County Board. So just excuse me.
Yes, I'm sorry. Yes. Yeah. Okay. Thanks.
County Office of Education. I'm sorry.
So we're going to take our 30 minute lunch break let's come back at noon. They give you 33 minutes, take, don't, don't get too excited but we'll come back and we'll have it written and we can consider and vote at that time.
And don't leave the room, because you might not get back in just stop your video and your audio.
All right.
Document on the screen, which had the, the motion.
Chad.
We want to go back to the previous document that was on the screen.
One minute.
I wasn't saying how smoothly things went yesterday. I think that was Kim I think she jinxed us.
Technology has been challenging today.
Chad, can we change the screen.
Do we want to get back to the conditions that were yes they're bringing up what was previously up there.
Do we still have the petitioners on the.
Yes, I think I saw.
Yeah.
Yes, I'm on. Okay. I wondered if you, if you would want to address a support that you have from the community on your charter.
Yes, absolutely.
So, we do have 133 intent, intent to enroll forms that we've gathered. Also we have over 180 letters of support. We, that we did include in the charter petition that was sent to see.
Those interest forms and those letters were sent to the CDE as part of the overall package because that's, that was what we were asked to send what was sent to LACO and that's what we sent to LACO to show the support of the community.
So we do have quite a bit of community support.
We now have the conditions here.
Somebody else who wanted to be recognized.
I'm sorry. Is that Eileen? Yeah, I just had a clarifying question. This is supposed to start as a ninth grade. So I'm assuming that the students that you had had interest in were entering ninth graders.
And if you wait a year, and you still start with ninth grade, won't you have to identify different students to start the program or will you plan to start with 10th graders that identified as ninth graders.
Unfortunately, we would have to recruit again.
Students to start in the ninth grade to follow the petitions opening plan, but I do believe with the interest that we have that we would very much be able to reach our enrollment goals.
Okay, thank you.
Would you like to restate the motion.
Yes, so now we have it on the screen. I also want to make sure that member Rucker is able to see this as well.
Yes, she is with us. She can see it. Okay.
In here. Great. All right. So, so moved to approve the time charter school petition for a term of five years effective July 1, 2020.
The school would delay opening the start of instruction in the 2021-22 school year.
Time will produce evidence that they have met the perspective enrollment for 2021-22 school year plus or minus 25%.
Time will submit to CDA revised budget with updated information to show that time is fiscally solvent and able to open in the 21-22 school year.
Time will submit to CDE evidence of their facilities lease and appropriate tournaments and submit to facilities inspection that is required for all SBE authorizer charter schools.
Time will correct the deficiencies in the petition identified by CDE in the A1 in the A1 and item.
All of the all corrected documentation will be submitted to CDE by April 29, 2020.
And if there are any questions whether these conditions have been satisfied time will and I can't see my screen.
Time will sorry.
Thank you. Time will.
Sorry, you have to go down a little bit. You're on number 18.
Okay. Thank you. Okay. There are questions with these conditions and says by time we'll come back to the SBE for resolution and the board delegates oversight to Los Angeles County Office of Education.
Okay. And do we have a second for this motion as stated?
I second that.
Jim Jim Jim. Is there any further discussion?
I'm not seeing any hands raised.
All right, we'll take a vote and Karen I think you need to manage the roll call vote. Okay.
Linda. Yes, Cynthia.
Yes, Jim.
Yes, Matt.
Yes, Brenna.
Yes, I day.
Yes, Eileen.
Yes, Ting.
Yes.
And Patricia Rucker.
Patricia, you have to call back in the phone line.
Oh, my.
And while we're waiting for Patricia, you see her. She's up.
She's on the screen. Yeah.
Well, she has to call into a different line, because her zoom line isn't working so we're going to have to wait a minute for her to call back in, I guess.
So while we're waiting for her to call it I have a question about the next item, Karen.
Do we need a break between these items for people to set up on your end or can we move right ahead?
I couldn't read and I said I was trying to send you a message on the chat and the cat seems to be disabled.
Oh, what a day you're having.
Do you vote yes on this set of on this motion with this set of conditions?
What is your vote?
No, we can't hear her.
Can you hear me, Pat?
We can't hear you. Oh, dear. No, Linda, I don't think we need a break again.
I'm muted.
All right, say it again. Try again.
Still not hearing you.
Oh, Linda.
Yes, she's.
She's.
We can't hear her. So she's going to try a different line.
I don't think this works.
So she's going to call into a different line.
The question I was asking is whether we need a break for the staff after this.
I think we can keep on moving.
Okay.
Just need to get that last vote recorded.
They're working the problem on this end. She's talking to somebody here. Just not we can't hear.
Oh, my.
Can she just can she talk to you and tell you her vote and you can.
Yeah, it has to be recorded as part of the low roll call.
Okay.
We can see you.
Can she do like a thumbs up or a thumbs down?
Okay.
Yes, she can hear. So Linda, here's what we can do. We're going to hold the vote open.
All right. Hang on one second. Maybe we solved it.
I'm waiting for item 20.
Thank you.
Okay.
Okay. So Linda, what we can do is we can hold the roll call open.
And when they get Patricia, so she can talk to us and we can hear her, then we'll register her vote. We'll go back when we can, but we can proceed with item 20.
Okay.
The day for creativity.
We will then move ahead to item 20, which is a public hearing regarding the petition for the renewal of a charter school under the oversight of the State Board of Education.
Consideration of John Henry High, which was denied by the West Contra Costa Unified School District and not acted on by the Contra Costa County Office of Education.
The CDE recommends that the State Board hold a public hearing to deny the request to renew John Henry High.
Guided will be presented by Stephanie Farland of the CDE. Stephanie, you can now, I guess, change this slide and begin item 20.
Stephanie, are you with us? Yes, I am. Sorry. I was just, can you see the item 20 petition for the, can you see the right slide up on your screen?
Not yet. Okay.
We are working on that very quickly. There we go. We got it. We got it. Okay.
Okay.
Okay, so item 20.
John Henry High School is seeking authorization from the State Board of Ed to renew its grade nine through grade 12 charter school within the boundaries of the West Contra Costa Unified School District.
The petitioners previously sought renewal through West Contra Costa Unified and the Contra Costa County Board of Education.
They were denied by West Contra Costa on December 18th, 2019.
It then went on to the Contra Costa County Board of Education on March 11th, 2020, and the board chose not to act on it.
They then appealed to the State Board on March 25th, 2020.
The California Department of Education recommends that the SBE hold a public hearing to deny the request to renew John Henry High, a grade nine through grade 12 charter school under the oversight of the SBE.
The Advisory Commission considered the appeal at their June 9th, 2020 meeting, and they moved to approve the John Henry High School renewal petition by a vote of seven to two.
The basis for recommendation of denial is the petitioner is significantly, is demonstrably unlikely to successfully implement the intended program.
They have significant declines in academic progress of their English learner pupils and admission requirements and enrollment process prohibit the school from reaching demographics reflective of West Contra Costa Unified.
And the petition does not provide reasonably comprehensive descriptions of all required 15 charter elements.
A little background on the school. Their mission is to provide a rigorous college preparatory education and character development program that will prepare students from underserved communities to succeed in college and beyond.
Their people population population primarily comes from Richmond and San Pablo, and consists of predominantly low income and immigrant students.
They are operated by a method public schools, a California nonprofit benefit corporation amps, as it's known is current currently operates three schools in Alameda County and three schools in Contra Costa County.
Academic criteria under 476071 was the author is the authority that granted the charter shall consider increases in pupil academic achievement for all groups of pupils served by the charter school as the most important factor.
The entity that granted the charter determines that the academic performance of the charter school is at least equal to the academic performance of the public schools at the other, but the charter school pupils would otherwise have been required to attend.
The population that is served under John Henry High is 95% Latino and 91% socioeconomically disadvantaged.
So here are cast results for John Henry High as compared to the other high schools in West Contra Costa Unified School District.
As you can see, they have met our threshold criteria for academic renewal, the academic renewal criteria, and you can see that there there's been some variation over the years and they've definitely have gone down in their math scores significantly from two or three years ago.
Here are cast results by people subgroup for socioeconomically disadvantaged peoples is that is their largest subgroup.
And again, some significant declines in their math scores their ELA goes back and forth but from the last couple years is on the rise.
We did look at alternative measures as allowed under section Ed code section 52052.
And one of the things that we looked at that they provided us where their increase in advanced placement course offerings.
They did increase to five offerings in 2018 19.
We've included some of the dashboard colors on here for you to see.
This is from the 2019 California school dashboard and you can see their yellow for ELA and orange for math.
Here are some of the subgroup totals.
English learners are an orange socioeconomically disadvantaged yellow and Latino Hispanic green.
No in blue.
Some more specifics in terms of the dashboard and English learners.
They are in orange for the English learners as a subgroup and in red for math as a subgroup with significant declines in math and small decline in English learners for ELA.
Ability to implement in terms of their budget, as I mentioned earlier, we did look at the original budget that they had submitted and according to the original budget, they
they seem to be fiscally viable.
It looked different for the ACCS because we were basing that one on May revise, which is no longer in effect.
And under that budget, they were not fiscally viable.
So we went back to their original budget and they are with the appropriate reserves.
We are not looking at this in terms because they are already they are an established school.
So we will we were not looking at it.
We did not have time to look at it in terms of deferrals, but that really is a question.
Hopefully that we can have the school itself answer in terms of how they plan to deal with the deferrals that will be coming to them and how they're going to do that.
And so that's something that they can they can discuss during their their time.
There were insufficient descriptions of many of the charter elements that are listed there.
Employee qualifications, they do not specifically identify which positions they regard as key in each category.
They do not identify the general qualifications of all their positions, including the general qualifications of their non-certificated staff and the petition does not contain job descriptions for for any of the positions.
Element seven, racial and ethnic balance.
You can see by the slide on the screen that their demographic data does not is not reflective of the West Contra Costa Unified School District.
And this has this was an important point for us when we were reviewing their petition and their data.
Concept of choices is one that is the CDE values and part of that choice includes the ability for all students to enroll in a school when it opens in a district.
Obviously, it's one of the elements.
So it was something that the legislature felt was important to include.
We understand that charters don't always have control over who applies to their school.
However, they do have control over the preferences that they use in terms of their admission requirements.
And part of the issue and the concern that we had with this particular school is they do not reflect the ethnic balance, racial and ethnic balance of of West Contra Costa.
You can see they don't reflect them in their English learners or special education or their African-American population.
And we feel that the preferences they've put in place and these were not I don't believe in place in their first petition.
So these are preferences that they're putting in place for this petition will really limit any new students from outside their pool of the Amps organization from from from getting into the school.
You can see that residents of West Contra Costa is number five on their preference list.
Their first preference is siblings.
Their second preference are pupils who are already enrolled in another Amps charter school.
Then you go to pupils of founding families and then you go to children of Amps teachers and staff.
And then you finally get to all of the other kids in the district and then all the other pupils obviously in the state because their charters are open to everyone.
And so we did have a very a very big concern about whether or not they were open to expanding the types of kids they enroll in their school.
There was nothing in their petition that specifically addressed the issue of of expanding enrollment in their school to kids outside of their organization.
And so that was an issue for us.
Suspension and expulsion procedures.
The petition does not present a reasonably comprehensive description of suspension and expulsion procedures in terms of placement of pupils in an interim alternative education setting.
The family handbook contains language that could be interpreted as an additional offense for expulsion that is not listed in the petition.
And that is that in the handbook, they talk about their student attendance review board and some of the issues that they take on.
And one of the things they state is that students can be dismissed possibly from the school, from Amps and or referred to the DA for student attendance issues.
And that was an issue because really students should not be dismissed.
The only way students should be dismissed is if they voluntarily disenroll or if they're expelled.
So there was some language discrepancies between what was in the petition and what is currently in their handbook that we had some concerns with charter elements 11 and 14 retirement coverage.
The petition does not specify who will be responsible for ensuring that appropriate arrangements for their employees retirement have been made.
And the dispute resolution procedures did not include a reasonably comprehensive description of this charter element.
So the CDE recommends that the SBE deny the petition to establish John Henry High School.
The petitioner is demonstrably unlikely to successfully implement the intended program and the petition does not provide reasonably reasonably comprehensive descriptions of all required elements.
Oops, I'm going to not do that one yet. Okay.
And that's the conclusion.
President Bradley-Hammond.
Thank you very much.
At this point, we will hear, I hereby open the public hearing at 1227 p.m.
And we will hear first from the petitioners.
They will have 12 minutes and we'll hear from the district and county that are opposing the renewal petition or at least in this case the district.
They will also have a total of 12 minutes.
After the presentations from both sides, there will then be an opportunity for public comment from any individual who has not already presented for one minute each.
So we'll take the practitioner presentation.
Hi, let me share my screen here.
Okay, thank you.
Good afternoon. My name is Sylvia Flores and I'm the site director at John Henry High School.
John Henry opened its doors in 2015 and we're a small school serving a total student population of 315 students in grades 9 through 12.
As a small school, we're able to create a community where all members of our school, we know each other by name, we are able to care for one another and support one another.
As you can see, 91% of our students are socioeconomically disadvantaged.
21% are English learners and 8% are receiving special education services.
Since we opened the school in 2015, we've seen a consistently growing waiting list of hopeful families looking to enroll at our school.
This past year for the 2020-2021 school year, we have the largest waitlist we've ever seen with over 300 applications for this upcoming school year.
So John Henry High School is one of the most coveted schools in the city.
This slide shows you we broke down based on current families addresses. We see that over 90% of our students would be required to enroll at Kennedy, Richmond High, or De Anza, with the majority of our students being assigned to Kennedy High School based on their home address.
As you notice in this next slide, John Henry is outperforming their peers at all three of these high schools on the CASP ELA ESPAC exam.
68% of our students are meeting or exceeding standards in English, and as mentioned, our English scores have increased annually over all the testing years that have taken place since our founding.
This next slide shows you the math comparisons for the ESPAC exam. Once again, you can see that John Henry is outperforming all high schools that our students would otherwise be required to attend.
We know that we have room for improvements. We don't like this 21%, so we have invested in new curriculum and restructured the way that we support math instruction.
Now, the ESPAC only shows you one year of student data, but as the data-driven school, this is our PSAT data, which is growth data for this past senior year class, so the class of 2020.
This cohort of students has taken or took the PSAT over three consecutive years, and I'm proud to report that the class of 2020 did increase their scores by 188 points during their time with us at John Henry High School.
We see improvements in both English and math, and the increase can be attributed to our targeted support and intervention programs such as learning lab, interim assessments.
So we are seeing growth, and I'm going to show you in terms of advanced placement, we have increased AP participation by 300% over the past few years.
The AP course offerings, as you saw in the CDE presentation, we weren't offering anything in the first few years because we only had ninth and tenth graders.
So as we added more classes, we began offering more AP courses, and now we're offering math, English, foreign language, and we're planning to add science and other electives in the next few years.
So as you can see here, our AP passing rate grew from 12% to 40% between one year to the next.
Now I do want to address some of the concerns that were raised in the CDE staff report, beginning with recruitment.
Our entire community, the John Henry community, is committed to achieving the demographic distribution that is reflective of our district.
Students are accepted through a randomized lottery, which is operated by a third party called Enroll West Contra Costa.
We partnered with them three years ago, and we've seen progress already. So over the years, our lottery numbers have grown exponentially.
For this upcoming year, we received 231 applications for only 90 spots for the incoming ninth grade class.
So in order to reach the demographics that resemble those of West Contra Costa, we plan to improve our recruitment and outreach efforts and diversify our applicant pool.
So we plan to target middle schools, both district and charter, who have large numbers of English language learners, SPED students, African American students.
And we want to collaborate with the leadership teams at those schools to do annual events where we can make sure that families are aware of the opportunities, enrichment, and we want to help them with the enrollment process.
We are also planning to hire a consultant who will be interviewing and surveying African American students, SPED, and EL families to provide recommendations for improving both the cultural responsiveness of our educational program, but also our recruitment and outreach efforts.
Now that West Contra Costa is breaking up into five district boundaries, we have security partnership with KDI Charter Zone, which we're going to be able to use a GPS demographic tool that captures school age populations and breaks it up into free and reduced lunch,
ethnicities, language status in order for us to identify areas to target. And we have also established family captains within our schools so that we can target those areas and host like block parties or right now virtual block meetings to distribute recruitment materials and answer questions.
We don't only want to diversify John Henry, but also our other elementary and middle school here in Richmond.
Moving on to English learners, we have seen success. John Henry is succeeding in terms of English, our English learner program and looking through the California dashboard data.
John Henry has the highest percentage of English language learners making progress towards proficiency in the entire district at a rate of 56.3%.
This is the highest rate of any school traditional or charter in our district.
Our students do receive designated and integrated EL instruction that is aligned to the California ELD standards.
This next graph shows you, this is our total student body broken down by English language proficiency.
As you can see, 21.5% of our student body is classified as English learners. This is for this year that just passed.
So 1920, 71% of our students were English learners and have been reclassified.
So in total, 92% of our total student body have been classified as English learners at some point in their educational trajectory.
And 71% have been reclassified in that trajectory. In terms of our LPAC proficiency levels, 50% of our current English learners are in levels one and two.
We saw a huge influx of newcomers into our school this past year.
So we have been able to provide the support and the rigorous instruction that they need in order to succeed.
I'm going to transition into math. This past year we adopted CPM, which is college preparatory math, as our new math curriculum.
As I told you before, we're not happy with that 21%. We want to improve.
And we have increased professional development opportunities for our math teachers and our support staff.
We also hired paraprofessional tutors in order to be in every algebra one section along with the credential teacher.
This past year, our geometry and algebra two classes had no more than 20 students per section.
And this has proven effective in increasing students conceptual understanding of math, which is one of the things that we noticed in the summer that was that was an area of concern.
I'm going to turn it over to Mike Barr, who is going to be talking about the revised financial projections for our school.
Hi, good afternoon. As discussed by the CD earlier, our financials are solid. There's two sets of numbers on the slide.
The numbers at the top reflect what we shared with the ACCS last month.
Those were based on the governor's May revision, which had a much lower funding scenario than what we currently know.
The bottom set of numbers reflect the latest guidance we got from Sacramento. We've done a couple things conservatively.
We've assumed that enrollment is only two hundred eighty kids next year.
We think it's going to be higher than that based on wait list and based on the excitement around the school.
We've also conservatively assumed that we do not benefit from any that hold harmless calculations that are made.
In other words, we'd assume that if we have two hundred eighty kids next year, that's what we'll get funded on because we feel that's more conservative.
There's a slide that talks about how we're going to mitigate through the external internal factors that will affect our abilities to be successful,
knowing that this is a multi-year economic crisis that we need to navigate through.
So with that, I'm going to turn it over to Janelle from Young Mini Core and then we'll come back to Sylvia.
Thank you. And good afternoon, board members, Janelle Rooley with Young Mini and Core.
I want to highlight for you again that even the CDE found that John Henry's academic program meets the renewal criteria and provides a sound educational program.
As to the other points that CDE raised, the staff report suggested that these are fairly easily remedied with amendments to the charter.
When it comes to governance, there was a question about the meeting location, but the charter school has complied with new law and will agree to a condition on employee qualifications.
They really just need to add the word key and move qualifications from the appendix into the charter.
We heard about racial and ethnic balance on admission.
The charter school is willing to work with the CDE to reorder those preferences on suspension expulsion.
They're already complying with the law.
And I would add that the law was changed in twenty eighteen to allow for involuntary removal as an additional reason that a student may be removed from the school on retirement.
On retirement, they just need to identify who the person is responsible for ensuring arrangements are made.
And on dispute resolution, we couldn't have made those changes because no changes can be made to the charter.
But the charter school promised to make those changes.
So ultimately, these things do not rise to the level of closing a nationally recognized charter school.
John Henry was named a twenty twenty best high school by US News and Mobile Port.
They certainly don't rise to the level of closing a school that outperforms all of the schools that students would otherwise attend.
The law simply does not permit this closure.
And I'll go back to Ms. Flores.
Thank you.
In terms of our distance learning plan, we're proud to share that 92 percent of our students were engaged in daily assignments during last semester's distance learning model.
So we are working with the community and stakeholders to be able to continue that rigorous instruction and learning for every student that is at our school.
We are college prep. We've sent over 90 percent of our graduating seniors to four year colleges since we were founded.
And you can see some other stats here in terms of highlights.
We are the third best high school in West Contra Costa.
So we ask that you go to our school. Thank you.
Thank you very much. And at this point, we'll move to the district presenters potentially with the county.
I don't know.
The district. There we go.
All right. Good afternoon. Thank you very much for hearing our appeal.
I would like to thank you all also for your work. My name is Dr.
Linda Delgado. I performed charters charter school oversight for the district of West Contra Costa.
And I will be joined as needed in this presentation with the folks listed below.
The school found the school findings for West Contra against John Henry include that there is an inadequate English language development and special education programs and the method organization provides inadequate governance and management.
Background preliminarily test scores are considered the most important factor in reviewing a charter petition.
Test scores are impacted, however, by student populations who traditionally underperform on the cast.
For example, English language learner percentages impact test results as the test is not in the students primary language.
Test score comparisons are legitimate only when student populations subgroups are similar.
The claim of equal to or better than district schools cannot factually be made in a review of the data will make this clear.
Subgroups include English language learners, special education, foster and homeless youth and students living in poverty.
A comparative review of all district high schools and John Henry will follow.
In this table, you'll find highlighted.
John Henry is in the yellow first column, followed by all district high schools.
Each school's data is presented in column form and subgroup headings are noted along the left hand axis.
The highest percentage for each row is bolded and underlined.
In no case does John Henry lead the schools most frequently used in the petition for comparison are immediately to the right.
Kennedy and Richmond high schools, and they serve considerably different populations.
Please note the following rows in particular for English language learners.
Kennedy and Richmond have greater than three times the EL's for special education.
All schools with the exception of middle college have higher special education numbers.
Kennedy and Richmond serve the greatest numbers of socioeconomically disadvantaged students.
John Henry is not serving a representative population.
And further, the organization has changed the lottery to further cement this disparity.
On this slide, the left hand column compares the district and John Henry for EL percentages over a four year period, illustrating disparity in percentages.
And there is a dramatically falling trend line.
The district average is orange and John Henry is gray.
The table on the right shows the overall school percentage of EL's in the first data column.
The second data column has the percentage of that group who are English language learners levels one and two.
For example, at John Henry, the overall percentage during the years of evaluation was 12.5 of the total population.
And of that 12.5, 23.8, about a quarter, are levels one and two.
Contrasted with Richmond High with an overall percentage of 39, basically 40%, and half of that group were EL's one and two.
Now we'll go on to the program itself.
Staffing and scheduling issues.
Over the 2019-20 year, five different teachers were, one after the other, tasked with leading the school's single ELD course.
During this class period, each teacher attempted to provide instruction for four grade levels, four EL levels, and four language domains in one classroom.
The petition was silent on how this might be achieved.
There was a failure to provide adequate curriculum.
Although the organization stated that ELD curriculum was in place from inception, the board did not adopt curriculum until this last academic year.
The reclassification process was just recently drafted and put into place in the school's fifth year.
We don't know what it contains or if it is effective.
The performance gap from the dashboard focusing on statewide data.
To demonstrate the effect of subgroup membership on CASP scores, a review of statewide data is provided.
The first row shows percentages of students at or above grade level for English-only and fluent English speakers.
This would be students with a firm command of English.
The second row shows ELL students at or above grade level.
Obviously, you've got English language arts on the left and math on the right.
Data are clear that John Henry is not serving the same student populations as other schools, and this demonstrates why it matters.
Note, in particular, the gaps which are presented here in red.
The gaps show the statewide difference between ELLs and those with a command of the language.
The gap between the two groups is significant, illustrating the effect of ELL designation on test scores.
Greater numbers of ELL students have a greater impact on scores overall.
John Henry has fewer ELLs than most district schools, and scores are less impacted.
Next, a comparison of these statewide performance data differences versus the John Henry gap.
Performance gaps.
The first row brings the statewide difference in scores between ELLs and fluent English students only from the prior slide.
That's the 45.68.
The second row are the same data for John Henry.
Ideally, that score would be smaller than the statewide gap.
Rather, it is larger, and the difference is, once again, in red along the bottom.
Compared with statewide averages, John Henry is underperforming.
In this review, the presentation has shown that the ELD program has serious and long-term flaws, and this data demonstrates the problem.
Now onto special education issues.
This table compares district and John Henry enrollment percentages for special education from 2015 through 2020.
Over the five years of operation, John Henry has served significantly fewer special ed students and has never served a student with moderate or severe needs.
There are no CASP data that are publicly available for SPED students throughout the five years of operation because the numbers have always been too low.
The district requested that John Henry share the data in their possession, and they refused.
This is an adequate special education program per former staff and leadership.
Two former A-Method site leaders with extensive special education experience submitted whistleblower complaints detailing faulty special education provision.
Five teachers from the school submitted statements with concerns about special education program and organizational leadership, and quotes are provided in the appendix.
Four teachers reported receiving direction from leadership to change grades for special education students to report that they were passing when in fact they were not.
And three teachers reported direction to mark a student present who had not attended class.
Additionally, the school failed to provide the required minutes to a number of students.
They were noticed for that, and they did make up the minutes, but they made them up in the last two or three minutes of each class period, raising serious questions as to the seriousness of the organization's focus on special education students.
Inadequate special education per community benefit organization.
In 2019, the district received a letter from the Disability Rights Education and Defense Fund, an advocacy rights organization funded by the US Department of Education that supports parents of students with disabilities.
That letter stated Amps administration violated the law by directing special education and site leadership to hold SST meetings in lieu of parent requested assessments to determine whether or not a child needed services in violation of the law and leadership
directed families to return to the district for accommodations services.
The charter petition references obligatory child find procedures, however, it does not explicitly reference RTI response to intervention as a fundamental aspect of child find, meaning a child may go through the whole ILP individualized learning program or RTI response to
intervention process and the site director may deem them unqualified for an SST, creating further barriers to specialized academic instruction.
The petition stated process could take an entire year for a child to receive services.
In order to review data illustrating the gap between those in special ed again and those who are not, staff looked at statewide data to try and get a sense of what the impact on test scores might be.
And here you have once again presented the gap in red.
Of course, the higher the special ed population served, the greater the impact on scores overall. All other district schools have higher percentages of special education except middle college high, and all see the expected impact on scores.
This data challenges the legitimacy of the school's data by demonstrating the impact of equivalent special ed enrollment.
Governance issues. Since 2015 the Method central office has lost at least 20 individuals out of 20 central office leaders, six special education directors two directors of talent, director of IT, the COO, the CAO, the COF, three regional
superintendents, directors of finance systems and assorted others. Seven central office staff were laid off or fired in June of 2020. That included two regional superintendents, two out of two compliance coordinators, talent communications, special ed coordinators, director of finance and accounting.
Since 2015 the organization has lost 28 site leaders, including deans and directors. Of these four were from John Henry, six from RCA, and six from BJE, those are the two other Method schools in West Contra Costa.
John Henry lost 13 teachers and two front office staff between 2016 and 18.
Sorry.
Time is up.
Okay, would you like me to stop or shall I press on.
Time, you should finish your sentence yeah.
Basically we're seeing a great deal of turnover there are two more slides but you do have them in your deck. Thank you very much.
Thank you very much.
At this point, we want to put up the public comments slide.
And we want to open the phone line for public comment. We hope that people who were trying to speak earlier have returned to speak at the proper time, members of the public wishing to provide comment on this item.
I wonder if we can remove that.
Can you remove that thing from the computer great can call 712-432-0075 enter access code 651905 pound wait for the operator prompts to press star six, and then another prompt to press one to enter the queue.
And could we have the translator read the instructions in Spanish, please.
Absolutely.
For the public hearing, the issue number 20, the phone number is 712-432-0075 will ask for an access number which is 651905 number.
Escucha el mensaje y cuando se le indique oprima asterisco 6, y cuando se le indique nuevamente oprima 1.
Cuando sea su turno, un operador le pedir en ingls que diga su nombre y su afiliacin y comience su intervencin.
Su turno empieza ya.
Dgale, mi nombre es Raya, represento a Raya y necesito un traductor.
Thank you very much.
We encourage you to please state your name and affiliation for the record.
Remember to turn down the volume on your computers if you are following the live feed and speakers are limited to one minute each.
Let's see if we have public comment.
Speakers on the line, please ensure that this is only for item 20 for John Henry.
If you're on the line for another item, we ask that you please hang up at this time and call back at the next item.
Again, only speakers for item 20 John Henry should be in the queue at this time.
All other callers should hang up at this time and call back at your scheduled item.
Thank you.
We have approximately 30 public commenters in the queue, so we will start with our first caller right now.
Caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record to provide public comment for John Henry High.
Your time starts now.
My name is Emma Urbach. Can you hear me?
Yes.
Okay, I am the executive director for United Teachers of Richmond.
I'm asking that you deny the renewal of John Henry High because the school does not have qualified staff at key levels to ensure student success.
A message John Henry's parent organization recently fired or laid off their Richmond regional superintendent, Richmond regional compliance coordinator, and special education director.
Additionally, the current John Henry site director, Silvia Flores, has never taught, has a 30-day substitute permit, and does not have an admin credential.
Natalie Garcia, the John Henry dean of instruction, does not appear to have an administrative credential or clear credential either.
John Henry is currently recruiting for 10 teaching positions, and it is not clear from the posting that a credential is required despite new state law.
John Henry averages only 6% retention of teachers, and the majority of teachers who work there do not have clear credentials.
John Henry and their parent organization do not have the necessary staff, credentialing, or expertise to successfully educate students this fall.
WCCUSD teachers are ready and willing to welcome students back into the district schools this fall, where they will be taught by qualified teachers with credentials.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record to provide public comment for John Henry High.
Your time starts now.
Hi, I'm Joseph Glatzer, a teacher in the West Contra Costa Unified School District, and I'm asking that you deny John Henry High School's appeal.
We have many great opportunities in our district and would welcome John Henry students back with open arms, including with AP courses, visual and performing arts opportunities, sports, exciting electives, academies, and more.
So the demographic makeup of John Henry is not reflective of the community with 95% Latinx.
They have a lower number of special ed English learners, homeless foster youth, and African American students compared to public district schools.
So comparing their test scores with those of our district schools is comparing apples and oranges.
In the 1920 school year, there was only one ELD class which had five different teachers, and there is a lack of progress for English learners overall.
It is an unstable learning environment. There is a largely large yearly turnover of teachers and administration.
Despite having many opportunities to fix these issues, they have not. They do not need more chances. Please deny their appeal.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record to provide public comment for John Henry. Your time starts now.
Hi, my name is Jamie. I'm a parent for one graduating student and one student who's still at John Henry.
I ask that you leave the school open. You want to give children of color a better education. John Henry is doing that.
Miss Delgado has given information that is based on the whole organization, not John Henry.
John Henry's numbers are much lower. Also, Miss Delgado should be disqualified for the way she has treated John Henry.
She's given data that she did not get from John Henry. She never visited the school.
This school has given my children a better education than any of the public schools have in Richmond, and I know because I moved them from public schools.
Public schools here in Richmond do not give safe environments for our children.
John Henry has done nothing but provide safe environment and a loving family environment that lets and helps children succeed.
They really live by their motto, honor hard work. Please, please approve this school. We need them. Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record to provide public comment for John Henry. Your time starts now.
Hi, my name is Beashers Burden. I actually have a sister who goes to the school. I am calling in to please ask you guys to give them another chance.
All the schools we have in the area are already overcrowded as it is, and we would really appreciate having a school in our color community that actually provides them a good education
and is not just overcrowded and doesn't have the attention that the students need both for their mental health and for their education.
So I just ask you guys to please sync with your hearts when you vote for this today. Thank you for your time.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record to provide public comment for John Henry. Your time starts now.
Hi, my name is Gabriela Rodriguez. I am a founding parent and a community member. I am an afternoon board member.
I would like to express my support for John Henry High School. John Henry is one of the top performing high schools in the West Country process.
I don't understand why this school is being penalized for serving our Latino community.
Our students have achieved so much with the high level of academics offered at John Henry.
They offer a safe environment for our students and promote a pathway for college.
It is very disturbing for our families and community to hear that UTR, the Teachers Union, sent out a message, message request to its members to vote against John Henry,
but it does not encourage its members to close the learning gap our district schools have. Please keep John Henry open.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record to provide public comment for John Henry. Your time starts now.
Good afternoon. My name is Philip Ellingberg. I'm speaking on behalf of ministers in Richmond. I'm a pastor in the city of Richmond.
And I'd like to speak on behalf of not only our congregation, but my colleagues and at least 40 parishioners.
We have at least five African-American students who are on the list on the waiting list for John Henry, and we'd love to have them there.
I've worked extensively with the school in our area, which is Kennedy High, and our students are traumatized from the gang violence as well as the heavy drug presence.
And we wrestle with how best to educate our children. Some thrive in these own schools, but it's not true for every child.
I work again with several of these students who are going through heavy trauma, and I ask that we please renew John Henry. Don't take that choice away.
Parents should have the ability to choose what works best for their child, and once economic situations should not be a bar to exercising that choice.
The bottom line is this, in my opinion, I thank you so much. Please renew John Henry.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record to provide public comment for John Henry. Your time starts now.
Good afternoon, everyone. My name is Claudia Lee. I am the site director for Down Charter School in Oakland.
As a member of the Alms community, I have worked closely with the staff members at John Henry High School for two years now.
I have witnessed their professionalism, dedication, and commitment to their students.
I have seen 100% of John Henry High School teachers and administrators and hundreds of parents and students going to meeting after meeting of this long and arduous renewal process.
Parents and teachers say that they appreciate the learning that is happening in the classrooms and the opportunity that having another high school in Richmond has created for the community.
I hope that the relentless support and advocacy of hundreds of Richmond Spines means something to you. They just want to choose the school for their children.
I hope that you grant them the right to choose. Thank you very much.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record to provide public comment for John Henry. Your time starts now.
Hello, my name is Marissa Glidden. I'm a proud West Contra County educator. Before teaching at West Contra Costa, I was hired to teach at A Method.
Beginning a teacher orientation, it became clear to me that something was seriously wrong.
Not only was every teacher uncredentialed at A Method, I was also explicitly taught by the leadership to participate in illegal and problematic disciplinary processes, including making students wear tissue boxes on their feet if they didn't wear shoes and met dress code,
taking a student's desk away to their floor, sit on the floor, withholding lunch from students who misbehaved and threatening expulsion for minor misbehavior and then dismissing students without official documentation.
I was also told that A Method encouraged special education students not to apply to the school and purposefully did not recruit students in predominantly African American areas.
This is what I was explicitly taught by A Method leadership. When I spoke out about these policies, they threatened to fire me.
After I resigned, Teach for America did their own internal investigation and had the same findings. They now refuse to place teachers at that school. Please protect our students and do not allow John Henry to open. Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record to provide public comment for John Henry. Your time starts now.
Hi, my name is Kevin Doherty and we work with John Henry High School along with many other schools and youth programs in Contra Costa County.
I personally have coached the youth in our community and I can recognize valuable influences teachers and institutions can have on them.
John Henry High School, their teachers, administrators and staff tirelessly work to provide quality opportunities and values for the youth in the community they otherwise would not have.
So for the sake of our community's future, we cannot afford to let quality, free public schools like John Henry High School be eliminated. Please vote in favor of John Henry High School. Thank you for your time.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record to provide public comment for John Henry. Your time starts now.
Good morning. Good afternoon board members. My name is Eric Becker and I come to you today to show my support for John Henry High School. I am currently the assistant principal at John Henry Sister School in Oakland.
I'd like to address the argument that A Method Public Schools is unable to operate a school that successively serves underprivileged communities.
Oakland Charter High School was established by A Method Public Schools Network in 2007. It is an exemplary school that serves over 85 percent socioeconomically disadvantaged students and 99 percent minority students.
According to U.S. News and World Report, it is currently the number one high school in Oakland.
OCHS is also a California Gold Ribbon School and was ranked as high as number four in the state for its API scores.
Again, this is the sister school of John Henry operated by the same charter management organization that West Contra Costa said is demonstrably unlikely to fulfill its education policy.
It is a high school that serves over 85 percent socioeconomically disadvantaged students and 99 percent minority students.
I'm also a parent in West Contra Costa. I have three children in WCCUSD public schools and I would like you to keep John Henry open as an option for them.
John Henry is outperformed all of the local schools, especially for socioeconomics.
It is a high school that serves over 85 percent socioeconomically disadvantaged students and 99 percent minority students.
It is a high school that serves over 85 percent socioeconomics.
It's time to put students first.
We have a growth but the dashboard shows we have a percentage of ELL students progressing towards proficiency in the district.
And 71 percent of our student body are former ELLs we designated as proficient.
The former G focus does not work under our current leadership.
He likely does not know that we were granted a letter of good state in the district.
Old grievances need to be set aside so we can focus on the future.
Compared our data with statewide averages instead of the local schools that our students would otherwise.
The only thing kept at local was looking at demographics.
We do not have a selective admissions process but we are notoriously rigorous.
And we have students who come to us who buy over 90 percent socioeconomically disadvantaged minority students.
Low African-American enrollment is a chartered issue not a John Henry specific issue.
And this blurs the fighting tooth and nail to make us a leader in changing this disturbing trend.
Thank you.
Next caller please state your name and affiliation for the record to provide public comment for John Henry.
Your time starts now.
Hi my name is Mike Parker.
I'm a retired community college instructor in industrial electronics and a member of the Richmond Workforce Development Board.
I have long been concerned about the problems in our education system in preparing underserved communities for skills required in our modern economy.
I and I assume all of you recognize the institutionalized racism in our society and in our school system.
JHHS is a good example of this institutionalized racism.
It's part of the re-segregation of our public school system.
Although the surrounding community is about 25 percent black, JHHS has less than 3 percent black enrollment.
At the same time, JHHS does a poor job in developing English language learners.
This segregation denies all of our young people the ability to learn and understand other cultures in the society in which we live.
I urge you to make rooting out institutionalized racism a priority and deny renewal of the Henry High School.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record to provide public comment for John Henry.
Your time starts now.
Hi my name is Felix Cabrera and I'm the Dean of Instruction at Oakland Starter High School, the sister school of John Henry and the Amps organization.
I've worked for OCHS for six years, five as a teacher and one as an administrator.
Just a second here.
Let me turn that up.
The public education system is clearly broken in California.
I've learned this not only in my time working in it as both before I joined Oakland Charter High School,
but also through my education program that I've gone through as an administrator, as I now have my administrative credential.
Nowhere is this gap more important.
We fail to close achievement grants across the state and nowhere is this more apparent than in Contra Costa County and Richmond in particular.
John Henry shows consistent improvement and growth in both Latinx and socio-economic disadvantaged students.
More and more families are looking to them as an answer for their educational needs over the failing public schools that resist change at every turn.
So I highly recommend that you keep John Henry open and allow it to continue to make the improvements that it has been working time and again to make sure it happens.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record to provide public comment for John Henry.
Your time starts now.
Good afternoon.
I mean, good afternoon.
My name is Ledza Cuellar and I am a student at John Henry High School who will be a senior next upcoming school year.
And I have grown in more ways than I can count academically.
All thanks to John Henry with the aid from my teachers, staff, and my own classmates.
And I would like to ask you to vote in favor of John Henry High School.
We have fought and worked so hard for so long to build up our community.
And I'm sure my fellow classmates have hopes for a future with John Henry as well as please vote in favor of John Henry.
Thank you for your time.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record to provide public comment for John Henry.
Your time starts now.
Hola.
Un momento, por favor.
Translators, are you available?
Right here.
Okay.
Good afternoon. My name is Karina Rodriguez and I have my own translator.
Hello, my name is Karina Rodriguez and I would like the voice of my son and my family to be heard.
Hi, my name is Karina Rodriguez and I would like my voice and the voice of my son and the voice of my community to be heard once more.
Mi hijo Angel Lopez estara comenzando a cursar el ultimo ao de la high school.
My son Angel would be enrolled in his last year of high school this year.
Esto va a ser posible si ustedes hacen un voto a favor para que la escuela siga abierta.
And this would be possible if you guys vote for the school to remain open.
Mi hijo actualmente se encuentra preocupado y yo dira hasta cierto punto un poco deprimido.
My son finds himself very worried and a bit depressed at times.
l es muy activo y con esta pandemia de golpe ha parado todos sus proyectos que tena para el verano.
He's a very active kid and with the current pandemic everything has stopped all of a sudden.
Y ahora lo que ms le preocupa es el cierre de la escuela.
l se sienta a la deriva sin saber cul es el siguiente paso.
But what the things that we're the thing that worries us the most is the closing of the school.
He feels lost and not being certain about his future.
We have enrolled him in many public schools but not have not heard anything back from any of them.
We don't understand why there's so much effort into closing down Henry High School.
When the school has been shown to surpass this all those competitors in Contra Costa and math and English
has been named one of the best schools in the country in 2020.
90 percent of its students get into a four-year college.
And the advisory commission has remained.
Thank you.
Next caller please state your name and affiliation for the record to provide public comment for John Henry.
Your time starts now.
Hi I'm Mary Flanagan.
I'm a retired teacher.
I taught 14 years at Neistrom Elementary Public School in West Richmond.
And for a few years John Henry High School was in a temporary portable on the other side of Neistrom.
The elementary school.
It was on the same block.
And John Henry did not have any visibly African-American students or teachers or parents.
And at that time the kids at Neistrom the elementary school were more than 20 percent African-American.
And it's a huge insult to our students and their families that John Henry excluded African-American students.
That segregation is unconstitutional.
Remember Brown versus Topeka Board of Education.
And our elementary students had witnessed that racist segregation right on the other side of a cyclone fence every day.
I urge you do not renew John Henry High School's charter.
Even now John Henry only has 2.8 percent African-American students.
And Kennedy High School the nearest public high school is 25 percent African-American enrolled.
Thank you.
Next caller please state your name and affiliation for the record to provide public comment for John Henry.
Your time starts now.
Hi my name is Forest Bori.
I'm a teacher.
Well I have been a teacher at John Henry High School for the last two years.
Right now I just found a job with Berkeley Unified Public Schools.
Not a transition that I wanted to make.
I very much wanted to stay with my family at John Henry High School.
I think that our director Ms.
Flores is an absolute hero to the community.
I feel that the biggest problem in the last two years that I've worked at our school has been the constant threats of closure.
And you want to talk about teacher turnover.
Well now you're going to have another one with me because I had to find another job this last year.
But again I would have absolutely loved to have looped two more years with the 10th graders of this year.
I'm sourly disappointed that nobody from the educational community ever once came into my classroom and got to see the incredibly profound growth that we were making.
They I am so blown away that people like the other mother had said from our school that people are putting so much energy into shutting this down instead of just asking us what we need and how they can help us.
They've constantly treated us poorly.
And this school absolutely deserves to stay open.
Watch it in five years it'll be absolutely the best school in West Contra Costa.
Thank you.
Next caller please state your name and affiliation for the record to provide public comment for John Henry.
Your time starts now.
Hello my name is Joanna Morales and as a junior at John Henry High School I feel anger.
Anger a strong feeling of annoyance displeasure or hostility.
So answer me this who must I blame for this hostility.
When I'm stuck in a class anxiety rising hostility knowing this isn't healthy for me so why must this be.
I'll vanish from me my tranquility.
I'm told not to blame you so please tell me who.
I must blame for making my worst year come true.
Look now I'm not just writing a poem I'm trying to get to you.
For my words that are broken please don't be like a court fool.
Your nose spreads to me and it kicks my hostility.
And so you must see I will keep my tranquility.
I tried so darn hard to do my best and if I got my school I'd give it a rest.
But sadly that's not guaranteed.
So here I am to plead.
Keep my school open. Fight for John Henry.
Thank you.
Next caller please state your name and affiliation for the record to provide public comment for John Henry.
Your time starts now.
Oh is this me.
Yes please please provide your public comment.
My name is Debbie Bayer I'm a Richmond resident and I am calling to ask you not to renew John Henry's application even though I hear that it causes disruption for the children who are currently attending and that does move me.
But I feel that the sort of segregate the lack of African-American students and the poor performance of disabled students and English learners students, high teacher turnover which happened before the previous two years all make me feel like John Henry,
The rest of us who pay money into the West County Costa Unified School District budget are subsidizing schools like John Henry who can take the students they want and then go forward with and reach out to the rest of us who are left.
Next caller please state your name and affiliation for the record to provide public comment for John Henry.
Your time starts now.
Good afternoon. My name is Michael Juba and I represent the California Teachers Association.
DTA recommends that the SBE vote to deny the renewal petition for John Henry high for the following reasons.
JHH fails to meet the academic requirements for renewal in the Charter Schools Act with significant declines in academic progress of English learners and ELA and math and concerns that the current admission requirements set up an enrollment process that prohibits JHH from reaching demographics that are reflective of West Contra Costa Unified School District.
Second, their enrollment practices are highly suspect and their governance practices fall short.
And the CDE also found that the petition does not contain a reasonably comprehensive description of all the required elements for five, seven, eight, 10, 11, and 14.
So in conclusion, the State Board of Education should deny this renewal position. Thank you.
Next caller please state your name and affiliation for the record to provide public comment for John Henry. Your time starts now.
Hello.
Hello. Yes, we can hear you. Please provide your public comment.
Hi, my name is Araceli Magana and I'm a proud mother of two students who are attending John Henry High School. And I really ask you guys to please keep it open. It's been an amazing school. It has helped a lot of my students.
And that's how I'm hearing a lot of comments. I don't know why they're focusing a lot in races who attend the school. Whoever, everybody's welcome in that school.
So I just please ask for you guys to please consider and keep our school open, especially now with our distance and kids cannot be overcrowded in other schools. Our Richmond schools are fully packed.
They won't be able for them to have them separate six feet off students. So please keep our school open. John Henry. Thank you.
Next caller please state your name and affiliation for the record to provide public comment for John Henry. Your time starts now.
Hi, hello.
Yes, we can hear you. Please provide your public comment.
My name is Nigeli Ochoa and I am a John Henry alumni. I graduated in 2019 and I'm currently attending a four-year university. More than 90% of graduates were accepted into four-year universities, looking to pursue higher education.
And a lot of that is due to the amazing academic resources provided to us at John Henry. It's honestly very devastating that we have to have to fight this hard for a school that has proven themselves numerous times in so many ways that we have the right to remain open.
This has become such a political thing. Please focus on the fact that so many students and parents chose to be part of the John Henry High School community.
It's very saddening that we have to keep fighting for our school during this pandemic. We're all frustrated that so many people try so hard to shut us down. Families chose to attend. The choice lies on us. And if so many families are fighting hard to keep the school open, that should tell all board members and board members this is to us. Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record to provide public comment for John Henry. Your time starts now.
Hello caller, would you like to make a public comment for John Henry High?
Yes.
Please state your name and affiliation. Your time starts now.
My name is Philip Chung. I reside in the state of Richmond. I'm a teacher at John Henry High School. We are a small school and we emphasize that in giving students and families a choice on where they're educated.
An example of how we use our small size to better students experience is just two days after the County Board of Education denied or took no action on our appeal.
We received or that was the last day of in-person instruction on that last day in order to minimize the impact of the digital divide. We did a full eyes on inspection of every student's laptop, power supply and ascertain that they had an internet connection.
If they did not, we made sure they had that and we maintained their communication with them throughout the instructional period of the school year. Thank you very much.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record to provide public comment for John Henry. Your time starts now.
Hi, I'm my name is Sam Ethan and I'm a teacher and a credit teacher.
I ask you to approve John Henry and keep us open.
I would emphasize like many people have been that we are really focused on high achievement. I've seen many of my students really grow and get into four universities and we are a college-bound kind of focus.
And I also want to mention that many students have been reclassified. A vast majority of my students are ELL students, but they've been reclassified and they're still bilingual.
Finally, I want to emphasize the ripple effects this closure would have not only on the hundreds of students, but these hundreds of families and the public schools in our area.
People have mentioned the public schools in their area are many times not safe and at the very least are vastly impacted by the pandemic and budget cuts and are overcrowded.
So again, I please really urge you to keep our schools open.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record to provide public comment for John Henry. Your time starts now.
Good afternoon. I'm Dr. Sifatib Mukherjee. I am a scientist at Lawrence Berkeley National Lab and a concerned member of the community.
I ask the school be allowed to continue operations in my capacity as a scientist and educator for over 15 years.
I've interacted with hundreds of high school students, including those from JHH, and I've observed firsthand how motivated and excited the students are to learn, especially coming from the background that these students are where no one expects these
teenagers to succeed. It's amazing that what JHH students have achieved over these past years. I mean, just look at their college expectations over the last years. It's phenomenal.
So I didn't get a chance to look at all of Ms. Flores' slides, but from what I saw briefly, the overall performance far exceeds all the other schools in the area year after year.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record to provide public comment for John Henry. Your time starts now.
Hello.
Yes, we can hear you caller. Did you need translation?
I know. Okay. Hi, good afternoon. My name is Cristina Avila, a parent of a 4.5 GPA student. I just want to say that John Henry is one of the best schools in Contra Costa County.
My daughter is one of the students and I'm proud to say that John Henry is doing an excellent work. The environment in John Henry is very safe.
You won't see any police watching around or arresting students. John Henry has an excellent discipline. It is a place where I feel confident to leave my daughter every morning.
It is a place where my daughter feels safe, supportive, and where she can accomplish her goals. Please don't close John Henry. Our students deserve an excellent quality of education as John Henry.
We don't have too many good options in Richmond. Please take your time to visit our school. Please don't turn your back to our students and keep John Henry open. Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record to provide public comment for John Henry. Your time starts now.
Good afternoon. My name is Sator Wilson. I'm a teacher in the West Contra Costa School District and I'm opposing the renewal of John Henry High because the school is failing to recruit and retain black students or black teachers.
During 2016-2017, 90% of the faculty was first or second year teachers. During 2017-2018, 80% of the faculty was replaced. The school is failed to meet the needs of black students, especially students and English language learners. The lack of consistency is damaging to the students of the community. Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record to provide public comment for John Henry. Your time starts now.
My name is Helen Chang and I'm a teacher in West Contra Costa Unified School District and already I've been working with colleagues to closely to plan for how to make connection with students, especially if we are starting the year distance learning environments.
The general, when you look at the data that the district has provided, it paints a picture of the governance or an institution that is generally chaotic and with such high staff turnover, it's going to be really hard to meet students' needs.
In addition, I ask that the board please deny the charter renewal as it creates a situation where the charter serves some students, not all, and any institution that takes public funds needs to serve all students. So I ask again that you please deny the charter's renewal. Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record to provide public comment for John Henry. Hi, your time starts now.
This is Katlyn O'Halloran with the Charter Schools Development Center. The Charter Schools Development Center has been a strong supporter of the larger Abe Method Public Schools organization since our deep involvement in its humble beginnings over 25 years ago.
Since then, AMPS has laid a remarkable track record of launching and operating schools that serve the Bay Area's most challenged populations. John Henry High is its most recent.
Though John Henry is only in its fifth year and needs to continue to improve to meet AMPS's organization's high standards, it has made significant progress and we believe it will continue to do so.
We also believe it meets the statutorily mandated standards for charter renewal and that John Henry is a far better alternative for its students than the schools they would otherwise attend. As such, we urge you to grant the appeal to renew the school's charter. Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record to provide public comment for John Henry. Your time starts now.
Hello there. Can you hear me? Yes, we can hear you.
Good afternoon. My name is Angelica Zermeno and I'm new to the community of Richmond and I'm also new to the AMPS community. I'm a former math consultant, also worked as a charter authorizer and worked for the WASC oversight committee.
I wanted to first applaud the board for looking at deconstructing some of the systematic issues that occur in education and I encourage you to look at what's happening now. It seems more political than anything else.
Maybe you might want to ask the questions of the authorizers if they did their part. Quality authorizers ensure that they support charters and help them improve and all I hear now is just nitpicking so it sounds more political.
I encourage you to look at quality charters and make sure that we're serving our schools because these kids are learning and I purposely chose to move to the AMPS community because they are fighting for all their students.
They're not selecting. So I just encourage you to keep it open. So thank you. Take care.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record to provide public comment for John Henry. Your time starts now.
My name is Brett Robbins. I'm calling at the knee of instruction at John Henry High School and I request that you renew the charter for another five-year term. John Henry High School was founded by parents and community members looking for a dependable pathway to college and opportunity for Richmond students.
A pathway that didn't exist for students in this district prior to the school's founding. Since opening, John Henry High School has produced a four-year college acceptance rate above 90% each year.
The schools that its students would otherwise attend by large margins in English, math, EL, progress towards proficiency and by even wider margins when you look at the most vulnerable subgroups.
These academic proficiency and college acceptance data must be prioritized in making this recommendation. The Black and Brown families of West Contra Costa have been denied a viable pathway to empowerment for far too long.
These communities have been disproportionately impacted during COVID and this is not an appropriate time to shut down their college preparatory high school that they've built in Richmond. Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record to provide public comment for John Henry. Your time starts now.
Thank you.
I'm Ramel Anton from the California Charter Schools Association speaking in support of John Henry High School. I want to re-focus the conversation to what is actually required by law and that is that economics be the most important factor in determining the renewal of a school with John Henry according to the CDE's report.
I want to point out that CCSA strongly stands behind quality authorization which we believe West Contra Costa has not offered. The first time that the school has been hearing about these pieces of feedback has come in this process.
We believe that if these were issues before hand there should be a healthy conversation between the school and their authorizer and this should not be the time to hold schools accountable.
I ask that you listen to the students that have offered their feelings about their school and how much they need their school. And the last thing I want to talk about is the population growth over time.
The numbers that have been presented are not static in terms of John Henry's population that they've made meaningful growth in all of the demographics that matter. Please support John Henry. Thank you.
Next caller please state your name and affiliation for the record to provide public comment for John Henry. Your time starts now.
Good afternoon to the board. My name is Edward Sklar and I serve as legal counsel for the West Contra Costa Unified School District.
And I ask this board to follow the recommendation of the CDE staff and not to renew the charter of John Henry High School. Contrary to John Henry High School's statement, this board may certainly deny the renewal under the law.
The district's decision not to renew comes with some context where A method public schools chose not to address what had been ongoing district concerns about recruiting English learners, particularly English learners who had less fluency in English,
about the educational program for English learners, about the lack of recruitment and program for students with disabilities, about a lack of staffing for these students, about high school and administrator, I'm sorry, high teacher and administrator turnover that was impacting the educational program,
and about a lack of transparency and accountability. The board should take this vote not based on the reputation of a school, but take a vote in light of the facts.
Keeping with the intent of the recent changes under AB 1505, we ask this board to honor the concerns of the district and not renew the charter. Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record to provide public comment for John Henry High. Your time starts now.
Hello, my name is Sarah Butler. I'm a trustee on the Contra Costa County Board of Education. I urge you to support the CDE recommendation for denial of John Henry High School due to the many issues involved.
Specifically, I want to call your attention to the West Contra Costa document in your documents folder titled NOV, which is for notice of violation.
The notice of violation includes, that was from November 2018, and I know that's a while ago, but some of these violations are still not corrected.
They included teacher credentialing, special education, the lottery and admissions process, and compliance with the confidential use permit for the facility.
Anyway, the admissions process is still a big problem. There are nine positions open of the 18 positions for John Henry, and special education, you've already heard, is not being done adequately for those students. Thank you very much.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record to provide public comment for John Henry High. Your time starts now.
Hola. Hi.
Un momento, por favor.
Translator, are you available?
Yes, to the person who is calling, if you can please give your public opinion on the topic of John Henry High. Say your name, affiliation, and proceed to speak when you like.
Yes, good afternoon.
Hello.
Is it for me? Yes, ma'am, I can hear you.
Yes, good afternoon. My name is Morena Larn. I'm going to need an interpreter, please.
Yes, ma'am.
Estoy hablando por John Henry. Soy residente de la ciudad de Richmond, madre de dos hijos, uno que se gradu este ao de John Henry y el otro que ir al nueve. Estoy agradecida con la escuela por haberme recibido a mi hijo. Vino hace un ao y medio del Salvador.
Aprendi el 90% de ingls, lo escribe, y est preparado para ir al colegio. Gracias a John Henry, a los maestros, a nuestra directora, por apoyarlo, por confiar en l. Espero tambin que mi hijo pueda ir y se pueda graduar. Tenga ese privilegio de graduarse en John Henry.
Me siento tan segura cuando me voy a mi trabajo, al contrario de las otras escuelas, donde hay una inseguridad en la que los padres estamos con miedo de dejar nuestros hijos porque a cada momento habla la polica que hay problemas.
Nosotros nos sentimos inseguros. John Henry tiene todo. Por favor, denos esta oportunidad. Necesitamos nuestros hijos. Necesitamos una alegra. Hace unos meses tuvimos una tristeza.
Translator can possibly get you to translate. We have about 20 seconds left in her comment period.
Yes, of course. Good afternoon. My name is Moreno Larry and I am calling on behalf of John Henry. I'm a citizen and resident of Richmond. I am mother of two, one that will be graduating this year, the other one is attending ninth grade.
We were here from El Salvador, and we are so thankful for John Henry 90% my son, it's 90% not proficient in English tank thanks to the teachers the support they supported him.
It would be a privilege for him to graduate and we feel confident in the work that they do here at John Henry, unlike other schools that are full of uncertainty and problems with the police.
I see that they have this uncertainty all the time, please give it another opportunity. We're full of happiness and we're just sad to see what's going on.
Thank you tons up.
Next caller please state your name and affiliation for the record to provide public comment for john Henry and begin speaking, your time starts now.
Hi, my name is Tammy Campbell and I'm an education advocate and taxpayer in the West Contra Costa Unified School District, requesting a denial of the john Henry charter to WCUSD staff provided you with an extensive report, and the school board denied the renewal of the charter on the following
Lack of growth for English language learners and declines in academic achievement, lack of transparency and accountability, failure of staff to provide a legally accurate special education program, significant teacher turnover, promotion of modern day segregation, and as a taxpayer it financially impacts my other public schools in my school district, and why would you turn over what the local jurisdictions have already deemed not renewable?
I urge you not to support the renewal of john Henry. Thank you.
Next caller please state your name and affiliation for the record to provide public comment for john Henry. Your time starts now.
Hello, good afternoon, my name is Coy Vargas.
I need a translator.
One moment please.
Translator, are you available?
Hello, please state your name to provide public comment.
Thank you.
My name is Coy Vargas and I have a girl in grade 10 who is going to 11.
I feel very happy to have my daughter in this school, since academically she has progressed a lot.
She has always been good at school, but now she feels very happy because the teachers help her a lot.
In fact, I don't know, but I feel happy that the teachers, the same director, make personal calls to tell us that our children need to complete a certain task.
I have the commitment to tell my daughter that she has to finish this task, especially in English.
The teacher and I are very happy with English because she has always put a lot of effort into it, and I am very happy with this school,
I am very sad that they are going to close it, but I always believe in God that it will remain open.
And I thank the teachers, the director, and all of you who do a wonderful job so that all schools are functioning well.
Especially John Henry, for me, it is a school that has opened my heart and I hope that all of you are there.
Translator, could you please provide us translation? Thank you.
Yeah, my name is Cuy Vargas. My daughter attends John Henry. She's 11 years old.
I'm happy to be...
I'm happy that she's at this school. The teachers are great.
Teachers call me to let us know if there's homework outstanding, and it makes me very sad to know that there's a possibility of a school closing.
I encourage you to please keep John Henry open. Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record to provide public comment for John Henry. Your time starts now.
Caller, did you want to provide public comment for John Henry?
Hi, this is Esmeralda Vinsalas. Am I on the line? Yes, you are. Please go ahead and we'll start your time.
Okay, thank you. Yes, I work at the front office at John Henry High School, and not only do I see the interactions between the students, the parents, the teachers, etc.
I see so much care that goes into and so much effort, not just on an educational level, but also caring for them, for their welfare, for what's going on with their families, and so forth.
I retired from the University of California, Berkeley, 37 years there. So many students told me how they wish they would have gone to a school like John Henry.
I wish that I could have raised my kids at this school, and they all graduated from West Hunter Costa Unified School District.
I went to Berkeley High School where predominantly there were other ethnicities, and Hispanics were not represented, but I can't blame the school for that.
I cannot, and I strongly urge you to please renew the charter for John Henry High School. Thank you so much for your time.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record to provide public comment for John Henry. Your time starts now.
Yes, good afternoon. My name is Edgar Quiroz, and I'm a homeowner, taxpayer, and resident of West Contra Costa County, and I serve as a volunteer board member of AMPS.
Thank you for the opportunity to express my sincere and strongest support for the renewal of John Henry High School.
As I sit here to listen to the opposition who is asking not to renew, I am appalled and saddened at accusations of this being a segregated model of education.
I'm a retired diversity and inclusion executive with Kaiser Permanente after 29 years, and to divide communities of color the way the opponents are is a disgrace.
John Henry High School matters.
The students and teachers of John Henry matter, and because of the parents and the community support of Richmond, Richmond matters. Thank you very much. Please vote in favor of John Henry High.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record to provide public comment for John Henry. Your time starts now.
You may now ask your questions.
My name is John.
John Henry High School matters.
The students and teachers of John Henry matter.
I'm sorry, caller, we're not hearing your.
Okay, my name is John Erminger and I'm a recently retired teacher in West Contra Costa.
I want to point out that the our local board rejected John Henry, the county rejected John Henry, and as of now, I know it was July 1st, the law changed.
So this definitely violates the spirit of local control. Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record and begin to provide public comment for John Henry. Your time starts now.
Hello. Yes, we can hear you. Please state your name and record.
Please. I'm sorry. Please say your name and affiliation.
My name is Jennifer laugh. I'm a community observer.
John Henry staff is diligent making connections with students and families outside of school time to ensure student success, which I believe is demonstrated in their test scores.
outside of school time to ensure student success which I believe
is demonstrated in their test scores their
four year university admission rates and their
recent six year WASC accreditation.
Though there are issues that John Henry does need
to address I would like to urge the board
to continue John Henry's charter both to allow
for clarification of the wide gap of information
presented by both sides today and to allow
the school time to remediate the cited issues particularly
because communication of concerns by the district
including the reasons for stated non-renewal have
disputed timing motivation and origin.
I'd also like to recommend that the board note
that multiple people called in on behalf of John Henry
earlier and many of our parents don't have the flexibility
of with work to ask for more hours off today
especially on short notice.
When we talk about barriers to access this is it in real time.
So I'd respectfully ask all board members and IT
staff to convene about 30 minutes to answer
the public part time which was 830 for today.
Tech happens but we've got to do better. Thank you.
Next caller please state your name and affiliation
for the record to provide public comment for John Henry.
Your time starts now.
Can you hear me.
Yes we can hear you.
Okay.
My name is Angel Lopez and I'm going into 12th grade
and I say that in theory because John Henry High School
has not been approved to continue operating
and I have been at every meet I have been to every meeting
with the state and the district and I have spoken
for my school without much understanding
of the reasons why people are interested
in John Henry High School closing.
In my school I am listened to.
My teachers are interested in me and they push me
to make an effort every day.
I find the support to them to finish my education
successfully and make it easier and they make it easier
for me to get into a four year college
and to actually finish it.
I am asking to please keep John Henry open.
Thank you.
Next caller please state your name and affiliation
for the record to provide public comment
for John Henry. Your time starts now.
Hi. Good afternoon. My name is Ingrid Gonzalez
and I was calling because I want the school to remain open.
I have my child who is currently in Benito Juarez
and I chose this school because of the fact
that you guys had the extension all the way to high school
and I didn't want my child to go through the process
of moving schools and you know having to meet
new friends and all that.
So I was very excited when I found this school
in my community with high stats high test scoring
good teachers safe location near the police station.
I am we are Latino parents we are a Latino family
and I never have ever felt any type of rage towards us
or even other you know racist African-American.
I've heard you guys think about that.
I don't believe this was racist racist at all.
I feel like every school every child is welcome.
So I do want you guys to remain open. Thank you.
Next caller please state your name
and affiliation for the record to provide public
comment for John Henry. Your time starts now.
Good afternoon. My name is Joanna Pace.
I'm the parent of a K-12 West Contra Costa
Unified School District graduate and I urge you to deny
the John Henry High School renewal petition.
Thank you for this opportunity to speak.
As a parent who's attended many many school board meetings
I've been appalled by John Henry High School's
lack of adherence to the laws regarding abuse
and harassment complaints by students.
Please listen to both the local school board
and the county school board deny the John Henry High
School petition for renewal. Thank you.
Next caller please state your name
and affiliation for the record to provide public
comment for John Henry. Your time starts now.
Would you would you like to provide public comment
for John Henry. One moment and we'll get the translator.
Thank you.
Time. Time translator.
Would you please provide a translation for us.
Certainly ma'am. Good afternoon.
My name is Maria Vargas.
I am speaking to support John Henry.
I am the mother of six and I am very happy
that my children attend the school.
One is there and one is about to get into ninth grade.
I am concerned when I heard about the decision
to close the school I would like for it to remain open.
I feel safe. I feel happy.
I see the grades of my daughter was there at John Henry
and that makes me happy.
I would like for it to keep it open.
My goal is for all of them to become professionals.
When you are a mother of six it is never easy.
I'm just calling in support for John Henry.
Next caller please state your name and affiliation
for the record to provide public comment for John Henry.
Your time starts now.
Hello.
My name is Patricia.
I'm calling because I want John Henry to remain open
because I see how John Henry has told my daughter
in her education and to complete her goals.
Also I have a son in seventh grade and I want him to have
the same opportunity as my daughter and I'm pretty
sure if you close John Henry my son will have
the opportunity that my daughter has.
Please renew John John Henry open.
To be honest I haven't enrolled my daughter in any school
because around my neighbor I don't see any good school
for her so please keep John Henry open. Thank you.
Next caller please state your name and affiliation
for the record to provide public comment for John Henry.
Your time starts now.
Hola mi nombre es Guadalupe Mign.
Un momento por favor.
Translator are you available.
Yes.
Thank you.
Siga seora Mir.
Hola mi nombre es Guadalupe Mign.
Tengo tres hijas.
Pero una est ah en John Henry y la otra va para
noveno grado.
Es muy importante para m como padre como mam saber que mi
hijo es un lugar.
Tiene excelentes maestros y libera tambin el bico.
Es mucho mucho muy bueno.
Lo veo reflejado en las calificaciones de mis hijas.
Veo la seguridad del lugar.
Es muy bueno. Los maestros son excelentes.
Y lo que viene siendo la directora ha hecho un buen
trabajo para que los estudiantes promoverlos y apoyarlos para que
sigan a la universidad.
Pido que por favor no cierren la escuela.
Ya que va a ser afectado para mis hijas.
El modelo se plantea de un lado por favor.
Necesitamos de su apoyo.
Para la apertura de John Henry.
Hello, my name is Guadalupe Mign.
I have three daughters, one currently at John Henry.
It is important for me to know that she can stay at John Henry.
They have great teachers.
There's great security.
The teachers provide support for my daughter to move on to
college.
I hope that they don't close John Henry.
Please, I pray that they stay open.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the
record to provide public comment for John Henry.
Your time starts now.
Good afternoon. My name is Dmitry Gonzalez and I'm a teacher
in West Bantacosta.
I am opposing the renewal of John Henry High School.
Currently, John Henry High School only serves 10 students
with IEPs.
This shockingly low number when compared to their total
population.
They have failed to recruit students with IEPs and have not
supported those students they serve.
In fact, the California Department of Education has
already flagged John Henry High School for failing the
adequate test, the few students they do have.
In 2018, WCOSD investigated a claim that SPED students were
not receiving their minutes as required in their IEP.
Staff found out that minutes were being made in three-minute
blocks at the end of class.
No one should think that three minutes is enough time to
adequately support student learning and development.
I ask that you please oppose the renewal.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the
record to provide public comment for John Henry.
Your time starts now.
My name is Nicole Estrada and I'm calling as a member of the
community in support of John Henry High School.
As a Latina working in the Bay Area tech industry,
I see how underrepresented we are in the Bay Area's largest
and most profitable industry and it deeply saddens me.
John Henry High School's success in graduating its black and brown
students into four-year colleges at a rate of over 90 percent
gives me hope that this reality is changing and that our
next generation will have greater opportunities
to participate and thrive.
Please follow the ACCS recommendation and renew
John Henry High School so that they can
continue their great work.
Next caller, please state your name and record
for the please state your name and affiliation for the record
to provide public comment for John Henry.
Your time starts now.
Hello community.
Yes.
Hello.
My name is Liam Dillow.
I'm a credentialed chemistry and technology third-year
teacher at John Henry High School and I'd like to express
my strong support for the school particularly
for its attention to underserved students.
I first want to point out what seems to be overlooked
today as it's shown in the data earlier.
We have a 91 percent low socioeconomic status
population which is actually higher than the rate
at the surrounding community.
In terms of racial equity I'd like to state
that our population is represented
of who applies which we do not control.
I will state that I personally had close relationships
with several of our students who happen to be black.
At least three of which who have spoken in support
of our school in recent hearings.
Three of my former students recently graduated
and are going to four-year institutions.
I hardly see how this constitutes
segregation or racism.
Our site leader has stated a plan to recruit
a more diverse population.
I'm personally willing to knock on doors
in the community to support this plan.
Finally our special education population
in my time in public charter schools I have not
seen more attention come to ELL or SPED students.
I've also seen at least seven of my students
with IEP's survival whole plan speak in support
of the school in recent hearings for John Henry.
Next caller please state your name and affiliation
for the record to provide public comment for John Henry.
Your time starts now.
Hello my name is Michelle Cordero and I'm calling
to tell you to please renew John Henry High School.
This school has helped me so much
by helping me achieve my goal.
My brother's in seventh grade and I would love it if he goes
to John Henry High School that we keep to achieve
his goals like I am.
Please renew John Henry. Thank you.
Next caller please state your name and affiliation
for the record to provide public comment for John Henry.
Your time starts now.
Hello can you hear me. Yes.
Hi good afternoon. My name is Luis Romo.
I'm a Richmond resident and graduate
of Richmond High School and now an employee
at A Method Public Schools calling in support
of John Henry High.
Despite the current uncertainty we still have more
than 120 families on our waiting list for the incoming
9th grade class.
Families remain hopeful and committed to John Henry.
We want the opportunity to continue building our program.
We've only we're only five years old and you can see
the positive impact that John Henry is making
in the community.
We have outperformed all of the surrounding schools
in both math English and math since we began
SBAC testing.
In 2019 John Henry received a 6-year WASC
accreditation status and a letter of support
from Dr. David Brown the WASC visiting chair.
This year we were recognized as one of the best
public high schools by the U.S. News and World Report.
In 2018 we received a letter of good standing
from WCC USD Superintendent and have not received
any complaints or letters of concern since.
And finally the 8CCS recommended that time will be renewed
by a 7 to 2 vote this past month. Please keep John Henry open.
Next caller please state your name and affiliation
for the record to provide public comment for John Henry.
Your time starts now.
My name is Don Gosney and I own an online
newspaper Radio Free Richmond which attempts
to disseminate what goes on at our charter schools.
I hope you all can understand that this isn't
about test scores and achievement.
It's about the school and you cannot divorce
John Henry High School from the company
that owns and operates it.
And that would be a method public school.
I sent you a detailed list of problems
that AMP has had with disclosure finances staff
and administration turnover on credentialed teachers
treatment of the community sexual bullying communication
with the community and the media failure to adhere
to their agreements failure to address concerns
repeatedly brought up by the WCC USD fomenting
a potentially dangerous situation at the WCC USD
board meeting when the renewal petition was initially
denied and some serious difficulty embracing
the Brown Act.
Given that my report didn't resemble any of the hundreds
of form letters you may have been sent.
I hope you had an opportunity to peruse it.
Given that we all want what's best for the kids
and their parents it would be nice to issue
a renewal condition on AMP's getting their
house in order.
But that's not an option for you is it.
So do you give AMP the five-year license
to continue as they have.
Time.
Doesn't solve any of the problems
that they've got just here. Thank you.
Next caller please state your name and affiliation
for the record to provide public comment
for John Henry. Your time starts now.
Hello can you hear me.
Yes we can hear you.
Please please state your name and affiliation.
My name is Jane Wong and I am a parent of two boys.
One attended John Henry and finished and had so many
offers from CSU's UC's and USC.
I'm a proud parent of this community and my second
son I hopefully will be in the same footsteps.
My request is please don't shut down John Henry.
It will be a disservice to the bright futures
of our leaders.
I am also a homeowner and I am still continuing
to pay seven bonds for the West Contra Costa
Unified School District seven bonds for the school district.
So we as parents should have choices for our children
to attend what schools they will need to propagate
their academic achievements and their career goals.
And they will definitely be strong constituents
in our community time and they will be leading
our community in the next few years. Thank you.
Next caller please state your name and affiliation
for the record to provide public comment for John Henry.
Your time starts now.
Hello can you hear me.
Yes we can hear you.
Yes good afternoon.
My name is Veronica Alvarez and I am calling in support
for John Henry High School.
I am proud parent of two daughters who are part
of the John Henry community.
My oldest daughter graduated from John Henry in 2019
and is currently attending a four-year university.
My 15-year-old daughter attended Richmond Chatter
Academy for middle school and completed
her freshman year at John Henry.
I was decided to keep her in the Ames family
because all of the help they provided for my
the support of my daughter my older daughter.
You are adding unnecessary stress to our students.
They worry about where they will go to school
for the next year.
Please keep that option open to them.
Parents enroll all children but they are the ones
who want to stay in the right decision life in your hands.
Thank you so much.
Next caller please state your name and affiliation
for the record to provide public comment for John Henry.
Your time starts now.
Hello.
Yes we can hear you.
I think you'll probably have some background speaker.
Background speaker.
Ok.
Would you like.
Oh can you hear me.
Can you hear me.
We need you to.
Hello.
said we need the volume on your computer please.
Hello?
My name is Cabo Establaro.
I'm a retired teacher with 20 years of experience
in our district.
And I am calling for a speaker.
We're receiving an echo.
You need to turn down the volume on your speaker,
please, on your computer.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record to provide public comment for
John Henry.
Your time starts now.
Caller would you like to make a public comment for John Henry?
Okay, we have no additional public comment in the caller queue at this time.
We do have several other callers that are on the call-in line.
This call-in line is for callers wishing to make public comment for John Henry High.
If you are calling to make a public comment on another school, we ask that you disconnect
from the line right now.
You'll need to call in when we're accepting public comment for that item.
Can we please get the Spanish translation of that also, that this comment that we're
accepting right now is for John Henry.
The calls that we're accepting right now are only for the number 20 on the agenda, which
is the case of John Henry.
For the next calls, you'll need to call in again and wait for the next call.
For now, it's only for John Henry.
Caller, would you, did you wish to make public comment for John Henry?
Hello?
Hello, we can hear you.
Did you want to make public comment for John Henry?
Yes.
Please state your name and affiliation.
Your time starts now.
My name is Dulce Bernal.
I'm the mother of a son in John Henry.
He's in 11th grade.
He wanted to attend 12th grade for next year.
I'm asking you to please consider to keep John Henry open.
My son is under a lot of stress because he doesn't know what school he's going to attend.
And also, he received a little bit of interest from different universities.
One of the universities in Bauer Harbor.
But letting you know that, that's telling you that John Henry is doing their job by
preparing our kids for the universities.
Many universities are looking to our kids and it starts the interest of them.
They don't want to keep John Henry open because they're doing a very lousy job not preparing
their students.
So I want you to take under consideration what our students, our teachers, our community
are doing.
So hard all this year for John Henry and they've been doing so much even if they have so much
stress.
So please keep John Henry open and don't give more stress to our kids and let them prove
that they can do much, much better.
Thank you.
Next caller, would you, do you wish to make public comment for John Henry High?
Caller would you like to make public comment for John Henry High?
Next caller, do you wish to provide public comment for John Henry High?
Caller do you wish to make public comment for John Henry High?
Yes.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
Your time starts now.
My name is Joaquin Robinette.
I'm a grad student in medicine and a recent graduate of the faculty of high school.
Speaker, speaker, we need you to turn down the volume on your computer.
We're getting an echo and cannot understand you.
Thank you.
Thank you for turning down the volume on your computer and you can proceed afterwards.
My name is Joaquin Robinette.
I'm a grad student in medicine and a recent graduate of the faculty of high school.
I'm a graduate student in medicine and a recent graduate of the faculty of high school.
My name is Joaquin Robinette.
Next caller, please.
Yes, I'm here.
Hello?
Yes, we can hear you.
Please start your public comment.
Yes.
Good afternoon, board members.
My name is Jeff Robinette.
I am a proud African American father of a 2020 graduate from John Henry High School.
I'm speaking on behalf of 15 African American students and their families on a wait list
who, if selected, are committed to attend John Henry High School in the fall.
While not guaranteed, these students deserve the right to attend a safe and progressive
school just as my child was able to do.
If John Henry is closed, please know that there will be no viable choices in the West
Contra Costa Unified School District for them to attend.
Time doesn't allow for me to list all of the outstanding achievements of this school.
Its permanent closure will devastate hundreds of students and their families as well as
having a negative effect in our community.
Please vote to keep our school open.
As far as the claim of lack of diversity where a black family, for us it was a matter of
choice.
John Henry High School not only welcomed us with open arms, but racism just simply doesn't
exist.
Time.
Fantastic school.
Please keep it open.
Thank you.
Caller, did you wish to make a public comment for John Henry High?
No.
At this time, we will disconnect you from the call if you're calling for today's fresh
start for the next item.
We'll need you to call back in when we're taking public comment at that time.
What time would that be, please?
When this item's public comment is over and the hearing is done.
Okay, is fresh start up next?
Yes, it's the next item, but unfortunately we don't have an idea what time that will
be.
Thank you.
Okay.
Bye bye.
Caller, did you wish to make a public comment for John Henry High?
Yes.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
Your time starts now.
Good afternoon.
My name is Bianca Forrester.
I'm the principal of Oakland Charter High School, John Henry Sister School.
I have worked in public education, serving the most diverse and deserving students in
the Bay Area for over 24 years.
John Henry High School serves over 90% SES and minority students.
Last year, John Henry was awarded a six-year WASC accreditation in no small part because
the school provides a comprehensive college preparatory curriculum designed to prepare
every student to meet the UC, CSU, A through G requirements.
Over 90% of John Henry graduates have been accepted to a four-year college or university.
Additionally, John Henry has outperformed all of the surrounding high schools in both
English and math for all subgroups since the school began testing in 2017.
The success of John Henry High School students in meeting the rigorous academic program
offered, classes that strongly correlate with later success in college and beyond,
illustrates why this school should be allowed to continue to equitably serve Richmond
students and families.
I urge you to vote in support of John Henry High School.
Thank you very much.
Next caller, did you wish to make a comment for John Henry?
Yes, can you hear me?
Yes, we can hear you.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
Your time starts now.
Hello, I am Natalie Garcia, one of the deans of instruction at John Henry High School
and a Richmond resident.
Amidst the worldwide pandemic and our current civil rights movement, we are living in uncertain
times and it is precisely why it is crucial to keep John Henry High School, a law school
accredited and nationally ranked high school by U.S. News, open for our schools and their
families.
It is a community hub offering resources, support, and academics among other things.
You should not listen to all the naysayers calling in.
We need teachers and adults who are spending their time to sabotage our school due to political
allegiances.
None of these loud naysayers have one step foot inside our learning community instead
of making false accusations.
West Contra Costa continues to dehumanize our students down to dollar bills as they scramble
to figure out how to get out of their $50 million deficit.
And false information is being disseminated even today, including during public comments
to our president stating that I don't have a clear credential.
Please check again because their credential is clear through 2024.
Let me remind you John Henry is the best in Richmond and has received a recommendation
from the ACFS board.
Unfortunately, West Contra Costa has only offered failing and unsafe traditionally large
public schools in our city of Richmond, and our families and students demand that this
not be their only option.
Please listen to the students, parents, and families who have elected John Henry as their
choice for their educational experience.
Don't get lost in all the smoke and mirror tactics.
Please vote to renew John Henry High School's charter.
Thank you.
Next caller, did you wish to make public comment for John Henry High?
Yeah, hello.
Can you hear me?
Yes, we can hear you.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record and begin speaking.
Okay.
Good afternoon.
My name is Kimberly Castro, a student at John Henry High.
John Henry has provided all the John Henry community, including myself, a safe and positive
environment that I know I won't experience at a public school.
I believe this is an issue between political groups that we students should not be dragged
into and taken our education away from.
John Henry challenges you into doing your very best work and to honor that hard work.
My sister attended a public school, and from what I've seen, she was doing very poorly
because of the education given to her and the environment provided.
At John Henry, I've noticed a dramatic change in her studies as well as her feeling safe.
At John Henry, I feel safe, and the education provided is outstanding.
Please don't take that away from all of us.
Vote in favor of John Henry.
Thank you for your time.
Next caller, did you wish to provide public comment for John Henry?
Yes.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
Your time starts now.
Good evening.
My name is Isora.
I had the opportunity of attending Richmond Charter Academy for all three years in middle
school.
In my three years at the school, I learned so much through expanding my education.
I experienced greater things than any other school in the area would have ever given me.
Due to some changes in my life, I had to move high schools and was blessed enough to have
landed in another great school.
Unfortunately, that meant leaving my friends.
With what this year has already brought us, I'm in shock and fear for the school, John
Henry.
Even though some of us were lucky enough to get out before all this happened, some of
my former classmates are still at risk.
The second option for them would be schools like Richmond High and Kennedy.
Knowing this gives me a very unsettling feeling because so many good kids I know will be thrown
into situations we all know of at other schools.
This organization left me with a greater mindset for my future and left all of us feeling safe
and set for what's ahead.
So to know that this could all possibly go away gives me a great fear for the ones I
left in love.
Thank you.
Next caller, did you wish to provide public comment for John Henry?
Yes, can you hear me?
Yes, we can hear you.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
Your time starts now.
My name is Juan Navarro and I'm a former student from the graduating class of 2020.
I have been part of AMS since seventh grade.
All of the teachers that have taught me have given me their all to make sure that we all
receive a good education.
My primary language is Spanish and John Henry has done an amazing job in helping me.
I am currently enrolled at a four-year university and receiving $20,000 in scholarships.
This is all thanks to my amazing inner teacher Ken Kasake who spent multiple hours of his
free time revising my essays and informing me of scholarships.
I am a first generation student and this type of support will not be achievable in a public
school.
I am deeply saddened that people are trying to shut down John Henry High School.
I have never witnessed the community that is present at John Henry.
We cannot let these people sway you or blind you from the greatness that is within John Henry.
Thank you.
Next caller, did you wish to provide public comment for John Henry?
Just a quick reminder, those in the call line, if you are waiting for the fresh start, please
hang up.
Once again, if you are waiting for the next item for a start, please hang up.
These comments, if you are on the call line, are only for John Henry.
John Henry, thank you.
Next caller, did you wish to make a public comment for John Henry?
Yes.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
Your time starts now.
Is this me?
Can you hear me?
Yes, we can hear you.
Great, thank you.
My name is Madeleine Cronenberg.
I was serving on the West Contra Costa School Board as a trustee when John Henry was approved
and I voted to approve it.
I'm calling today because I am truly disappointed in how many violations they have had since
the time of their approval.
I understand that they have some strong teachers who serve their community well, but they have
some very, very poor operations and governance procedures and that's why all these violations
are out there and left for people to be victims of.
It's really important that districts and schools not be allowed to treat employees and treat
the rules the way they have done.
So I please ask you now to look into that and to not allow the renewal to go forward.
Thank you.
Next caller, did you wish to provide public comment for John Henry?
Yes.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
Your time starts now.
Hello.
My name is Eduardo Martinez.
I'm a Richmond City Council member as well as a retired elementary school teacher.
I urge you not to renew the John Henry High School Charter.
As a classroom teacher, I have found that the unspoken policy of calling problematic
students from charter schools and casting them back into non-charter schools hinders
the abilities of teachers working with students whose parents cannot advocate for their
children and who end up in non-charter schools.
Statistics illustrate that this is what is going on at John Henry High School.
By looking at statistics, we can see that the, well, we can surmise that, anecdotally,
the school may serve some students adequately but fails the community as a whole.
We need schools that are inclusive in their ability to serve all students.
This is not happening at John Henry.
Thank you.
Next caller, did you wish to provide a public comment on John Henry?
Yes.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record and begin speaking.
My name is Suzanne Balmeseda and I'm asking you to please deny the petition of John Henry.
I am a parent and a teacher in West Contra Costa.
John Henry is not providing a strong academic program.
Overall, their math scores are going down quickly, according to the California School Dashboard,
and there are huge gaps between their Hispanic students and all other subgroups.
Their college and career readiness scores are also declining, even though they supposedly focus on that at their school.
John Henry has falsely claimed that they are a top high school in California,
but according to U.S. News and World Report, they are actually number 746 in California.
Several district schools are higher on the list and have higher graduation rates.
They do not serve the same population of students as our district,
and they do not do a good job of serving the few students from subgroups that they have.
Compared to their nearest district schools, such as Kennedy High and Richmond High,
John Henry serves significantly fewer English learners, special ed, and homeless foster students,
and socially economically disadvantaged.
Please do not renew John Henry, and they only have an 84% graduation rate last year.
Thank you.
Next caller, did you wish to provide public comment for John Henry?
Yes.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record. Your time starts now.
Hi, I'm Richard Peregrina, and I am going to be a senior next year at John Henry.
There hasn't been one year of my high school experience that I have not had to fight for my school,
and yet if I had to pick either Kennedy or RHS high school experience,
I would rather fight for John Henry all over again.
So please keep my school open.
And to the lady that said something about our school being racist and such,
I guarantee you that's the exact opposite.
And that's all. Thank you.
Please state your name and affiliation and begin speaking.
Hello, my name is Missy Perez-Caro. I am a homegrown educator in Richmond, California.
I work at my local WCC high school, about a mile from John Henry, named Kennedy High School.
I plead you to hear the voice of the community, your students, families, educators that are asking you
to reinvest into the schools that already exist here.
I am humbly requesting that you let the students come to schools like Kennedy High, Richmond High, or De Anza High.
These schools will welcome these students and families with open arms.
We want more students to be a part of programs or academies like information technology, media, law, health, theater, international, many more.
If they are interested in trades, they can work in wood shop or welding.
If they enjoy electives such as art, Kennedy has an amazing silk screening program that would be a great experience for them.
They have a promising future at our neighboring schools, and I would like to invite them to join.
And I implore you to deny John Henry High School. Thank you.
Next caller. Did you wish to provide public comment for John Henry?
Next caller, would you like to provide public comment for John Henry?
Yes.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record. Your time starts now.
My name is Miss Duguay, and I'm a credential John Henry teacher and Richmond resident.
John Henry admits to areas of growth, but the dashboard shows we have the highest percentage of ELL students progressing towards proficiency in the district.
And 71% of our student body are former ELLs redesignated as proficient.
We were issued a letter of good standing from the district in November 2018.
So old grievances need to be set aside so we can focus on these students' bright future.
Even today, the district compared our academic data with statewide averages instead of the surrounding schools that our students would otherwise attend.
The only time the district keeps it local is when looking at demographics because switching these lenses strategically supports their false narrative.
We do not have a selective admissions process, but we are a notoriously rigorous college preparatory program.
And we take the students who come to us who, by the way, are over 90% socioeconomically disadvantaged minority students.
Low African-American enrollment is a tragic charters issue, not a John Henry issue.
And Miss Flores is fighting tooth and nail to make John Henry a leader in changing the disturbing trend.
Cut through the noise. Vote John Henry. Thank you.
Next caller, did you wish to provide a public comment for John Henry?
Yes.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record. Your time starts now.
Hello, my name is Stephanie De La Cruz. I'm a student at John Henry High School.
I wanted to say that the John Henry High School is a very secure place.
I've been part of AMPS for five years. Thanks to John Henry, I was able to get a program,
enter a program at the University of San Francisco.
As the oldest sibling, I wanted John Henry to stay open so that my younger siblings would be able to attend.
So please do not close down the school. Thank you.
Next caller, did you wish to provide public comment for John Henry?
Yes, please.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record. Your time starts now.
Hi, my name is Art Orencila. I'm calling on behalf of Defend Public Education Now,
and we are asking the board to deny John Henry's application.
We are asking you to respect the district's denial and the county's denial.
These denials did not come easy. There was a lot of hard work put into them.
And I applaud the teachers and the members of John Henry for trying to save their school.
But the facts are the facts, and we're asking you to deny John Henry's renewal. Thank you.
Next caller, did you wish to provide public comment for John Henry?
Yes, please.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record. Your time starts now.
My name is Madeline Lozada. I was an ESL student, now reclassified as a speaker,
as a speaker of English, thanks to John Henry High School.
I'm so happy to be there, and I don't want the school to close because I'm so sad about it.
And also, they have so many programs like AB programs, and please, I really wanted to stay open. Thank you.
Next caller, did you wish to provide public comment for John Henry?
Yes, please.
One moment, caller, while we get the translator on the line.
Translator, are you available?
Hello, I'm online.
Did the caller wish to make public comment on John Henry?
Do you wish to make public comment on John Henry?
Yes, please.
Please state your name and affiliation and begin your public comment. You have one minute.
Say your name and affiliation and start with your public comment. You have one minute.
Good afternoon, thank you very much.
My name is Richard Luzada.
I am a proud father and I have my daughter who attends John Henry High School.
If you don't know, John Henry High School is in the top group of the best schools in Richmond.
And please, it makes no sense to close our school.
My daughter finished learning English thanks to this school.
Please consider the great education that staff provides here in this school.
She is in this John Henry High School.
She has found good AP classes and honors.
She is a very good student.
She has everything. She is a student who has pure A.
Please remember that having an opportunity to attend a good high school makes the difference to go to a good university.
I am also sure that you know very well the difference that there is here in places of little money like Richmond
compared to areas that have more money.
So it's not fair.
Time. Translator, would you please provide feedback?
Time is up.
Good afternoon. Yes. Good afternoon. My name is Richard Luzada.
I am the proud father of a daughter attending John Henry.
John Henry is one of the top schools in Richmond.
It doesn't make sense to close it.
She just finished learning English thanks to this school.
Please consider John Henry.
The staff, education, everything is good.
IEP, the classes, and my daughter is a straight A student.
Please give it the opportunity to continue with this good school.
You know that going to a good school makes a difference to getting to college or not.
And especially here in Richmond, there is a difference between schools versus other areas.
Please consider John Henry.
Next caller, did you wish to provide public comment for John Henry?
Caller on the line, would you like to provide public comment for John Henry?
Next caller, would you like to provide public comment for John Henry?
Yes.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
Your time starts now.
One moment and we'll get the translator.
Okay.
Yes, please state your name and affiliation for public comment.
Look, my name is Alejo Sabina.
I am calling for John Henry School.
I don't want this school to close because this is where my son is learning.
He is going to enter the 10th grade and he is learning a lot in this school.
I would like to not close this school.
I ask the senior staff to not close this school.
So, that is what I want, not to close it because this is where my son is getting more qualifications,
he is learning more in this school than in other schools.
Thank you very much.
Yes, my name is Alejo Salinas.
My son is a student at John Henry.
He is learning a lot at this school.
I beg you to please not close this school because he is learning a lot there.
Please don't close it.
Thank you.
Next caller, did you wish to provide public comment for John Henry High?
Next caller, would you like to provide public comment for John Henry?
John Henry? Caller on the line would you like to provide public comment for John Henry?
Yes. Please state your name and affiliation for the record. Your time starts now.
Hello my name is Rosa Kuriel. Good afternoon board members. I am here to support John Henry.
I am representing six families that were not able to attend the call. John Henry is important
to our community, our Latino community. John Henry has provided the students with higher
education and has offered a way to go to college and universities. Our seniors have been accepted
to UCLA, UC Berkeley, UC San Francisco, along with others. Our district says that they're ready for
our students. So they have a 48 million deficit. How do they plan to provide a quality education
to our students? I'm appalled to hear the teachers union calling to close the school.
They have not provided, they have failed our students and they continue to fail our students.
That's why there's so much learning gap in between. We need a quality school. John Henry,
that's what is providing our families, our Latino families. Time.
Just a quick reminder, anyone still remaining on the phone line, this is only for John Henry.
Again, this is for only for item 20, which is John Henry. All others need to hang up and call
back when that item is read. Thank you. Did you wish to provide public comment for John Henry?
Hello? Yes, we can hear you. Did you wish to provide public comment?
Yes, ma'am. My name is Jorge Lopez. My name is Jorge Lopez and I am the founder of AMPS,
the oldest charter school system in the East Bay. And perhaps more importantly,
I am born and raised in Richmond and raised in West Contra Costa schools. I became an educator
due to my experiences in Richmond schools, especially due to being expelled from Richmond
high school without due process simply because my mother did not speak English. I agree with
that public schools need to serve all kids. So if we look at West Contra Costa academic
achievement through the history, and I mean decades and generations of families, you will see
that black and brown kids have been severely mis-served in the West Contra Costa schools.
So just because kids are in the building does not mean that they are being served. Black and brown
poor students of Richmond deserve a shot at better outcomes of college. JHHS is one of those pathways
to a better future. If you look at the transitions in the West Contra Costa Unified School District,
you will see also so much turnover with three associate superintendents terminated,
two superintendents, one a lame duck. You will also see a chief academic officer resignation,
two SPED directors in three years. You will also see a HR resource associate superintendent also.
Time. So what's good for the goose is good for the gander. Keep JHHS open for the families of
Richmond, for family, community, and for equity. Next caller, did you wish to provide public comment
for John Henry? Caller on the line, did you wish to provide public comment for John Henry?
Caller on the line, did you wish to provide public comment for John Henry?
Did you wish to provide public comment?
Yes. Caller, did you wish to provide public comment on John Henry?
Yes. Thank you. Please state your name and affiliation for the record and begin speaking.
Your time starts now. My name is Lucy and I'm a 9th grader at John Henry High School. I just want
to say that John Henry is a good school that supports their students and they want their
students to go higher than they already are. I'm a student that is recently at the University of
Art and I really want to support the school. Thank you.
Next caller, did you wish to provide public comment for John Henry?
Hello. Yes, we can hear you. Did you wish to provide public comment for John Henry?
Yes. Your time starts now.
My name is Carlos Taboada. I'm a retired teacher with 20 years experience in our district
and I think I want to request this board not to renew John Henry's charter. They have had five
years, five years and that's enough time. They do not deserve another chance. They talk a lot about
English learners that they have but they fail to tell you that not one student was redesigned
fluent English proficient. Also, they have a tremendously high turnover rate in teachers.
Currently they are trying to recruit 10 teachers and yet in their job description they do not
mention the requirement of a teaching credential. It's time that we, this community, get together
and support our democratically controlled system of education. You must remember that
our school board denied the charter. Time. Please. Thank you.
Next caller, did you wish to provide public comment for John Henry?
Yes. My name is Conception and I have a daughter in John Henry and I really appreciate this call
because my daughter is having their engraved straight A and I really like it because teachers
have been improving a lot and they always focus and they do their homework and time so this is
something that I really love because they care about them and I also, the behavior and the
environment is really good. It's safe. So this is why I would like you keep John Henry open.
Thank you so much.
Next caller, did you wish to provide public comment for John Henry?
Yes. Please state your name and affiliation for the record and begin speaking. Your time starts now.
Hi, my name is Ajanta Dey and this is my seventh year at OCHS, which is the sister school of John
Henry. During these years, AMS has nothing been much supportive and always been very inclusive of
the staff population, which is one of the concerns which keeps coming, I see, and I do not understand
do not understand why John Henry is being closed down because I have all a lot of times
collaborated with their staff for student support and they have supported their students to the
best of their abilities and the leaders work as hard as no other school. For last two years,
this commotion about if it's getting closed or open is creating a lot of problems in our community
and I hope that you would take our problem under consideration and think about the student
population. Thank you in support of John Henry. At this time, we have no additional callers and
the caller Q&A and no additional callers for John Henry High on the participant line.
Thank you very much. At this point, before we get into public discussion among the board members,
I'm going to bring a close of adjourn the close the public hearing at 2 49 p.m. I'm going to
encourage us to take a 10-minute break so that people can be prepared for the next part of the
conversation, get a cup of coffee, whatever you need, and we'll resume at 3 p.m.
All right, let's see who we have back here.
I see Eileen and Idae, Jim, Brenna, Cynthia, Ting.
Kim will be back in a little while perhaps. All right, and I understand, Karen, do you need to
call the roll again? Yes, I will call the roll again. And then we can see if Patricia's available
to vote. Okay. So, Linda, you're obviously here. I'm talking to you. Cynthia? Yes. Here. Jim?
Yes, here. Matt?
Here. Brenna? Here. Kim?
Here. Idae? Here. Eileen? Eileen? Here. Okay. Ting? Here. Okay. And then, Patricia Rucker?
Here? Yay!
All right. So, I think we want to ask you, Patricia, while we have you, and we hope you'll
stay with us, to cast your vote on the previous charter school item on the Time Community School.
Okay, I do want to confirm that I did receive a written copy of the motion that was proposed
by Board Member San. As I understand what was written in the document I received, I will vote
reluctantly yes. Okay. Thank you. You voted yes, so the motion passes, Linda.
All right. So, we will now move on to, we can take that off the screen, and we will move on to
discussion on John Henry, and I'm going to turn to Ting first as our liaison for framing.
So, just I wanted to thank all the members of the community who called in and spoke on
John Henry, both for and not for the renewal, and I know that with these charter renewals,
unlike the new charter petitions we looked at earlier, these charters come with history
and varying perspectives of that history, and often they come with a lot of emotion and passion.
And so, again, just, you know, it is always helpful to hear from the public, and I just wanted to
commend those who called in, and especially the students who called in and advocated for their
school. And then from here, I just have the board members address, have any questions they have on
the charter. All right. Well, we will start our discussion. There were a lot of questions
raised, so I'm sure we will have many we want to explore. I did want to begin the conversation by
treating one issue that came up, which was the question about the performance of English learners
at the school. And just to point out that the English learner category is this unusual category.
As students gain proficiency, they leave the category. So, having your best students
reclassified at a high rate often means that the students remaining in that category
have lower scores because they're reclassifying at a high rate. And we did see that in this
charter school, the 90-plus percent of students who began as English learners and the 70-plus
percent proficient reclassification rate means that English learners are doing well in the school
and becoming reclassified. Those remaining in the English learner category are a smaller number
because of the reclassification of others and may have lower scores because those with better
scores are moving out of the category. So, that's something that we could illustrate statistically.
It's an unusual aspect of that subgroup and understanding their performance, but it seems
very important to understand that in this particular case. There are a lot of other
questions that came up that I think we will want to explore about the treatment of students in
special education, their recruitment policies, and suspension and expulsion policies. And I would love
to get back to those agenda items at some point. I do want to open it up to other board members
who have questions that they'd like to get on the table, but I wanted to start with that
clarification so that we can move on to the other set of pressing items that have been raised.
So, do I see any board members ready to hand one up? Yes, Vice President Strauss.
I have several comments and clarifying questions. It may be that other board members are wondering
some of the same things, so I won't do all of them. I'll do some and then see if other board
members have some and then come back. First, let me just say I think this was, I think John Henry
provides an opportunity for students in the community, and we heard from the students and
the parents, that's meeting a need. And I felt that strongly and I believe that that's important
to consider. However, I think the concerns that were raised in the denial and in the comments
are worth exploring, and I have several concerns. So, and I have an interesting question. So,
first, let me ask the petitioner. So, if this petition is not approved, the students will not
the students will not go to school this fall at John Henry. So, what plans have you made
to support students knowing that we're in July and schools likely to open in a month? What
communication and plans have been made? Because at this point, it's denied unless it is approved
here. So, I just wonder what you've done to think about that. Are you addressing that to the district
or to the petitioner? Hi. Thank you. Yeah, thank you for the question. So, in March when we received
the decision from the county to not hear our petition, and when they told us that we have
to go straight to the state board, I told my families that they needed to have a plan B,
an option if John Henry doesn't renew. Since then, we've been supporting families in trying to
enroll at other schools. Most of our families want to enroll at other charter schools,
but by then it was March. Most charter schools did not have any space. They had very long
waiting lists. The school closest to us, leadership public schools, they had a waiting list of over,
I think it was 75 students. So, they told us, you know what, we're most likely not going to be able
to accept any of your transfer students. So, we also helped them with the applications for the
district schools. However, at that time, the pandemic hit and the transfer office was closed
for several weeks at the district. We directed them online and we helped them with the online
applications, but our families continue wanting to enroll at John Henry for next year. So,
they told us that even though some of them have found another school, most of them haven't yet.
They either haven't received an offer from a school. A lot of them have told us that they're
going to pursue private schools or online schools if John Henry doesn't renew. And we've started to
make calls after the ACCS recommended for approval. We began making calls to ask what their status was.
Have they found another school? And like I said, some of them had, but the majority of them said
that they were considering online options. Some were even told that if they wanted a small school
within the district, that they could look at Greenwood Academy, which is a continuation school.
And in terms of the families wanting to stay here, we've had several town halls throughout
the summer and we started that in May. And they keep wanting to stay at John Henry. So,
like I said, some of them have found an option, most of them haven't. I would say about 70% of
them are still in limbo basically. So, let me just follow up with the district. If this charter is not
renewed, what would be the process for supporting these students, particularly as the transition
and how difficult the times are now? Hi there. This is Dr. Linda Delgado. I will start to answer
that and I may lob the rest of the question to Mr. Ruben Aurelio, who's also on the line.
We did write up a one-pager. Actually, the district has been engaged in preparation
for welcoming the students back when the initial petition was refused in the district.
So, we have prepared well, I believe, to welcome students back. I can clarify too that there is
another option for students who prefer a small school and that would be Vista Independent Study
High School, one of our district schools. And also, I'm going to mention that all of our larger
comprehensive high schools have a program called academies, which you're probably familiar with,
Linked Learning Academies of Learning. And they enable us to take a high school of 1,500 or so
students and break those kids into smaller groups. So, if the students were to, say, attend Richmond
High School, they would be in a cohort that's about 150 students and they would move through
most of their classwork with that same cohort of students. So, it offers the benefits of
a large school but the crowd size of a small school. Thank you. And I'm just going to ask
the petitioner. My understanding is there was a notice of violation in 2018, so almost two years
ago. And now we're at 2020 and I'm just wondering what you did to address the notice of violation
at that time. Yeah, yeah, yeah. So, we entered into a resolution agreement with the district
and in November of 2018 we received a letter from Mr. Matt Duffy, who's the superintendent for the
district, a letter of good standing, meaning that we had addressed these violations or these concerns
on the resolution agreement. So, ever since then we've had to submit several documents to the
district. We had to submit our credentialing status every quarter. We had to submit
plans for professional development and we have not received any letter of concern,
any complaint from the district since we received that letter of good standing.
In the resolution it stated that if there was any concern, Amps and West Contra Costa would meet
and confirm if any issue arose. And so far we haven't had any issue arise. We haven't had any
requests for a meeting and we've been serving students well. So, Dr. Delgado, you and your
presentation actually appeared to challenge and listed quite a bit of violations. So,
do you believe that the John Henry High had addressed the notice of violation and is in
good standing or did you believe that that wasn't true? I believe that they did the very best they
could back when things were due, back when various submissions were due as per the agreement.
The gentleman who led most of that charge is no longer with the organization. So,
I think some institutional knowledge was lost. So far as the concerns that were called out on the
notice of violation, special education was one and as you heard from the presentation today continues
to be a concern with the district. They're among our most vulnerable students and they are students
who we are keenly attached to protecting. Also around credentialing, there has continued to be
quite a bit of turnover at that particular school as well as the other two schools in the district.
So, I would say credentialing continues to be a concern. Let's see, I think I'll leave it at that
for now. Oh and so far as we there were some communications with the school surrounding
questions such as provision of free and reduced lunch. Apparently there was something in the
handbook and paper disseminated to parents saying that there would be a penalty if free and reduced
lunch were or if parents were not current with their lunch bill, report cards would be withheld
and things like that. So, there have been some communications back and forth of the district
endeavoring to notify the school when there are issues and work with them as best we can.
Thank you. So, I have one more question and then I'll leave it to my other board members. I'm sure
there are more. To the petitioner again, there was a concern about obviously your demographics
not representing the local community and concern about your admission require priorities
which have been changed from your original petition to give priority to. So, that doesn't fit
with what you said you would do to address the lack of representation of certain groups. So,
how do you address the issue of the admission priorities considering that the population is not
as reflective as it is supposed to be? Yeah, thank you. You're right. We haven't had
the preference for students coming from an AMP school in the past. The reason why we decided
to add that to this petition is because our elementary, middle and high school are on the
same block. They're right next to each other. So, we wanted to have a K-12 system and right now,
I mean, we've been working on this recruitment outreach plan because we do want to diversify our
school. It's not that we want to stay the same. We do want to diversify. We've been trying to work
with, you know, many different stakeholders. With church groups, we created parent groups
in order to support the addition of English language learners, of SPED students, of African
American students. Just in one year, we increased from 11% to 22% our English learner population.
This happened from 2018 to 2019. We're open to working with you guys, to changing our preferences
if that's what's needed. Like I said, we added it because we had a campus that was right next to
each other. But if that is going to create an issue, we are open to removing it or changing
the priorities. Can I follow up on that a little bit? Yeah, and I'll wait after that for my other
colleagues to comment. I just wanted to follow up on that particular issue and just get a little
more clarity on some aspects of it. On the English learner population issue, if you continue to be as
successful in moving kids towards reclassification quickly as you have been in the lower grades,
that will go down again. So I just want people to understand that you have to watch,
think about that population differently than others. But I am interested in what your specific
recruitment plans are for African American students and for students with special education needs.
And I know you mentioned that quickly earlier that you have a consultant working with you as a
recruiter, but I couldn't catch it all in the speed with which you had to explain it. So could
you tell us more about what you will be doing in the context of recruiting African American students
from the community and recruiting and keeping students with special education needs? Definitely.
So right now we just started working with the consultant. It's KDI Carter Zone and they are
allowing us to use this GPS tracking. So they do their own breakdown of students who have
special education, I'm sorry, language that is the ethnicity, race and ethnicity. They have
that specific tracker and it helps us as a charter school to target areas. We haven't right now worked
with middle schools in order to go into the middle school and do an outreach event. I was working at
Oakland Charter High School three years ago and I was there for four years on different leadership
capacities. I was a counselor there. And when I came to Henry, I'm a resident of Richmond. That's
the reason why I decided to transfer over here. And we were seeing that, yes, the demographic
population wasn't resembling the district. So one of the strategies that has worked or that I
noted that it worked was going to the middle schools and providing the support for families
to apply and also the information because sometimes they don't know what options they have
and how to apply. So this is an online application through Enroll West Contra Costa. All charter
schools in Contra Costa have been using this third party system in order to run their lotteries.
So we are thinking, why don't we go to a middle school? Why don't we set up a table and outreach
and maybe work with the leadership team at the middle schools who have high percentages of
African-American students in order to be able to give the families the information. And they
choose whether they want to apply to our school. But we're there to support them and help them
with a computer, with staff who are going to help them apply. And then the other thing is that we
are, some of our students who are currently enrolled, some of them have already graduated,
specifically African-American students. This year we started a partnership with other
charter schools. We created the African-American Task Force. And it's a group that we meet every
quarter or every two months, I believe, in order to discuss this issue. Because it's
not just an issue at John Henry High School. It's an issue at a lot of the charter schools
in our community. So we are working to do an independent, basically like a survey and hiring
that consultant to come in and talk to them to be able to see what is missing. How would we be
able to attract more African-American students, more special education students, more English
language learners to our school? And also in terms of the Task Force, we are, we're seeing that a lot
of the work is very effective through word of mouth. So we've been working with pastors
from African-American churches. And we've been working with families who are connected in the
African-American community in order to go to events and in order to pass out that information
and let them know that we exist, let them know that we're there, let them know that we're in
the marina, that we're safe school, and help them apply to our school, diversify our African school.
Okay, that's helpful. Let me see if there are others who would like to,
I'm not seeing anyone with their hand up yet. Oh, there we go. Mr. Navo.
Yeah, I want to, yeah, I just want to echo Board Member Son and Board Member Strauss' comments.
And Board Member Strauss, you asked a lot of the questions that were on my mind, but
one in particular that I don't know that we've had a chance to dive in a little deeper to is
the question around credentialing. So for the petitioner, I know that the district
raised a number of questions around credentialing. There were a number of callers that called in.
Can you tell us what you're doing, how you're addressing that issue?
Yeah, definitely. Since we received the notice of violation, like I told you guys before,
we had to submit a very detailed credential list. Every one of our teachers, the 18 teachers that
we've had, we had to provide their credentials. We had to provide the number of their credential,
whether it was preliminary, clear credential, whether they were on a short-term staff permit.
Every single teacher at our school has a credential or a permit in order to be in the
classroom. We do not allow anybody who doesn't have the appropriate credential to be in the
classroom with students. So we have been fully staffed. At the beginning of this past year,
we did have a substitute teacher in one of our classrooms, but the teacher was there
for 30 days only. They weren't there for any longer than that. So we follow the law. We follow
credentialing requirements. And there hasn't been any, like I told you before, there hasn't been
any communication from the district saying that we do not have, or that we have a problem, that
we have an issue. They have not asked us to meet and confirm regarding any issue in terms of
credentials, in terms of spread, nothing like that. There have been certain issues brought up
that are not related to our school. They're not related to John Henry High School. And that,
I think, is where the confusion is happening.
Would you like to clarify that? Yeah, thank you. Yeah. So there, one of the issues that was brought
up was that there was an investigation regarding a lot of different things. And that, we did have
an investigation. That investigation was, I believe, in 2017, 2018. So basically,
with that investigation, it was an independent, it was Oracle, and they came back and they told
us that the allegations were unsubstantiated. So there was nothing there. And then after that,
we received basically that notice of violation. And once again, we received the letter of good
standing. We have not had any issue. There was someone who brought up a spread concern
in regards to a letter from DREDF. That was not at our school. I honestly don't have information
because that wasn't part of our school. We have not had any complaints or any letters of concerns
since I joined the organization in 2018. I think at this point,
Board President, I'm going to back away and let other board members ask questions.
Okay. Member Rodriguez is waiting.
So I had a couple of the questions that came up and another question. But I saw that Miss Elgato,
you raised your hand, and I'm not sure if it was in response to the last issue.
So if she could answer. Well, we work with board members at this point in the conversation.
Okay. All right. I thought she was going to respond to that. So I similarly had the question
that Mr. Navo brought up regarding the credentialing. But also when you said an
investigation of things, were there, could you be specific about what things and was that at your
site during the time that you were there? It was not during the time I was there. It was
before I joined the organization. I joined the organization in 2018-19, specifically at John
Henry High School. I had been working at Oakland Charter High School our sisters prior to that.
So the investigation took place in 2017-18. And like I said, that investigation was through a
third party. It was through Oracle. And yeah, once again, the allegations were unsubstantiated.
We can send you information on that. I also have our board president here who can answer
to that question in more detail if I'm allowed. That's okay. I'll go on to my next question.
So somebody made a comment, a public comment regarding teachers being encouraged to falsify
documents and that TFA was no longer sending teachers to your site. Can you respond to that,
please? Yeah. So the first part of that, it was in the investigation. Once again,
it was unsubstantiated. The second part, TFA, we haven't worked with TFA. John Henry started in
2015. We have not worked with TFA since we started. We didn't have the partnership. So we've never
had TFA say, oh, well, we're going to investigate you guys and we are not going to send teachers
there. In terms of my dean of instruction, Natalie Garcia, she was a part of Teach for America and
she has been there for the past two years. So I don't know where the TFA investigation took place,
but it definitely didn't take place at John Henry High School because we were open since 2015 and
I know that we have been working with TFA since. Thank you. All right. I'm going to
ask Ms. Delgado if she wants to add a point here that was on the previous matter and then see who
else wants to, then we'll go to our next board member. Thank you. Regarding the 2017-18
investigation, yes, that was conducted and according to our review of the investigation,
it was perplexing in that the items that were investigated had to do with actions that were
taking place at John Henry High. And of the people who were interviewed, there was not a
single interview of a teacher or a staff member at John Henry. All of the interviews took place
with people who were from the central office. And in the words of our attorney, it was not a
serious investigation. So moving on to the other issues, I think we've conflated a couple of
different things. There is the letter of good standing and there is the notice of violation.
The school was allowed to move on and attempt to rectify their issues, but the letter of good
standing was related to funding issues and was issued specifically so that the school could
continue to draw down federal resources. Could I ask, our attorney is available to answer these
questions in a little more detail. Are we able to bring him into the call?
If he is not currently here, I don't think so. I think he's standing ready. And also,
I just wanted to return really quickly to the issue of reclassification. I pulled up the
reclassification data for this particular renewal and students redesignated last year for John Henry
were exactly 0% of total of 12.5%. That's the number that connects to the presentation earlier.
So zero students were reclassified. They did, as I mentioned in the presentation,
just recently redo their reclassification process. So I think that was put into place this year. And
I think it's early to say how effective that is because there's simply no experience with it yet.
I don't know if the petitioner wants to say anything about that. I do want to get to member
Glover Woods. And I just want to frame this to say that at this part of the conversation,
we're really trying to prioritize the questions that board members have. We've heard from both
the petitioner and the district. So we want to stay specific to the questions that are getting
raised. And did you want to respond on the reclassification and how that played out this year?
Yeah, so the reclassification policy was in there even before John Henry High School opened
because we've only been open for five years. Every so often we look at our English language
learner program. We take a look at our reclassification policies. We take a look
at the state or the California Department of Education County, all of that. And yes,
last year we did submit a new reclassification policy to the board, which was approved.
And in terms of 0% of our students being reclassified last year, that is correct.
We did not have students who were at that threshold yet. And prior to that, the first two years that
we opened, we saw that there were a lot of students who were long-term English learners.
And we decided to reclassify at that moment because they were proficient. So we, last year
we didn't have many or we didn't have any students. Then this year we did reclassify some. So it just
depends on the year. It depends on where our students are at. We're not going to reclassify
just because we want our numbers to look a certain way. We want to make sure that our
students are ready to succeed and we're a college prep school. So we definitely want to make sure
that our students are meeting the proficiency standards in order to be reclassified.
And you noted that you had recruited in a lot of new English learners in this last year. It's such
an unstable category that that's why I just want people to keep those points in mind.
Member Glover Woods. Thank you, President Darling-Hammond. First, I'll proceed my
question while I was saying that it was encouraging to hear the comments from the students
that are being served and the positive statements from the parents as well.
Many of the concerns I have have been brought up by my fellow board members, but I would like to
drill down on a particular topic, which is the recruitment and the work that's being done to
diversify the student population. It's been mentioned and I believe Ms. Flores, you mentioned
that there are a lot of efforts planned or either have started as far as working with
churches, working with students at the middle school level to again increase the population
of African-American students and students with disabilities. My question to you is how long have
those efforts been taking place? Did the start of those efforts coincide with the
decision to revoke the charter or were those efforts that were put in place before?
And I have one other question after that, but I'll stop there for that first response.
Okay. Yeah. So we started these efforts recently and it wasn't because of the
notice. It wasn't due to the notice of violation that we had from the district.
That effort started this previous year. When I came to John Henry, I basically saw that we needed
to do some work. We needed to improve. We needed to diversify. We needed to make sure that our
students, that we had a representative group. And unfortunately in one year, we, you know,
haven't seen the progress that the district wants us to have yet. We're asking for a little bit more
time. We in 2015-16, which was the first year, we only had ninth and tenth graders. And then
the following year we included, or we, you know, we went up ninth, tenth, and eleventh. So
we didn't have that many students applying to our school. We're a brand new school. We tried to
recruit from the different quarters that were around from Richmond Charter Academy, which was
our middle school within the AMP system. We went to Richmond College Prep. We went to
Caliber, to Waves Academy. But where we haven't done yet is we haven't gone to
district middle schools in order to do that outreach. So we definitely want to open up that
channel of communication. Last year we joined the district enrollment fair. That was the first year
that charter schools were invited to the district recruitment fair, which was huge.
It was at the Richmond auditorium. So we were very happy that we finally had established that
communication between district and charters. And it wasn't just, you know, our charter.
It was chartered all over the West Country across us. So since I started at John Henry,
yes, there is work to be done. And I am committed to doing this work. We at John Henry,
like I told you, it's not just me. It's our families. They want to be able to help. I had
one of the parents tell me, her son was graduating. We did a drive-through graduation.
And she told me, hey, Ms. Flores, if you want me to stay in the task force, I'll definitely stay.
She's an African-American parent. Her child had special education. And she was like,
I love the program. I want to help. And I want to help you guys recruit more students
to diversify the school and to be able to achieve the demographics that the district is
asking for. I definitely don't want John Henry to close, even though my child doesn't go there
anymore. He graduated. I still want that to happen. So we definitely have those connections.
We have been building more and more community connections with our outreach. I'm sorry,
we hired an outreach coordinator. It was two and a half years ago. And they have also been
helping with the serving in the African-American task force through West Country Cross the charter
schools. And we've been, in my opinion, we've been making progress. We were not there yet.
That's not, you know, I'm not trying to stay at the current level. I want to improve. And I want
to make sure that our school is representative of our district numbers. And that's why we're open
to changing our preferences if that's what's needed. We thought that it was good to include
the neighboring school, the Richmond Charter Academy, which is right next door.
But if that's not going to, you know, give us the results that we need,
then we're willing to work with that. Linda, this is Stephanie. I just wanted,
wouldn't you get a moment to respond? Okay, I do have just a couple of follow-up
questions. They're not necessarily a couple of follow-up questions, maybe one more. It seems
that it's been fairly recent for the school to reach out to the community organizations,
the faith-based organizations that may provide support and services for predominantly African
American community. Maintaining confidentiality, of course, for students and families at John
Henry, of the three percent African American student population, approximately how many
families would you say are actually represented in that three percent?
What do you mean, how many families are represented in the three percent?
Correct. So if you have three percent, based on the numbers that have been shared, three percent
of your student population being African American, how many different families make up that three
percent? Yeah, we currently don't have any siblings between African American families. So out of the
315 students that we have, if we, I'm doing like math here, it's about... About 10 kids.
10 students, yes. And so there are 10 different families. Like I said, we have two of the families
who are really strong in terms of being in the community and helping put the word out there.
This year, the lottery, we've seen huge increase in the amount of students that are applying
and we are diversifying our recruit, our applicant pool. So I do expect us to move up in terms of
that. Thank you. Thank you very much. I heard Stephanie's voice a moment ago. I tried to find
you on my Hollywood Squares, but go ahead, Stephanie, if you would like to make it up.
I don't know that I'm on the Hollywood Squares. So I just wanted to respond that I appreciate
hearing for the first time all of the recruitment strategies that John Henry is putting in place
now, which is great. But I also want to make sure that it's understood that you can put in great
recruitment strategies and you can have a lot of kids on the wait list going into the lottery,
but if you don't change the preferences, you're not really going to see much of a difference
unless those kids are already in the AMP system. So the recruitment strategies are great, but it's
not going to make much of a dent if the preferences stay the same because all those kids are in the
lottery. And as you know, once you're in the lottery, those preferences kick in. But I just
wanted to clarify that. Thank you very much. And that I'm not seeing any other board members hands
up, so that may get us close to the question that we might want to be raising, which is,
as we have experienced in other cases, if we want to consider conditions, those might include
conditions around the preferences or other features that we've heard concerns about.
So this is, oh, Brenna has her hand up. And if anyone else wants to get in the conversation,
this will be the time to flag it so that we can move forward towards a vote.
Linda, after Brenna, Patricia Rucker would like to ask a question, too.
Great. And then I have member Strauss also in the list. Go ahead, Brenna.
Yeah, just quickly. Hi, there. So, you know, I think the school is already committed to
responding positively to the conditions, you know, and we're ready to implement whatever it is that
the state board decides as conditions. You know, with lottery preferences, as Director Farland
mentioned, those can be a helpful way to change up demographics, because we're, of course, we can't
have any preferences that discriminate on the basis of race or ethnicity.
And in terms of the suspension and expulsion...
I think we want to know about the suspension and expulsion policy in very specific terms.
Sorry, is that for me?
That was raised as an area of concern.
So the area of concern that was raised was regarding our handbook. So on the petition,
I don't believe that there were any issues that arose. It was related to the family handbook,
which was online, and it was an old family handbook that we had used in previous years.
We have since removed that language. In the presentation from CDE staff,
you guys saw that one of the blocks was for suspension. We are in the green.
Our suspension rate is very low. In the past five years, there has been one expulsion,
unfortunately, but we tried our best to support every single student. We have used
reserve justice practices. We've been working with our previous dean of students. It wasn't
that he left the organization. He transferred to the elementary school. He taught us a lot
when he was here, and we've been instituting those practices. We've been systematizing those
practices, and we definitely don't like to suspend students. We don't like to expel students at all.
As you can see, our dashboard data is in the green for suspensions because we've been using
other methods when there are behavior issues that arise. We're not in the business of suspending
or expelling students. We have two amazing counselors who have been working tirelessly
with our students. They support them since they're in ninth grade. Two counselors for a student body
of 315, we think that that is part of the reason why our suspension rate is so low, because we are
able to serve them and to start working with them in groups and all of that.
So I hope that answered the question. If you need more specifics, I'm open to answering that.
I thought that was clear. Did you have anything else, Brenna?
Brenna, did that answer your question adequately?
Are you frozen? I think Brenna's frozen. Brenna, are you able to try again?
Yes. Can you hear me now? Yeah. Can you hear me? Yes. I was just going to ask what the
restorative justice practices were, a little more specifically.
Okay, can we get a succinct rendering on that? And then I do want to move to a couple other
callers waiting. You can move on. You can move on. Okay. So I think Member Rucker is waiting to
get in. So I'm going to acknowledge her, because she's had such a hard time today. We definitely
want to hear from her when she's able. Patricia, can you get in? I'm hoping you can hear me.
We can. Yes, we can hear you. Okay. Well, first of all, I want to thank my family. I'm so grateful
to have you here. Thank you so much. We can hear you. Okay. Well, first of all, I want to thank
my fellow board members. I think you've been having some psychic moments in reading my mind
and asking a number of my questions. So the frustration with the technology really and truly
has not hampered my ability to feel that I'm participating in this call. So let me just say,
I heard the President suggest that maybe we could consider looking at some conditions as a way
of looking at how to approve or how to move forward on this particular charter. And let me
just give a little perspective from where I'm sitting out here with the inability to speak
in some detail about that. There was yesterday you created some conditions for approving a charter,
and the conditions on that charter were significant and important, primarily because
it addressed an opportunity for the development of a new program and a specific approach
to serve a particular community. And we just, on the previous item, also approved a number of
conditions to correct a charter application or to correct a renewal that had problems that through
all of the conditions that are happening right now, at this exact instance, through the hearing
process, just there was simply interference for a lot of conditions that were probably unique and
different conditions. And so I understand why those conditions were added to that charter,
especially given the fact that we would have a partner with the local LEA that would be doing
a lot of the oversight and monitoring and support with the implementation and the work that that
charter would be doing as it opened going forward. This charter is different. In listening to the
presentation from both sides, there obviously is conflicting information. There's also a conflating
of a lot of ideas or a lot of points of information about whether the charter was substantially out of
compliance or had met their compliance requirements from the notice of violation. And the district,
and I found the district's presentation was very compelling in pointing out what the problems
of this charter were. These are not new problems. These are not problems that have arisen
in the past couple of months. These are problems that have been recurring and occurring throughout
the period of the relationship the LEA has had with the charter. I'm concerned that there is a
teacher recruitment and preparation program, Teach for America, who thrives on not only an
innovative program for developing teachers but also looks for innovative opportunities
for their workforce to go into teaching, has decided to change or alter their relationship.
And I'm further concerned that despite what the charter management organization is saying about
what they have done and what they are now trying to do, the district is quite clear that this is
something that the problems are things that they are aware of and that they either have not addressed
or have been inadequate to address. So I'm not sure how a set of conditions for this charter
are going to resolve problems that fall somewhere on the continuum between you haven't done nothing
or you simply haven't done enough. So I'm concerned not only about the quality of the management of
this charter but I'm concerned that the problems are not simply going to go away with a set of
conditions aimed at trying to support the charter as you have with the previous two items and the
previous two hearings. The conditions are not the same and I do not have faith in the ability
of this charter to address these problems because they clearly have not done so up to this point.
I'm done.
I will make a small response just to the reason why I raised that question. By law, the primary
metric we need to use is the performance of a school in relation to the other schools that
students would attend in its absence and it's clear that in this particular case,
students in this school are outperforming those in surrounding schools in English,
Language, Arts, and Math. So we have a burden of growth in relation to this particular renewal
and we've heard a lot of the back and forth about different conditions but some of those have
stayed on the table and some of them have been moved off the table and so I think
it would seem reasonable to be thinking about that question but I would love to
hear from the other board members and member Strauss is next in the queue.
The only comment that I wanted to make was that I had some very strong concerns about
the turnover and the amount of teachers. We know it takes teachers a couple of years,
three to five years to gain confidence and skill set to really make a difference
and so the amount of turnover I was very concerned about and also in the whole
management organization, it seemed like there seemed to be, as I heard from the district
presentation, a lot of turnover. I don't know that that's a condition we can put in because who
knows what the causes are obviously for recruitment and support for teachers as they develop but I
just want to put that on the table that I am concerned about the constant turnover as it was
presented. I have one other factual question I'd just like to ask which is the question about the
role of the county offices. I believe I understood and maybe Stephanie is the one to answer this
question. The district denied and then the county declined to hear the appeal, is that right?
I believe they heard the appeal. They declined to take action.
Is that correct? Yeah, no, they didn't hear it at all. Okay, I'm sorry, they didn't hear it at all.
They declined to hear it at all. So they did not, they did not deny the charter?
No, they did not. And do we know anything? I mean, I would love a little background about
what it means when a county steps aside and says we're not going to hear the appeal.
Should I respond to this? Yeah. This is Judy Sias with the Chief Council for the State Board.
Under the law, the county has the option to not hear the appeal. So I don't think we can
try to presume what their motives were or were not. But if they declined to hear it,
there's nothing in the record as to their issues or concerns or anything about this charter school.
Okay, so we can just correct the record on that score and move to any other.
Questions?
Linda, Matt has his hand up. Okay, member Navo.
I just have just a few questions for C.D. Just to Stephanie, are you, are you there?
Yes, I am here. Sorry. Okay. I know I saw you walk away. I just want to get back to
brass tacks a bit, because I do sense that there's a struggle between what the district
sees and understands and what the petitioner sees and understands. And I see a petitioner who,
by all extensive purposes, seems to be willing to try and make whatever adjustments are necessary.
But I just want to go back to the original presentation. The charter was academic,
academically, it met the requirement. Is that correct?
Yes, it met the threshold for the academic renewal criteria. Yeah, it did. Yes.
And it, okay, and it met the requirement fiscally?
They are, they are fiscally, yes. Yes, they are.
So the issues that we're talking about are related to the, the program, but it sounds
like we're also talking about things of the past.
What is, what is all of this fall under? Right. I would say that the, the, the,
the primary issues would be access for students to attend the school. And that was whether students
in the district have access to the school. And that was one of the primary issues. We also had
issues with some of the elements that we had, we had gone over in the presentation
in terms of employee qualifications and in terms of the suspension expulsion,
which they addressed in terms of retirement coverage, dispute resolution. But I would say
that the biggest concern for us and the, and the, the issue that we really wanted the board to,
to discuss was this issue of access for all students and whether or not moving forward,
if they moved forward over the next five years, students would actually have,
more students would have access to the school, which we found not to be the case because of the
preferences they put into their admission requirements. And so I, I think the department
feels that access is an important issue when it comes to charter schools. It's something that
we've discussed in other items and other appeals over the course of the last year or so. And I'd
say that was, that is very much a concern. Okay. That, that helps a great deal. So
really what, either the preferences change or the potential that we're going to be continuing
to deal with this issue. Yes. Yes. Because recruitment is great, but if you don't change
your preferences, then there's no other way for other types of students to come in.
So that becomes the issue. And I got to, I have a question about 1505.
The charters that the state authorizes, right? When 15 after July one, we're past July one. So
we're, where do they fall? Where does this charter come back to for renewal? They say
they are approved for five years. Where do they come back? Us or the county office, the authorizer?
After, I think it, they would go back to the local, the local district. Yes.
Okay. That, that, okay. So I didn't, I didn't quite, I didn't phrase the question very well.
My, my, my point was that I think this goes to the petitioner at the end of this journey,
if you can't come to agreement with the district, at some point, you're going to come to a fork in
the road, but where the district is the authorizer and they don't come to us. Is that correct?
Under 1505. Well, under, under this is Judy size under 1505 at some point,
um, not for this appeal, since this appeal was heard by the district in the county before
AB 1505 took effect. So start there, but in the future, when they come up for renewal again,
in the future, should they be renewed this time, then they would be subject to 1505 where they
would be, could eventually come to the board under a different standard that would be under
an abuse of discretion standard. Right. Okay. So it's, it's going to be incumbent, whatever happens
if the charter is renewed through us, at some point, the charter and the district and the
county are going to have to come to agreement because it's not going to come to us again in
the same way. I'm sorry, Matt. This is Judy. I'd like to correct my answer a little bit. Um,
been a long day. I think, um, for all of us, I know, um, the first renewal, they will come back
to us under the current, um, under a de novo review. Um, but then eventually you are right.
There will be a fork in the road where they will have to get authorized locally and be
appealed or it's an appeal. It would be under an abusive discretion standard.
Okay. Thank you.
All right. Um, any other questions from anyone? If not, I wonder if we can see if there's a motion.
Okay. I don't see anyone else with their hand up. Oh, Brenna. Okay.
Um, can Stephanie speak on the governance issues that, that, um, former record brought up
or management issues? Just, she was concerned that I want to have one more chance for
Stephanie to feel you can respond to that.
Um, the, the department didn't have governance issues. I think that came from the district.
Okay. So that was not an issue that that was not, no, it was not. Okay. All right. Um, all right.
Do we have, uh, we have no other hands up. Do we have a motion? Yes. So I will, if I could make
a few comments and then I will make my motions, uh, appreciate the, my fellow board members
questions and deliberation in this topic. It is not easy as most of those of us who've gone through
some of these charter renewal processes before. Uh, I wanted to just say that, um, although academic
performance is the most important part of, for renewal, there are other compelling factors that
we often need to and should look at. And so, um, I think the questions that is raised by board
members and, um, it really spoke to those in the case of John Henry, the school has acknowledged
that their opening was not perfect and they have, uh, very earnestly communicated their openness to
making the recommended improvements and knowing that they are in their first renewal there,
they were a startup. Um, it does take a while for your student demographics to, to, um,
make that change, but I believe that they have, um, shown lots of success with their students.
Um, they are accomplishing their mission of sending their students to college.
And, uh, I was very impressed too, that I think it was something like 92 or 94 percent of the
students, or maybe even 96 percent of their students, they, during the, um, campus closures,
they were able to outreach and connect with their students during this past spring. So this is,
uh, I see this as a school that is, um, meeting the student needs. Certainly there are some areas
of work and so I am ready to make, um, areas of work, including, um, repairing some of those
relationships with, um, their, their, the district and their areas. So with that, um, I am making a
recommendation that we approve the renewal of John Henry, uh, charter and, and I have some conditions
that will go with that that's on the screen right now. So here we go. So recommending approval of
renewal of John Henry High for a term of five years with the following conditions. That John Henry
High will conduct a root, uh, cause analysis and develop an academic action plan focused on
identifying and improving the school's mathematics performance and its services and performance for
students with disabilities. This plan will include a description of related staff training and
support for utilizing assessment data and targeted instruction and intervention. The Amethyst
Public Schools Executive Board will adopt a plan, the plan, and provide it to the California
Department of Education by October 1st, 2020. John Henry's leadership will provide quarterly
updates to CDE on their implementation of the academic action plan. John Henry will provide
residents of West Contra Costa Unified School District enrollment preference above all other
preferences categories described in the tradition document, with the sole exception of siblings of
current students. Um, this preference is intended to produce a student body that mirrors local
ethnic English learner and special education demographics. John Henry High will provide an
annual update to the CDE on or before October 15th, 2020 on its success in recruiting, enrolling,
and maintaining a student population that matches local demographics. The student will, the school,
sorry, will submit to the CDE a revised budget and a revised charter petition that addresses
deficiencies and or includes necessary language as outlined in the CDE staff analysis.
All right. Thanks very much. Is there a second for this motion?
I will second that motion. I appreciate Board Member Sun's detail. I like the
requirements to come back and review admissions preferences, so I will second that. And I,
yeah, I will second that and just simply add that again, at some point with this recommendation,
the petitioner is going to have to mend the relationship with the district and the county
based on 1505. All right. Is there any further discussion?
Seeing no hands raised, I think we're ready for a roll call vote. Karen, can you conduct the roll
call? Yes. Ting? Yes. Eileen? Yes. Eileen? Yes. Okay. Yes. Iday?
Iday, you might be talking to yourself on mute.
She was having technology trouble. I was raising my hand instead. Yes. Okay.
We need a vocal vote from everyone. Iday, can you repeat your?
Yes. Okay. Thank you. Kim?
Abstaining since I missed most of the presentation. Okay. Brenna? Yes. Matt? Yes. Jim? Yes. Cynthia?
Yes. Linda? Yes. And then Patricia? No. Okay.
The measure passes. Okay. Wow. You guys are in a marathon here. We all are. And we have another
charter renewal, which is the Fresh Start Charter. We're going to take a 10-minute break
so that Stephanie can organize and set up. And we'll be back at 4, let's say, 422.
All right. Are we all reassembled?
I am having some trouble with my computer now. I think it's just over. It's exhausted.
Yes. We all are. And I want to start out by welcoming everyone back. I think
probably Karen needs to call the roll to reestablish the quorum. Yes. I shall call the roll.
Okay. Linda? I'm here. Cynthia? Here. Jim? Here. Matt? Here. Brenna? Here. Kim?
With volume here. Okay. Hi. Hi, Day? Here. Eileen? Yes, here. Ting? Here. Patricia Rucker?
Here. Yay. Good. Everyone's present. All right. And I want to say at the beginning of this
part of the process that I have to leave shortly after 5 for another meeting and that will come
back. So I'll be in and out and Vice President Strauss will take the gavel at that point and
carry us forward. Agenda item 21 is a public hearing regarding petition for the renewal of
a charter school under the oversight of the State Board of Education. Consideration of today's
Fresh Start Charter School, Inglewood, which was denied by the Inglewood Unified School District
and the Los Angeles County Board of Education. The CDE recommends that the State Board hold a
public hearing to deny the request to renew today's Fresh Start Charter School, Inglewood,
a transitional kindergarten, kindergarten TKK through grade eight charter school.
And this item will be presented by Stephanie Farland of CDE. Stephanie, please begin.
Great. Thank you, Linda. Thank you, Stephanie. Good afternoon, everyone. So as mentioned,
we're here today to hear the appeal for today's Fresh Start Charter School, Inglewood.
The charter school is currently authorized by the Inglewood Unified School District
with a charter term that expired on June 30th, 2020. The petitioner sought renewal from IUSD
and the Los Angeles County Board of Education. They were denied on October 11th by IUSD
and on January 7th, 2020 by the LA County Board. At the June 9th, 2020 Advisory Commission on
Charter Schools meeting, the ACCS moved the CDE staff recommendation to deny today's Fresh Start
petition to the State Board of Education. The motion passed by a vote of six to three.
As stated, our recommendation, the department's recommendation is that the State Board hold a
public hearing to deny the request to renew TFS CSI, a transitional kindergarten through eighth
grade charter school under the oversight of the State Board. This is going to be an acronym that
I'm going to keep tripping over. TFS CSI is demonstrably unlikely to successfully
implement the intended program. The operational history of the Today's Fresh Start organization
exhibits ambiguity, self-dealings, and a lack of transparency. Conflicts of interest based on
related party transaction. And in its history, in 2007, Today's Fresh Start countywide was revoked
by the LA County Board of Education. The petition does not provide a reasonably comprehensive
description of the required elements and the petitioner has a past history of involvement
in charter schools that the SBE may regard as unsuccessful. A little background on the school.
Today's Fresh Start Inglewood is currently authorized by Inglewood Unified School District
and serves 430 TKK through grade eight pupils on a private facility with a charter term, as stated,
that ended on June 30th. TFS Inc. operated a countywide charter which was revoked and later
closed in June 2015. Petitioner also operates Today's Fresh Start Compton authorized by the
Compton Unified School District with a term that ends in 2023. Today's Fresh Start intends to serve
527 students in TKK through grade eight in 2021. Their mission is to educate each scholar
individually and personally, academically, emotionally, and socially to achieve their
individual academic potential and personal best. And you can see on the graph that projected
enrollment starts at 527 for the next school year and moves up to 727 for 2024-25.
The California Department of Education's findings and concerns.
Fiscal and governance concerns. Current governance concerns in past history of fiscal mismanagement
were critical in CDE's recommendation of denial as it has an impact on Today's Fresh Start's
ability to serve its pupils. Operational history of Today's Fresh Start exhibits ambiguity,
self-dealings, and a lack of transparency resulting in adverse relationships with its
authorizers. Conflicts of interest based on related party transactions, which include
transactions with Golden Day Schools, Inc., Los Angeles School Services, Inc., and California
Construction Management Services. TFS, Inc. has a long history of movement between authorizers as
well as negative outcomes in terms of non-renewals and litigation, including the 2007 Today's Fresh
Start countywide charter revocation by the LA County Board of Ed. Conflicts of interest.
Today's Fresh Start Inglewood contracted with California Construction Management Services,
which is run by the petitioner's husband and for which the petitioner served as an officer.
Golden Day Schools, Inc. is a related entity and run by a petitioner's husband,
contracted with the CDE for child care services. Today's Fresh Start to Inglewood audit findings,
which were upheld by the courts, included findings of various improper conflicts of
interest based on related entities. And further note, the Department of Education is currently
in litigation against the Golden Day Schools, Inc. and the petitioner's husband to recover
disallowed costs of approximately $20 million. LA School Services, Inc., an entity owned and
operated by the petitioner and her husband, owns the building Today's Fresh Start Compton leases.
The petitioner also appears to run religious organizations that use the Today's Fresh Start
address. Unsuccessful history. Today's Fresh Start, Inc., a non-profit benefit corporation,
has been operating charter schools since 2003. In 2007, their countywide was revoked by the LA
County Board of Ed, which resulted in litigation, which was settled in 2015 when the revocation was
upheld by the California Supreme Court. Today's Fresh Start Compton, in relation to today's Fresh
Start Compton, TFS, Inc., dissolved the countywide benefit after the revocation was upheld and filed
a single school petition approved by the Compton Unified School District. The California state
budget impact, this is, as you will recognize, the same slide we've been using in all of our
appeals the last couple of days to describe and explain the budget impact during this COVID-19
pandemic and the impact it will have on the state budget to LEAs, including charter schools in 2021
and the future. With the fiscal analysis, we did not find that Today's Fresh Start
would have any fiscal issues during this time, or as we analyze their budget and their budget
projections, would not have any issues in terms of deferrals. However, as you can see here, they
have a projected enrollment of 527, with positive ending fund balances of 19 million, over 19 million
with reserves of 300%, 295%, and 276% for fiscal years 2020 through 2023, respectively.
Now that first block there includes their charter school facilities grant, so when we take that out
of their budget, they still are viable and they still have very large
ending fund balances and very large reserves.
The Department of Ed is concerned about the following. Their high reserves are well above
what is normally required by the State Board of Ed, which is 5%, and if you remember, they have
over 100% reserves. The TFSI, what we're concerned about is that they're not spending money on
students being served by the school. If they were investing in the school, they would be spending
students being served by the school. If they were investing resources in pupils, I think you
will see when we get to their academic achievement, they would probably likely yield a more significant
gain in academic achievement, as well as when we noticed that these funding reserves were so high
and were questioning whether or not they were spending money on students, we did go out and
look at the SARCs for some of the schools that we used in our comparable school comparisons with
today's Fresh Start, Inglewood, and we did see that there was quite a gap in expenditures.
For a 2018-19 year, today's Fresh Start, Inglewood, was spending $9,500 per pupil,
where the comparable schools that we were comparing them to were spending between $12,000 and $19,000
per pupil, so there's quite a large spending gap in expenditures at the school.
Academic renewal criteria under Education Code 47607. The authority that granted the charter
shall consider increases in pupil academic achievement for all groups of pupils as the
most important factor, and the entity that granted the charter determines that the academic performance
of the charter school is at least equal to the academic performance of the public schools of
the charter school pupils would otherwise have been required to attend. I'm going to take my mask
off just for a second because I have to, I have to breathe. Deep breaths for a second.
The Department of Education findings, we select 11 schools serving similar grade spans where
pupils would otherwise attend and that are comparable and that they have similar enrollment
for similar significant subgroups. The CDE has determined that the CAS data demonstrates that
TFSCSI does perform at least equal to the schools where the pupils would otherwise be required to
attend. However, in general and statewide, this school is still academically low performing.
You will see in our comparable schools that we did use schools in Inglewood as comparable schools
and schools in LA Unified as comparable schools, as according to our data, a large proportion of
their students at Inglewood actually would be LA Unified students. Moving on to their dashboard,
their dashboard for 2018-19 and 19 in English Language Arts, you'll see that they were in
yellow in 2018 and have gone down in 2019 to orange, so there was a decline in their colors
for the dashboard. Mathematics had a slight increase but stayed in the same color range.
There were decreases in CAS data when you look at the ELA and math scores for the various
pupil groups that attend the school. There were decreases, some more significant than others,
but specifically in ELA for the socioeconomically and for
in ELA for Hispanic Latino students decreased significantly.
Ed Code 52052F allows charter schools to use alternative measures that show increases in
pupil academic achievement for all groups of pupils school-wide and among significant
subgroups in order to meet renewal requirements. The CDE reviewed the alternative measures
information provided by Today's Fresh Start. The data shows that Today's Fresh Start alternative
measures reflect some increases in their CAS, LPAC, and RFEP. Among the charter elements that
we reviewed, CDE finds that Today's Fresh Start Inglewood does not provide a reasonably comprehensive
description of the following required charter elements. Description of their educational
program, the governance structure, suspension and expulsion procedures, and dispute resolution
procedures. In terms of their educational program, it lacks description of a comprehensive English
learner plan. Projected enrollment does not include the number of TK pupils and special
education services does not include sufficient information to show a continuum of services.
In terms of the governance structure, their bylaws reflect non-compliance with the Brown Act
requirement allows regular meetings to be held without notice and no requirement for public notice
of special meetings. The Today's Fresh Start conflict of interest code reflect non-compliance
with the political reform act includes exceptions and definitions that are contrary to government
code 1090 incorrectly relies on California corporations code rather than government code
section 1090 which is now required. In conclusion, CDE staff recommends denial of the Today's Fresh
Start Inglewood petition. The petition is unlikely to successfully implement the intended program
based on involvement of current governance concerns and past history of fiscal mismanagement.
The petition does not provide reasonably comprehensive descriptions of all the required elements.
And that concludes
my presentation.
Thank you very much Stephanie. This is the opening of the public hearing. I declare the
public hearing open as of 438 p.m. First we'll hear from the petitioners. The petitioners will
have 12 minutes. Then we'll hear from the district and county that are opposing the renewal petition.
They will also have a total of 12 minutes. After the presentations from both sides there will then
After the presentations from both sides there will then be an opportunity for public comment
from any individual who has not already presented for one minute each. So we'll hear now from the
petitioners.
Hi there. Can you hear and see me?
I saw some nods. So I guess I'll go ahead and get started. So good afternoon board members. My name
is Janelle Rooley. I'm an attorney with the law offices of Yonge Indian Court. Another day of first
speaking to you through a mask. So to kick things off I wanted to first dispense with a couple of
the items that are more legal in nature. First of all the law applicable to this renewal tells us
that increases in subgroup academic achievement is the most important factor. Again the most
important factor in determining whether to grant renewal. Today's fresh start has documented those
increases in the past and will do so again today for you in great detail. Crucially the CDE also
found that today's fresh start met this academic threshold criteria. So we're in agreement there.
Second you may hear today and have heard already about claims of past performance that was
unsuccessful or maybe allegations of conflicts of interest. Ultimately these claims what they
boil down to is smoke but without any fire. So the district county and the CDE have all stated
that the today's fresh start charter the county-wide benefit charter was revoked.
That's the exact same charter that the state board approved in 2010. I was there. I personally was
there. This the state board cannot renew a charter that was revoked. It just can't happen. So it
wasn't revoked. Next the today's fresh start Inglewood operates at a facility that was
constructed with support from the charter school facilities program. That's the building where we
are all today. The district has made allegations about a lease that the Compton school a separate
charter school entered into. That particular property was acquired by the parkers in the
1960s and used and it was used to provide free education to socioeconomically disadvantaged
students. That property is held in a family trust and it's leased at or below market rate to a
preschool and then eventually sublet to Compton, TFS Compton. The site ownership has never been
concealed and indeed the site was approved by the state board in 2010 again as part of that
county-wide renewal and the fair political practices commission made a determination that
that the that the arrangement was lawful. All of that is documented in your papers.
Last you might hear about a construction contract that's related to the Inglewood site.
This construction project or contract is complete. The contract is expired. There's no live contract
here. The construction company employed Dr. Parker's husband so there was a financial interest
but it was properly disclosed contemporaneously both to the state board and to the office of public
school construction. All of these issues can be explained in a way that really does sound scary
however the facts are that no authority with jurisdiction has actually found a conflict of
interest. So with that out of the way I want to turn this over to Dr. Codio who's going to tell
you all about the academics. Good afternoon esteemed board allow us to show you a video
about how great today's fresh start is. The great Maya Angelou said hope is born again in the faces
of children. We see that at today's fresh start charter school in Inglewood which serves more
than 500 predominantly Latinx and African American students with a rich personalized
learning experience. From the moment children begin at today's fresh start they know they're
in a special place where they're wrapped in support and learning is a joy. In safe clean
modern classrooms the school's student scholars rise to meet the expectations of performance.
TFS academic scores rank well above other schools in the Inglewood Unified School District.
The focus on technology helps prepare students for their futures.
All students are provided with laptop computers and instructors use interactive Promethean boards.
Today's fresh start welcomes students with special needs. They benefit from caring on-site resource
specialists counselors and psychologists who provide patient holistic services. Students
especially love the state-of-the-art gymnasium. On any day of the week you can find children
playing sports and games engaging in after-school activities attending school dances and enjoying
other activities. When school is not in session the gym is often used by members of the community.
TFS offers a nurturing environment for students and ESL students helping them to face and
surmount challenges outside of school. Rather than using harsh or punitive discipline teachers
talk to students about their home lives and take an interest in their future. Today's fresh start
Inglewood is dedicated to its mission of preparing students as lifelong learners to participate
responsibly in a diverse and changing world. Hello again my name is Pierre Cotillo and I will be
discussing the rest of this presentation to show that today's fresh start should remain open for
years to come. First of all let's talk about our governance structure. Our governance is controlled
by five very experienced community-minded people and you see their accomplished names on your
screen. Complete with knowledge in education law finance and government. Our board does a great job
of making sure that our parents are represented. One board overseeing multiple charters which was
something that was discussed is the standard practice in the charter world and yearly our
board received Brown Act training and compliance with legal guidelines.
We're also an award-winning school. Look at that screen that you're seeing. This is not an
exhaustive list. We've received commendations from the National Association of Special Education
Teachers for our special education process and how we do as a school. We've also been received
commendations from Innovate Public Schools as a top school of choice for children of color.
We're also part of National Honor Society fully accredited by WASC and our students are sought
after by some of the most prestigious high schools in California and quite frankly the country.
Our school is raising the bar and closing the achievement gap. Also looking at our dashboard
you will see that we have a great school culture. TFSESI has achieved blue since the inception of
the dashboard on suspension and expulsions because we believe in counseling and mentoring our
scholars and their families. With regard to the ability of successfully implementing the program
as we stated to you in our April 3rd letter our education program undeniably works as it relates
to everything that we do because of our cash scores and now I'd like to take this time to
discuss our authorizer Englewood and the challenges they themselves are dealing with.
Englewood has been dealing with many many many many challenges. First of all with the closure
of Freeman Elementary in 2013. Also with the closure of Monroe and we'll talk about that in
a moment in 2018. The closure and the reframing of Woodworth to become Woodworth Monroe at that
same time and now they're about to have experienced possibly another closure with Warren Lane Elementary
School and of course TFSES Englewood has been a stable consistent high performing school in the
Englewood community. As it relates to our ELA scores you see from our 2018-19 data and you see
that trend line of all comparable 7th and 8th grade schools within Englewood and you see very
clearly that our scores are outpacing everything that's happening in Englewood Unified School
District as well as the district as a whole. The same story also bears true for math where you're
seeing all the different schools from Hewlett-Pane all the way down to Warren Lane how we are
performing as an institution. We are raising the bar and closing the achievement gap for our
scholars. When you're looking at comparable Los Angeles Unified Schools the same story bears out
but today's fresh start the 3rd to 5th grade cluster outpacing the 3rd to 5th grade clusters
of our comparison schools doing the very same thing for ELA for 6th to 8th grade.
When you look at our math scores again the same story bears out Honorable Ward with TFSES Englewood
outpacing our other comparable schools. We are indeed the highest performing school from all
the comparable schools that we've received in middle school as well as elementary because again
we believe in raising the bar and closing the achievement gap for all of our scholars.
So again let's go back to talking about how Englewood closures impacted our school community.
If you take a look at the dashboard here you will see when Monroe closed in 2018
June 30th to be exact they're one mile north of today's fresh start. So when they refrain
Woodworth Elementary to become Woodworth Monroe naturally all their children did not just transfer
from Monroe over to Woodworth Monroe. Many of their children over 50 of them enrolled in today's
fresh start and because of their performance as you can see clearly identified here with very very
very low points from distance from standard you will see that when they came to us they improved
greatly. We were able to take their score from 83.4 points distance from standard in the 2018
testing year I'm sorry up to 74.4 points following year 2000. You'll also see as you accurately
stated earlier that we were able to make gains within the same population with regard to math.
So again we are raising the bar and closing the achievement gap for our scholars but it's got us
to thinking how are all of our scholars doing once they transfer to us from other institutions.
So here's the information here when students transfer from other institutions that weren't
doing them well or they weren't serving their their students well when they came to us you
see the trend line of improvement started with 74.7 distance from standard intake when they're
with us for one year 53.5 all the way to three years plus we're closing the gap for our kids.
The same issue the same story I'm sorry bears true for math with our children closing the gap the
longer they're with us. So we know for a fact if we had those Monroe children earlier we would have
closed that gap even further because of our process in our program and how excellent our
how excellent we do things. Looking at it from distance from standard for the very same thing
the very same thing in ELA the third through fifth all that information bears the same way
with our students outperforming both Englewood Unified as well as LA Unified comparable schools.
Again that's true for our students in ELA for sixth through eighth grade and you'll see that
also true for math third through fifth sixth through eighth. CCSA and the California Charter
Schools Association also stated that our school meets the minimal criteria and if you see it on
your screen and we qualify for renewal support based on academics because again of how we do
business we raise the bar we close the achievement gap we counsel our students we keep our students
in classrooms and we do right by our kids. Analysis does continuity and learning because
this is a very important piece of what we're doing in terms of moving forward. Today's fresh start is
focused on strengthening our academic program in the midst of our COVID-19 outbreak following all
regulations and guidelines. Within two weeks and that is not a misprint within two weeks of the
national emergency 97 percent of our scholars were engaged in online learning because we provided
computers to them and had all their classes transition from what's happening here at the
school site into Google Classroom and synchronous classes happening daily through Zoom. We also
again as I shared provided computer devices and we're not stopping there. We're creating partnerships
with T-Mobile. We also did a formative assessment in June to see exactly where our students were
prior to them leaving and we will repeat that same assessment in the fall to see what happened over
the summer so we can plan effectively for our scholars. We're also going to be purchasing new
laptops so the students will be able to take their laptops home and also stay with us. Thank you so
much. Today's fresh start should remain open. Thank you.
Are you still talking? Sorry, thank you.
We want to move now to the district county representatives.
Let us know when you'd like us to begin.
When you're ready. Okay, thank you. Do you have a slide that you want to be showing because I
don't see one. Yes, I'm sharing my screen. We're just seeing a black
black screen at the moment.
Let me try it again. Maybe unshare and then reshare. Yeah, thank you.
Thank you. How about now? We can see it. Excellent. So glad.
Are you unmuted? Okay, I'm unmuted. Can you hear me? Yes. Yes. Good afternoon,
honorable board members. My name is Dr. Erica Torres and I serve as the proud
county administrator of the Inglewood Unified School District. We at Inglewood Unified are
very passionate about education and putting our students first, all students first. We have
students, teachers, administrators, and parents all seeking to be heard today to support our district.
Contrary to what today's fresh start has shared, Inglewood Unified is actually on the right.
Students in Inglewood have choice. The district is transforming with amazing outcomes for students
and we have many other charter schools within our district. We are ensuring that every student,
regardless of race, ethnicity, special needs are treated with care and respect and are able
to learn in a safe and nurturing environment. Inglewood has nine charter schools, two were not
renewed. Both with academic performance issues, TFS appealed. The decision by Children of Promise
did not. Today's fresh start is operated by Jeanette Parker. Jeanette Parker is married
to Clark Parker. The Parkers also operate other for-profit companies that contrast with TFS.
The state board regulations require consideration of past performance and whether a charter school
has had an unsuccessful history. TFS has an unsuccessful history including misconduct.
TFS was revoked by LACO for a myriad of violations including the same conduct TFS has continued to
pursue under its current charter. Violation of conflict of interest laws and self-dealing,
including violation of governance requirements and Brown Act and fiscal mismanagement. TFS has
pursued unsuccessful litigation against LACO. The state and Inglewood unified. This simply
shows no regard for compliance which translates into a failure to put students first and ensure
them the education that they're entitled to receive. Our community and students deserve
better than TFS. We are a district on the rise and expect integrity, compliance and collaboration
with our education partners. TFS has repeatedly asserted that it was not revoked. It was in fact
revoked as confirmed by chief counsel for this board. This is also confirmed in the LACO board
minutes. Dr. Sforza. Yes thank you so much Dr. Torres and thank you Auguste board members
for listening to us today. I am Dr. Tanyan Sforza the president of the Inglewood Unified School
District Board of Education and a UC Region Emeritus. You know I really want to thank you
all for hearing us out as we take the time to share our concerns with you about the Parkers
as well as today's fresh start because this the self-dealing concerns we have with their
charter operations is not new. As reported by a teacher of today's fresh start students go
without internet adequate supplies or even books and yet rather than invest in students education
today's fresh start has amassed a multi-million dollar reserve and the Parkers pay themselves
well over a million dollars annually through salary and contracts.
In fact today's fresh start make local and national news with their self-dealing
including being named by the Washington Post as one of the five most serious
charter school scandals in 2019 nationally.
You know it's not good for students and it's not good for charter schools generally to have bad
actors enriching themselves in the name of charter schools. You know as a as a native of Inglewood
who very much cares about our children who has my own children in our schools I want to ensure
that all children in our district have access to institutions that are providing a great education
to institutions that are providing a great education for them and are ensuring that we're
maintaining integrity in our operations. Today's fresh start is not a good steward of the sector.
With a history like TFS we would hope to see lessons learned and corrected conduct however
the deficiencies with their practices and the charter itself are ongoing and extremely serious.
Despite efforts to close their financial benefits one of the TFS school sites
is owned by the Parkers who lease the property to Los Angeles School Services Inc
who in turn leases to TFS. TFS is paying approximately 800,000 in rent annually.
The Parkers financially benefit from contracts between TFS and a construction management company
owned and operated by the Parkers. This is not putting the school and its students first.
TFS's board is not in control and there is a lack of transparency in their governance.
They skirt the law at every opportunity wrongfully operating a school outside the
district and unsuccessfully suing the district when they try to hold them to the requirements
of the law. These failures are serious and undermine the education
for all of our students including those with disabilities.
Good afternoon my name is Dr. Bernadette Lucius, chief academic officer for the
Eaglewood Unified School District. In reviewing the renewal petition academic performance was
considered as the most important factor but critically TFS refused to cooperate with the
district even refusing to provide the 18-19 CASC data. TFS asserted it was embargoed even though
state superintendent Thurmond instructed charter schools in writing to share it with their
authorizers. TFS was trying to hide the serious declines. Now they claim the district did not
consider the performance which is untrue. On the day of the decision the data was obtained from the
state and was incorporated in the district's consideration and decision. That data and the
county administrator's consideration is part of the record. The next slide clearly shows double
digit declines in nearly every grade. The decline in 2018-2019 is shown here but the decline in both
ELA and math performance was a trend over the five-year term. TFS did not demonstrate increases in
academic performance for all students. This is a social justice issue for students in our district.
The declines were in every subgroup as indicated on this slide served by TFS with EL and Hispanic
pupils declining in the double digit. The LACO board like Eaglewood found that TFS did not
meet the academic requirements for renewal and unanimously denied the renewal petition.
My name is Aba Nghissa and I'm a teacher in Eaglewood and also the president of the
Eaglewood Teacher's Association. The special education violations the district witnessed were
particularly alarming. When visiting the school the TFS special education administrator was asked
how they address the needs of students with severe disabilities or that enroll with an IEP that
requires a specialty class. She responded that they send them back to their home district,
a clear violation. Review of the disaggregated data provided by TFS shows that TFS serves a
smaller number and a smaller percentage of special needs students and primarily students with mild
disabilities. TSF reported no students with intellectual disabilities. The district also
found that the TFS numbers were skewed due to identifying the same student under multiple
categories. So the disaggregated data even skews favorably to the TSF members.
After careful review of all of the information and the input I found TFS did not provide the
requisite information to be eligible for renewal and the CASC data did not demonstrate increases
in academic performance for all subgroups. Dr. Scorza. Yes thank you. The local board which
revoked today's fresh start charter in 2009 heard the TFS in good appeal. Ward member Alex Johnson
was concerned with whether things have changed at the charter school since that time. Our
consideration of all aspects of this appeal is because of students because we care for children
because we want to see every child succeed every child receive a high quality education.
And from my perspective as this one board member it means that we do not turn an eye
to the glaring concerns that are raised in this petition. So my concerns
uh rest as I said at the last meeting I asked the question what has changed?
Excuse me. So since since you have worked since November which is a reasonable amount of time to
make an assessment you can then uh give a perspective on whether or not this has been a
board operating in name only. And I would not classify it as a board operating in name only
but I also would not classify it as a board that is in full control.
So the consultant that spoke on behalf of TFS responded.
And confirmed that she would not classify the board as in full control.
And when we look to the change we can see that that Dr. Alex Johnson was looking for we can see
that it has not occurred. My name is Sueann Evans and I am legal counsel for the district.
The Parkers have enriched themselves there's no question through the abuse of Dr. Jeanette
Parker's position at TFS. Now the district has focused on particular transactions one being the
leases between the Los Angeles school services and today's fresh start and the construction
management services agreement with today's fresh start. These transactions are with companies that
are owned and operated by Clark Parker Jeanette Parker's husband and operate out of property
owned by the Parkers at 4508 Crenshaw which we will note in a few minutes is a site that
today's fresh start also pays a lease for or has entered into a lease for.
So this has gone on under this board it's been the same board for many many years at least five
years and they reelect themselves. So we're not seeing any change we're not seeing a change
in the governance even in the folks who are stepping up to the plate to run the program.
Now where do we get this information all smoke no fire not true it comes from their own audits
it's the Parkers audits that identify the related party transactions and the property leases with
TFS and under these agreements TFS has paid companies again operated by the Parkers.
Okay was that 12 minutes or did you give us 10 because my my clock is saying we have a little more time.
That was 12 minutes okay thank you I'm gonna quickly finish.
No there's time sorry.
My comment and I'm going I'm not going to go through all the slides but I do want to point out
that the these their own tax records show that they did not go through any of the procedures
for related party transactions they didn't even acknowledge them on their tax forms so I'll stop
there but we're available to answer questions and I know you all have copies of of our presentation.
Thank you so at this juncture we're going to open up for public comment.
Members of the public wishing to provide comment may do so by calling
the public comment number which we want to show on the screen we can get that up there.
712-432-0075 and access code 651905 pound listen to the message when prompted dial star six and then
when prompted dial one be sure to turn down the volume of your computer if you have the live
webcast on to avoid background echoes we did have trouble with that earlier in the day when it's
your turn to speak an operator will announce please say your name and affiliation begin public
comment and your time begins now can we have the translator do that same translation with the Spanish
version
do we still have our translator
translator are you available to read the Spanish slide yes ma'am I am right here sorry I was on mute
651905 and the numeral key when listening to the message and when prompted press
asterisk six and when prompted press one when it's your turn an operator will ask you in
English to say your name and affiliation and start your intervention your turn begins now
say my name is I represent and I need a translator also remember to reduce the volume of your
computer if you are watching live
thank you very much we will start the public comment now I will personally have to leave for
a little bit in the middle and I'll be back and if there is a need in that time Vice President
Strauss will be chairing so let's call on please be aware that the item is number 21 for today's
fresh start please if you are calling for another item please hang up now this is today's fresh start
item 21 caller you are unmuted please state your name and affiliation for the record
caller are you there
yes
caller are you available
uh hello yes you're on online please please state your name and affiliation for the record
I am Carol Freese and I've been on the board of today's fresh start for about 10 years
today's fresh start Englewood deserves a renewal of the charter in this underserved black and
hispanic community our academics are good and we're always striving to do better we have
wonderful people there's no good reason to deny the charter we have a highly professional and
competent hard-working dedicated staff we're an asset to the community in a lovely facility
we have state-of-the-art technology in each classroom our parents have asked to keep the
school open with impassioned letters and signed petitions our students have asked to keep the
school open with notes and drawings members of our community have asked to keep the school
open in letters sent in support of the petition it would be a tragedy to close this school tear
apart a thriving learning community and harm the educational and social environment of the deserving
students who need every break they can get in this society this wonderful charter would not
should not be shut down for the wrong reasons time thank you speaker
next speaker you're unmuted please state your name and affiliation for the record
hi this is dianne faulk can you hear me
yes please go ahead speaker okay thank you so much hi my name is dianne faulk and i am a board
member of the education of englewood unified school district as we do with all of our charter
schools the district exercise appropriate oversight over today's fresh start during its
tenure in our district our administrative team ensures that each of our charter schools complies
with the law monitors their academic performance and oversees their operations to make certain
that students are receiving the education that they deserve and as contemplated by the charter
schools act not only did today's fresh start fail to meet the academic eligibility requirement
for renewal but other deficiencies as reflected in our written findings and as confirmed by laco
compelled denial of the renewal we want to make clear that it is the independent analysis of both
our district staff and also the experts on behalf of laco that has reached the same conclusion that
renewal is not time renewal is not time okay thank you thank you speaker next speaker you
are unmuted please state your name and affiliation for the record
i am bishop johnny young the former englewood unified school district board of education member
and president from 2003 to 2015 educational code section 47607 a3a compels authorizers
to consider pupil academic achievement as the most important factor for charter schools renewal
if denying a renewal petition an authorizer is required to independently review the fact
and make its own findings based upon specific facts it has examined in the record
in the two-part charter approval approved by englewood unified school district the old stale
issues were reviewed and determined to be irreverent time we earned this time
and the church time thank you speaker today thank you
next speaker please state your name and affiliation for the record your time starts now
speaker are you available
yes i'm bishop craig brown i'm an englewood area member association ministers association
executive board member we all know that when high achieving students are forced to attend lower
achieving schools their academic performance significantly declines stanford university
center for research on education outcomes credo found that the typical student in a
charter school gains more learning in a year than his or her district school peer
amounting to about 50 more days of learning and reading and an additional 79 days of learning
and math today's fresh start has shown this progress and should not be closed because
the regulations and statutes state that academic performance should be the highest determination
to grant renewal thank you thank you next speaker
please state your name and affiliation for the record your time starts now
hello i'm cicely bingener i'm a kindergarten teacher with englewood
um the apparatus of tss have a decade-long record of what amounts to robbery of pressures
and limited state funds to enrich themselves on the backs of thousands of unsuspecting
and vulnerable students and families as a mandated reporter i'm compelled to point out
that using children to enrich yourself and for your pleasure is tantamount to nothing less
than thinly veiled child molestation allowing even a single cent of taxpayer money to underwrite
child molestation is unconscionable sb don't allow yourself to be groomed by these predators
you must deny the charter today i cede my time thank you thank you speaker next speaker
next speaker please state your name and affiliation for the record please your time starts now
now
speaker are you online
next speaker please state your name and affiliation for the record
hello board of education and its members my name is christina ramirez i am a parent at today's
first star charter school englewood first off i would like to say that tfscs has provided my son
with an amazing learning experience he has learned beyond his grade level and his test scores test
scores are above the district level he has accomplished so much in the four years he has
attended tfscs englewood it would be very heartbreaking not only to myself but most
important to my son to have his school close especially through these difficult times we are
living in just to think of the idea of having to look for a new school upsets me we are going
through a pandemic that has changed the world and has changed our children's lives why take more
away from them why take away school that not only has provided an excellent education but most
important a safe environment for all our children please understand the importance of keeping our
school open please keep tfscs englewood open do it for our children now my son is going to speak
hello department of education members my name is sebastian rodriguez and i am a scholar at today's
fast start charter school englewood i would like to start off by saying that tfscs englewood is my
second home i have learned so much at this school i've had amazing teachers that have helped me
accomplish some of my goals and i've contributed to the young man i am today it makes me sad just
to hear that my school might be closed covid 19 has taken away one of my family members it will
break my heart up to also have my school taken away from me please keep my school open give me
the right to continue to succeed as they have the most important where i feel comfortable
do it for me in my future thank you
thank you speaker next speaker please state your name and affiliation for the record
your time starts now
hi my name is paula epstein and i am an employee of today's fresh start i've been an employee for
10 years i have seen firsthand the care and concern that all employees have for all of our
students we don't pick and choose who our students are we accept any and all students that come to
our doors for enrollment we only use positive methods to reach all of our students it's evident
that our procedures are working when you look at our data we have been honored to receive many
accolades we're very excited to have many students that are members of the elementary
and junior honor society and when we had the initiation ceremony for the honor society
all the inglewood board members were invited sadly to say none attended this is unconscionable
our school tfscs inglewood does not deserve to be shut down due to political issues
over 500 students and their families have chosen tfscs i we are a caring high performing
school that demands thank you speaker raise the bar thank you so much thank you next speaker you
are now unmuted please state your uh name and affiliation for the record your time starts now
now
hi i'm Yadira Funes please renew today's fresh chart charter school inglewood charter the school
moves forward to reach excellence at our school we monitor our students' progress routinely
we have high success rates because we are resourceful and use strategies that work to
help each student we have parents and students with us since their child started kindergarten
and have finished eighth grade many parents continue to enroll the younger siblings because
of the good work we have done i am also calling on behalf of several english learners parents
who could not call in we provide designated and integrated english language development
and teacher support we have an active DLAG we provide parent workshops and reading groups
such as la lectura for all of our parents so they can continue reading at home please renew
today's fresh chart charter school inglewood's charter for the sake of our future thank you thank
you speaker next speaker you are in the queue please state your name and affiliation for the
record your time starts now good afternoon i am terence and i am the current music director
instructor of today's fresh start charter school with steam academy with a full-time music program
today's fresher charter school established and created a school mass choir guidelines these
guidelines in accordance with the california music standards are now working as an effective
core foundation and basis of our core of the music program the students are more engaged and
motivated to learn and always looking forward to our music class and choir rehearsals the parents
are supportive and grateful that we have the music program that is designed to help their child to
enhance their psychomotor effective and cognitive development in addition the students are growing
towards good and positive behavior not just in school but also in our community in regard to
this i hope that you renew our charter school to continue our commitment to educate our students
and guide them towards a brighter future today's fresh start charter school is committed to our
promise of raising the bar and closing the achievement gap thank you so much thank you
next speaker please state your name and affiliation for the record your time starts now
speaker hello yes please please go ahead and state your comment
hello my name is dr young from today's fresh charter school i have a support
this the school renewal the school has created the since the news of the
the closure of the school many families have been restless and uncomfortable thinking that they
they have nowhere else to go the issue has so devastated them that they have received more
than 50 calls from my relatives parents and friends who from their kids are in today's
fresh charter school they were all expressing the hope is going to cause them because they feel
they have no hope anywhere since all the schools around them usually have low scores in tests in
fact there is no school you can compare with today's fresh charter school that that was why
it was difficult for them in my mind i feel the issue of closing the school
is mainly political if not i wonder why they have time in the impact of thank you speaker your time
is up we appreciate you calling in thank you all right thank you next speaker you are now
unmuted please state your name and affiliation for the record your time starts now
now
this is catelyn o'haller on behalf of the charter schools development center
today's fresh start englewood is a school with a charter that should be renewed
according to cde's own analysis today's fresh start has a viable budget and they perform
academically comparable or higher than the schools around them they are an award-winning
school fully accredited by wasp and they have a great school culture as shown on their dashboard
this school is an important option for the students and families in englewood
and i urge you to approve their charter petition thank you thank you next speaker you are now
unmuted please state your name and affiliation for the record your time starts now
hello hello can you hear me yes thank you please go ahead and state your comments
hi my name is marie lesley i'm a teacher of englewood unified school district third grade
teacher for the past 30 years i was first introduced to fresh start's charter when a
parent approached me regarding her child failing in school i tested to tutor this child i tested
him and he was like at a second of first grade reader i reconferenced with the teacher to find
out what was the problem and what was she doing to facilitate his learning and she was not able
to provide anything substantial to show us why or how or what he was doing in school she said he
was doing fine he was a well-behaved student however she thought that he was doing fine where
i thought that he was really below and needed additional support so i i didn't feel that the
school genuinely provided the rich enrichment for these times to do their work your your time's up
thank you for calling in next speaker you're unmuted please state your name
and affiliation for the record your time starts now
miss mary von teacher and englewood unified school district i'm calling in support of the
englewood unified school district LACO and CDE decision to deny the renewal of today's fresh start
this public school is not providing the englewood residents with free and appropriate educational
programs and ELL programming or special day classes this school is located in a minority
community where these services are vital this policy is being used to weed out the students
with the greatest needs our englewood children deserve better all today's fresh start students
are invited to enroll in englewood unified schools where these services are in place
such as woodworth memro warning lane benet q and all other iusd schools they can visit www.englewoodusd.com
for further details on enrollment for the 2021 school year thank you thank you speaker
next speaker please state your name and affiliation for the record your time starts now
speaker are you on the line hello hi my name is pastor domico fishterl and as a stakeholder for
my membership i am compelled to fight for the renewal of today's fresh charter
i believe that we are facing times like never before in this pandemic
we are facing times like never before in this pandemic and i find it criminal that we would be
taking away a viable option when education is being debated whether it be a hybrid online or
face-to-face i believe that our students in englewood need every option that we can provide
and today's first charter based on the academics that have been displayed earlier is a viable
options for our students thank you very much thank you next speaker you're you're now unmuted
please state your name and affiliation for the record your time starts now
good afternoon my name is lena atutola instructional coach for englewood unified
school district i'm here today to ask that you deny the renewal of the charter for today's fresh
start charter school we're hearing that the charters believe that their students are their
top priorities but i believe that the evidence shows that money is their top priority they are
self-interested and they have had a history of financial conflicts of interest number one we've
heard about them renting own buildings owned by the parkers we also know that they're paying
golden day schools to provide food for their charter students they've spent about fifty thousand
dollars the state grant to hire an unaccredited university to recommend ways to improve their
charter this university was founded by jenette parker more than half of the board has a financial
stake in the schools additionally the parkers donated seventy three thousand dollars to state
superintendent of instruction jack o'connell who led the department staff in recommending that the
board keep time tfs is open thank you thank you speaker next speaker you are now unmuted please
state your name and affiliation for the record your time starts now
hello hello yes can you hear me yes we can please go ahead and state your comments
my name is pauline miller i am a board member for today's fresh start for over five years
and we do not get paid we're there to volunteer to make sure the school is ran in the proper
way that it should be run i am also a volunteer at the school have been for eleven last eleven
years every day i'm there my three grandchildren and my one nephew are a student they make excellent
grades because the teachers are caring and making sure that the students are learning
we have an excellent counseling and um special education pro special ed program we have an
after school program that is very good that teaches works with the students to do homework
and tutoring and any wherever they is needed our teachers do also after school tutoring
we have a um aren't all students at the school time great take the end time a test on thank you
speaker uh your time has expired uh we appreciate you calling in next speaker please state your
name and affiliation for the record you are unmuted
hello yes your time starts now thank you my name is I am a student
of today's fresh start charter school please renew the school because it is better than
any other school i have been to the teaching system is very good the environment is clean
and i never experienced bullying in this school
my name is merely to go feel blue i am a student of today's fresh start charter school
please renew the school charter because i have lots of friends in the school i do not want to leave
the teachers are very good i do not want to go to a new school in this coronavirus time
sorry
thank you speaker next speaker you are now unmuted please state your affiliation
and name for the record your time starts now
we have four speakers in this call can we get our own time for each yes each
speaker will get a minute each thank you okay okay here comes the first speaker
hello my name is Fulton Fahmy i'm a teacher with today's fresh start charter school i have
observed this school heavily invest in classroom resources and materials such as laptops for every
student that have been recently distributed to the students for distance learning they have smart
boards and or promethean boards are in every classroom the school has provided their science
provided their science teachers with resources such as robots and their software microscopes
to investigate the dna of a strawberry for example laboratory equipment to observe chemical reactions
they have also purchased common core intervention booklets to prepare our students for the smarter
balance test which of course was not given because of the pandemic test scores outrank
those of the surrounding inglewood unified school district the school has also invested
in many professional development programs and webinars for their teachers and their staff thank
you thank you next speaker please my name is inez solman on behalf of the student parents
community and educators that make up today's fresh start our call on your support in renewing our
charter we have today's fresh start we support our scholars academically using multiple academic
tools to build strong student teacher relationship we endorse positive character development
during the pandemic we have implemented the wellness program
to check on our students and to do assessment to meet their needs we have counselors psychologists
behavior coach on campus to assist our students to navigate their daily challenges most of all
we encourage our students to achieve that educational potential our mission is to provide
each student an opportunity for a great public education thank you
good afternoon this is ms. Farras the teacher here at today's fresh start charter school
requesting that you approve the renewal of our charter i've been blessed to see how our school
have grown and progressed from eight bungalows to 20 beautiful high tech classrooms a gymnasium
offices and more we have computers for every child from ck to eight smart boards projectors
and other tools to use for teaching and learning i've seen the hard work and education of our
superintendent our administrators teachers and staff to provide everything that our families
in our community need to raise the bar and close the achievement gap during this time of pandemic
our school was able to transition from on-site learning to distance learning days after the
school was closed the school was able to provide grab and grow meals to our families to our community
in addition our schools also provided laptops for all our students work packets log information to
online resources and technical support for those who need it cfscs is an important part of our
community for teachers staff parents and students this is our family in our home the families in the
community that we serve rely on us to provide them with good education that we've been doing
everything we grant a request to renew our charter our families our students matter we matter thank
you for your time thank you and here's the voice of a parent um is there one more speaker or was
that our last speaker oh we still have one more okay thank you you may may go ahead please
okay
speaker can you move closer to to the mic we're unable to hear you
yeah sorry it's a recording
the parent says that the teachers were patient and that the help provided to the students
during school and after school with homework they have made a big difference in my child's
academic performance and for that reason she is very grateful with the teachers and the
administrators at the school thank you thank you speakers do we have one more or has everyone
spoken thank you thank you very much for calling next speaker please state your name and affiliation
for the record you are now unmuted and your time starts now
my name is alice grixby and i am a board member of the inglewood unified school district
i'm here to urge the denial of the renewal petition for today's first start
it this school has not been a good partner with the district and nothing about their interaction
with the district could be characterized as even remotely cooperative their lack of cooperation
with the district epitomizes their long-standing history of antagonism toward their
authorities as well which includes a prior revocation of the los angeles county office
of education the evidence has been presented both the inglewood unified school district board
and the la county board time recommended i urge the denial of today's first start
thank you speaker next speaker please state your name
and affiliation for the record you are unmuted and your time starts now
hello my name is dr murphy i'm the principal of benetton school
i met a mother yes dr murphy from today's fresh heart speaker of those children here with me yes
speaker um i believe your computer volume is up and we're getting an echo could you please turn
it down for us can you hear me now yes perfect thank you thank you my name is dr murphy
i am the principal of benetton school i met a mother and father of four children
who were scholars from today's fresh start the parents of these children shared with me that
their children's start was not fresh they indicated the school's environment was very chaotic
and there were many behavior issues that were swept under the rug there were no positive
behavior supports in place and their son was even injured in class and there was no contact made to
them as parents from administration they also shared that the school's curricular resources were
low and even students deaths were limited fast forward they shared with me that if they knew
what they knew about our school district they would have had their children in our school district
instead of today's fresh start thank you thank you your time has expired
next speaker please state your name and affiliation for the record your time starts now
hello my name is trevino jones and i am a teacher here in inglewood unified school district
i'm here to voice my strong opposition to the renewal of today's fresh start charter school
their behavior is particularly egregious in light of the fact that our that our state is entering
into yet another budgetary crisis where each dollar for our public schools is invaluable
this charter has had countless opportunities to demonstrate that they are a good partner in
education however today's fresh starts unethical practices have been going on for years without
any accountability and continue to this day i ask that you listen to our voices this is a charter
school that is being opposed at all levels of the local community from myself as a classroom
teacher to our local teachers union to district administration to the mayor of inglewood and by
unanimous agreement by the los angeles county board of education the los angeles time has several
stories on today's fresh start shady dealings today's fresh start does not deserve renewal and
i ask that you recommend denial of this petition thank you thank you next speaker please state your
name and affiliation for the record you are unmuted and your time starts now
hello this is margaret evans and i'm a board member of the inglewood unified school district
i want to raise to the commission the chilling exchange that occurred during the public hearing
for the los angeles county board of education on the charter schools renewal during the public
hearing today's fresh start was asked a simple question by board member johnson about what has
changed since they were revoked in 2007 by the county board the board member wanted to know
to what extent the charter school learns from its prior malfeasance with respect to its inadequate
governance leading to self-dealing transactions and conflicts of interest the charter schools
struggled and ultimately failed to provide a satisfactory answer in fact rather than answering
the question they appear to defy the concern namely they claim that they that the revoked
program was a different charter school than the one previously overseen by the county board
despite having the same name same program same operators and same board today's fresh start
simply does not reflect any intention to change instead the renewal documents and their prior
history indicating intention to continue their problem course thank you please deny them thank
you speaker next speaker please state your name and affiliation for the record your time starts
now and you're unmuted my name is daniel redd i'm a credential teacher for today's fresh start
charter school and i'm for the renewal of today's fresh start charter school where would your lives
be without education teachers and most of all a school of choice attending to the data for the
assessment of student performance and progress's website today's fresh start charter school has
given students and parents an opportunity to access a safe school where students are achieving
literacy and english and math at today's fresh start charter school students are learning the
united states constitution how to vote and the joy of practicing democracy in america at today's
fresh start charter school students have shown patterns of never showing up late and having
perfect attendance throughout the school year at today's fresh start charter school they have helped
me to clear my single subject teaching credential that was recommended to the california commission
on teacher credentialing by the los angeles county office of education at today's fresh start charter
school we can consistently talk and have professional developments with experts in the
field of education that can help our school stay in existence and possibly build relationships
and today's fresh start charter school and our community that have never been in existence before
on behalf of today's fresh start thank you speaker your time is up that you got renewed today's
fresh start charter school's license thank you thank you next speaker please state your name
and affiliation for the record you're unmuted and your time starts now
hello my name is josephine williams and i was going to say something else but i am really upset
because i know for a fact that today's fresh start families have been coming to iusd to give
breakfast and lunch for their children and i am also highly offended and concerned because was
that the same bishop young who allegedly helped lead iusd into insolvency and have been trying to
be hired again by iusd these are the people today's fresh start hang out with it's about
money it is not about the children and i'm tired of people coming into inglewood and trying to
make money off our children enough is enough to the parkers the bishop young and everybody else
and that fake dashboard that you showed with yellow and yellow and orange of cde showed and
yours is all green stop the lying it's about money we need more for our students i am tired time
that they thank you speaker next speaker please state your name and affiliation for the record
you're unmuted and your time starts now
hello yes please state your name and affiliation for the record your time starts now
is it me it's you you're the next caller all right thank you thank you hi there my name is
saranga and i want to celebrate first our school with hard work and cooperation of the administration
teachers and students families did a fantastic job preparing and training both teachers and
students transfer to online education during this unexpected pandemic and i must say i am grateful
we are grateful for all comments from all involved and we value that now i humbly ask you to please
grant the opportunity to continue to serve our children families and communities all we need is
a chance to continue working to make our school better sir madam we have the ability to move
our ability and the motivation to solve our many challenges and so do our students
we are not a perfect school we are not perfect sirs and madams but we need time for corrections
we want to be better and please grant us the opportunity thank you speaker
we value your consideration thank you speaker we appreciate your time thank you thank you
next speaker please state your name and affiliation for the record your time starts now
my name is taniqa flanaugh i am a parent in inglewood unified
with regard to today's first start the court of appeal appealed the finding that golden day
school a preschool operated by student parker wrongfully sought reimbursements from the state
department of education for 48 employees there were actually employees of today's first start
in other words while tfs was receiving ava funding to cover its payroll dr parker was claiming
reimbursement from the state for these same employees including clark parker senate law
under its preschool contract with the state department of education the court found as
results the departments determined that nine hundred and thirty thousand six hundred fifty
seven dollars in payroll costs relating to today's first start were inappropriately charged
to the child development program for the period july 1 26 2006 through june 30 2008
within a month after the judgment again time today for about three million time thank you
speaker your time is up we appreciate you calling in next speaker please state your
name and affiliation for the record your time starts now
now
hi my name is akita johnson and my son isaac attends today's fresh start i enrolled isaac
at this school because we live in a country where black students are least likely to become
proficient readers by third grade be placed in gifted and talented education programs be
taught by credentialed teachers who share their cultural experiences even though this doubles the
likelihood they can attend college and they are least likely to feel emotionally safe and valued
this school provides these supports and refuses to follow the 60 year old trend of leading students
black students in particular behind lost chains and transitions are realities that students of
color know all too well and significantly devastate their life chances please don't introduce another
disruption to our students by closing the doors of this school my son deserves better i looked
around inglewood and south l.a for a school that was free that was clean that had resources and
that would value my son i found it in today's fresh start thank you so much for your time and
thank you for listening thank you caller next caller please state your name and affiliation
for the record you are unmuted and your time starts now
hi my name is yael girth and i'm a teacher in inglewood unified school district i previously
taught at la tiara which is a k a k-8 school that does everything that fresh start says that they
do there is nothing unique about what fresh start does and and you guys have even shown that their
test scores are the same as us so they're not doing anything special i would like before you
vote to take a look at anna phillips los angeles times for march 27th 2019 and that is one of the
reasons why i am so against fresh start because they are making money off of those kids and not
giving them all the resources that they need we in inglewood give every resource we can to help
give every resource we can we have after school programs we have tutoring we have all kinds of
things we have robotics they are not offering anything that we don't offer and we gave out
laptops i even was one of the teachers who gave out laptops when we had to close our doors on
march 13th please deny this sham of a charter school thank you thank you speaker next speaker
you are now in the queue please state your name and affiliation for the record your time starts now
my name is vali herandes de luna and i'm representing today's roger tartie school
i recently graduated from tfcs this school has changed academically for the best i have been
able to get a number of opportunities while attending for example being a part of the national
junior honor society teachers inspired guide enlighten and motivate scholars every day when
learning new aspects they remind you all this time to believe in yourself and always be the
best of you the staff here are incredibly considerate of the scholars when needed you know
you can count on them for anything i would really like to see my sister graduate at today's first
right charter school thank you thank you next speaker you are now unmuted please state your
name and affiliation for the record
hello can you hear me we can hear you hello yes please yes my name is paulette francis and i'm
a teacher for england unify school district and i'm urging the board to deny the charter today's
fresh charter today's fresh charter school represents all the lowest standards of unethical
behavior that is in well documented today and in the local media it is important that all schools
whether public or charter are held to the same high ethical standards of behavior because
education our children matters not only does their education matter but who educates
educates our children also matters and it's time for the board to stop blinking and turn
a blind eye to unethical behavior of such charters as today's fresh start so i urge you to deny
renewal of today's fresh charter thank you thank you next speaker you are now unmuted please state
your name and affiliation for the record hi this is um diamond logan and i have three kids that
attend fresh start charter school i'm a parent and i would be very sad if the school closes
my kids are doing well academically and i have a daughter that just graduated eighth grade and
she will be attending the vinci high which is a prime school charter school in hawthorne
and my second and fourth grader are doing very well and i i assisted them doing the learning and
the teachers provided them with so much work as if they were in schools and i would be very
disappointed if the school closed we've tried inglewood schools and they just did not exceed
like they are doing at today's fresh start thank you thank you next speaker you are now unmuted
please state your name and affiliation for the record your time starts now
now
good afternoon my name is tibana keza from good afternoon my name is tibana keza a student from
today's fresh start charter school i'm calling to plead on behalf of today's fresh start charter
school inglewood please do not close the school down it is like a home to me and my siblings
here we have we have learned and educate achieved because of the school there are amazing teachers
who come to work every day to teach us there are beautiful classes and environments here they
accept us for who we are if we close the school down we will we my service will have no school to
go to we're this is one of a kind and this is a life school for us so for the sake of children
and parents please do not close the school down i love the school
thank you thank you thank you speaker next speaker please state your name and affiliation
for the record you are now unmuted and your time starts now
asia flowers licensed clinical social worker and parent i would like to strongly encourage that we
keep the school open my daughter has been attending this school since kindergarten and she absolutely
loves it it's a second home for her she has really become a scholar here the administrative
the administration is very supportive all her teachers have been supportive towards her growth
she's really soared here you know her learning during COVID-19 has been a smooth transition and
i really would like to say it's really hard right now trying to find a school during COVID-19
to to find somewhere to take our children and i would really like for you all to consider the
parents that are working every day in this current time also i'd like to keep my child in a community
that teaches them about their heritage and in inglewood she learns that from the school and
so please keep charter school open thank you speaker next speaker please state your name
and affiliation for the record you are unmuted and your time starts now
hello my name is ariel my niece attends today's fresh start i'm calling in support of today's
fresh start charter school in inglewood my niece and our family have all been a part of the today's
fresh start community for six plus years while attending the school she's reached many academic
milestones some of them being on honor roll and also being inducted into the junior honors society
outside of academic she's also thrived by gaining the skill of public speaking that came from after
school programs and cheerleading which she enjoyed which was just one of the many after
school programs she attended this past year transitioning to online learning with speedy
organized seamless during the covid pandemic that we're all dealing with the school is not only
important to her but to our family and the community do not close the school it would be a
disservice please keep today's fresh start open not only for the community but for our children
thank you thank you speaker next speaker please state your name and affiliation for the record
you are unmuted and your time starts now
hello yes hello yes we can hear you please proceed with your comments
yes my name is irene green and i am the principal of chelsea elementary school
and i just wanted to say that the district has properly denied today's fresh start renewal
petition the charter school fails to meet the academic renewal eligibility in education code
47607 subdivision b the school has not been is not likely to successfully implement the program
presented in the petition the petition failed to provide a reasonably comprehensive description
of all required elements of a charter petition and the charter school presents an unsound
educational program for the pupils to be enrolled in a charter school dr torres based upon all the
information presented regarding today's fresh start history its failure to meet academic
performance requirements its lack of cooperation and compliance its ongoing violations of laws
laws designed to time students public funds thank you speaker your time is
your your time is up speaker thank you very much for your call thank you very much
next next speaker please state your name and affiliation for the record
you are unmuted and your time starts now
oh hello uh can you hear me yeah yes we can hear you okay my name is gavin english i'm a
special ed teacher with uh inglewood unified school district and i just wanted to uh point
out that that schools like this are are present a uh a uh real disservice to the community and
for for the sheer uh reason that they they don't accept students with severe disabilities all of
these students are turned away and that is a it's a disservice to the community it's a
disservice to these students it's discrimination and that's just one of the reasons that this
charters uh charter needs to be denied thank you thank you speaker next speaker please state
your name and affiliation for the record you are unmuted and your time starts now
hello good evening everyone can you hear me yes please please go ahead and begin your comments
my name is i'm a parent of a today my daughter attend today first school this school is a very
good school i'll see both academically and uh morally improvement in the life of my two kids
i'm also a student i'm a naughty student and these teachers they work with parents also please
please if it be a very big stress for me if this school is closed down help me to support my dream
i say no by opening this school because it will be hard for me to look for another school for my
case because they are doing well even my sister's one is here he has disability he's improving no
longer pee on himself they cooperate with us they they have good teachers that work with kids
according to the way they can learn time for the time family thank you so much speaker your
time's up we appreciate your call next speaker please state your name and affiliation for the
record you are unmuted and your time starts now jennis wallace ingaloo teacher if today's fresh
start had a 97 to 100 participation in their continuity of learning during covet 19
why did we receive requests from today's fresh start students and their families when they came
to our bennett queue monroe and hudnall elementary campuses from ingaloo unified school district to
provide them with laptops while receiving the meals we provided our families in need this is
because today's fresh start families needed assistance from their local public schools
that they have not received from the school that their children is enrolled in of all of the charter
schools in ingaloo today's fresh start students were the only ones asking for iusd laptops
please deny their renewal request thank you thank you next speaker please state your name
and affiliation for the record you are unmuted and your time starts now
hello yes please go ahead okay oh i'm dr charles for cablo i'm calling to
call you to please renew the charter for the uh today's first school i have to keep it that
school and before i brought in there i put them in many schools which wasn't good in one of the
school districts they were they were constantly being bullied i haven't sent any school around
this place that is as good as that school for now and i just noticed a lot of people are saying a
lot of things but what's on the ground shows that they are having good results so i urge you to
please renew that call thank you thank you next speaker please state your name and affiliation
for the record you are unmuted and your time starts now
hello my name is lenise porter and i'm calling and so
i'm calling to support the decision made by the inglewood unified school district
and the cde to deny the renewal to today's fresh start
there are several newspaper articles that tell the community about their illegal operations
speaker are you still and approving them to remain open in our minority community we will send
a message to you that the state value minority students less than the more
affluent area communities please support our community and removing illegal operated
organizations who benefit financially without providing adequate services for our children
thank you thank you next speaker please state your name and affiliation for the record you are now
unmuted and your time starts now
hello my name is apontessa meadow i'm a student from today's fresh starters school i believe that
my school should not close or shut down the reason i say this is because at my school the speakers
are very nice very and there is also a very good educational system the school is great our
state test scores have always been good and those are my reasons i say my school should stand
because it has made me the person that i am today because i have been at that school since
kindergarten and i am now going to the sixth grade for these reasons i beg you all to let my
school open to educate other learning minds thank you next speaker please state your name
and affiliation for the record you're now unmuted and your time starts now
now
good afternoon my name is janima hipala calling on behalf of today's fresh start charter school
i have the pleasure of working with this wonderful organization for more than six years
at today's fresh start we have a great special education program our special education program
has been successful in providing educational opportunities for individuals with disabilities
we have effective special education staff who inspire and encourage our students to achieve
success inside and outside outside the classroom please approve our school so we can continue
helping our students successfully develop to their fullest potential thank you thank you
next speaker please state your name and affiliation for the record
you are now unmuted and your time starts now
now
speaker hi my name is dr kane yes can you hear me yes we can hear you thank you
hi my name is dr kane and i am a parent and an employee in inglewood unified school district i
am asking to deny the charter renewal as the charter's purpose is to provide services that
are unavailable in their home districts this is not the case as inglewood unified provides the
same programs and a vast amount of programs district-wide as a parent you want what's best
for your children that is why my four children have attended iusd since kindergarten with one
entering her senior year in college this would not be possible if it were not for the love
commitment from our teachers our staff and our community in inglewood unified school district
so for that i am asking that they deny the charter renewal of today's fresh start thank you
thank you next speaker please state your name and affiliation for the record
you are now unmuted and your time starts now
speaker hello yes hello yes you are now unmuted and your name is joy
this is joy i just called because i had a lie that was so hurting to me i had somebody say that
this uh people from today's fresh start came to their school to get laptops that's a big lie
and it's so hurting because today's fresh start they have their own laptop and every student got
laptop my children got laptop and when it's not okay we go back to school and we change it we did
not get laptop from anybody and that lie was so bad they shouldn't they shouldn't be lying please
thank you
thank you and callers please remember that each individual is allowed one minute each
next speaker please state your name and affiliation for the record
your time start you are unmuted and your time starts now
now
hello yes please please state your name and affiliation for the record
hi my name is sensu iron i'm a teacher from inglewood i am calling to oppose the renewal
of today's fresh start charter this school does not deserve to have this charter renewed
evidences indicate that the school has historically been doing shady business
not putting the students needs before the gains of their leaders this charter school is not
servicing the community's total student population including those students with severe disabilities
who are sent away to their home school in addition erratic academic performances is one more reason
enough to deny the renewal of the school instead i would like to invite the current students
to attend the inglewood unified school district our caring and dedicated teachers and staff
welcome you with open arms we will make sure that you will be careful and your academic needs will
time time we spend more time money for students speakers thank you very much your time your time
is up just a quick reminder each individual is allowed one public comment for one minute
unfortunately we'll have to disconnect people who are calling in more than once
next speaker please state your name and affiliation for the record
and you are unmuted and your time starts now
hello yes please please state your name
my name is ike age marco i'm calling on behalf of today's fresh charter school inglewood
um i want to say like um the school is a very good school for my kids i have two
two sons over there the learning and the welcoming environment is so lovely
especially this time of the pandemic i don't know if the school should be closed what i'm
going to do with my kids and they are they love it they are looking forward like you know going
to school every day so please i'm in support with the staff and the students to keep the school
open thank you then i have my son to say something about you thank you
hello my name is henry and i am going to take the cfsa charter school and i would like to say that
cfsa is a good school we have good teachers that teach us a lot
a lot cfsa has a welcoming and good learning environment that no one will resist
they do cfsa has activities like spelling beats and math beats where everyone wants to participate
they do these activities once in a school year for college students the purchase of learning
so students can get more educated by the questions they ask i would like you
to support organizations to keep cfsa single work open thank you thank you next speaker
please state your name and affiliation for the record you are now unmuted and your time starts now
now
hi my name is miss sam i am the ex-parent of today's fresh start please listen i put my child
in today's fresh start three months then i had to pull my child out there was no academic support
for my son to be successful they did not come through for my child the grass looks green at
today's fresh start but it's some fake grass it's a stale start
thank you for your comment speaker next speaker you are now unmuted
and please state your name and affiliation for the record your time starts now
speaker are you there
the ground talking hello yes hello you're now live please state your name and affiliation for
the record your time starts now can you hear me yes we we can hear you please proceed with your
comments hello my name is akaila carter my son attends today's fresh start charter school his
name is aiden carter first off i would like the power of god to intervene any negative remarks
towards today's fresh start charter faith of a mustard seed will um shall prevail
i would like to request that our school receives their renewal the benefits of keeping our school
open in my opinion well outweighs the risk of closing our school it is my belief that today's
fresh start academy anklewood sites will continue top quality service services helping students to
connect with each other teachers staff materials and academics that our schools strive hard to
thank you thank you speaker your time has now expired we thank you calling in next speaker
please state your name and affiliation for the record you are now unmuted and your time starts
now
next speaker you are now unmuted and your time starts now my name is julie safe i don't know how
much longer the inglewood community has to be quiet about today's fresh start illegal activities
one of my children goes to animal charter and another one is at calso elementary school in iusd
today's fresh start is not an educational partner dedicated to students instead the priority is to
enrich the parkers their fiscal misconduct has allowed to be occurred by their board
and their failure to put students first is why i did not put my children in that school
i am asking that the board does the right thing by the students of inglewood and deny the charter
for today's fresh start send your child to a school in iusd or even animal inglewood
thank you speaker next speaker please state your name and affiliation for the record
you are now unmuted and your time starts now
speaker are you on the line
okay thank you next speaker you are now unmuted and please state your
name and affiliation for the record
hello yes please speak state your name and affiliation my name is glenn sterling i'm a
minister in the community and i want to support today's fresh start charter and getting their
charter renewed this sounds very political and there is no facts to back up anything that i've
heard inglewood unified school district say and i want to see the charter get its charter renewed
and hope you have a nice day thank you very much thanks for calling in next speaker please state
your name and affiliation for the record you are now unmuted and your time starts now
hello yes yes we can hear you we can hear you okay my name is bishop robert t douglas senior
i'm the president of the inglewood area administrative association can you hear that
hello yes we can hear you you can go ahead and proceed with your comments
okay yeah i want to say to you thank you for your assessment and your time giving us this
but i'm i'm extremely hurt i've been a resident of inglewood since 73 i'm extremely hurt because
fred today's fresh start does matter today's fresh start does matter today's fresh start does matter
we have students and parents and staff and faculty who are major contributors to the academic success
of the inglewood area community being the president of the inglewood area ministers
association i'm not reading from a script i'm coming from my heart the bible said in the book
of galatians chapter number five verse number 15 but if we bite and devour one another be careful
that we do not consume one of another thank you speaker your time has now uh up uh we appreciate
the call next speaker please state your name and affiliation for the record please um you're
unmuted and your time starts now good afternoon my name is sakura koshikawa a teacher at tfsbs
compton in the last hearing a gentleman on the board concluded that the school technically meets
the criteria for renewal and for the sake of 500 families it would be unconscionable to close it
emotions aside the fact remains that the school meets the academic and financial
requirements for renewal while there's always room for improvement the school must be doing
something right to meet those standards furthermore you're evaluating a charter school that
has been around for some time while there are voices who speak in opposition there are countless
boys and family who have stayed with the school for years and could use the stability of an
established school and use in certain times especially looking forward to the transition to
fall also safe are the jobs of many hard-working teachers and staff who have met expectations
but would face non-existent job market despite meeting standards for the sake of those returning
students and families and teachers please renew the charter as it meets the criteria for renewal
thank you thank you speaker for your call next speaker you are now unmuted please state your
name and affiliation for the record your time starts now hi my name is kelly stewart and i am
a 13 year resident of inglewood and i am an educator i've taught for almost 15 years in
similar communities as tfsds and i've seen what underperforming schools look like and today's
fresh start is far from it they say that the purpose of education is to open the windows of
the mind those windows are open at tfsds and we need more examples of schools that are successfully
ran by people of color with intellect and compassion and also by teachers who care
closing this school would be disruptive to the american dream of many families and it is a shame
that this school is under unwarranted scrutiny and the biggest casualty is at schools that serve
students well like this one are historically denied the chance to uplift and build black and
brown and diverse and all students and families i strongly urge the renewal of today's fresh start
charter school thank you thank you next speaker please state your name and affiliation for the
record you are unmuted and your time starts now
my name is destiny and i have two children at today's fresh start i implore the board to weigh
more heavily what has been reported by the actual staff students and parents of today's fresh start
not outside parties that have nothing to lose and everything to gain in the form of increased
ada my children were provided with a touchscreen laptop during covid they have a full lab they have
teachers of color they have black teachers they're all fully credentialed and this is
not something that you see at school that have over a 40 black population and that might not
mean a lot to other people but it means a lot to me my household in my community closing the door
to that school to send a message that we don't care about schools that serve black students with
that level of integrity the the commitment that i'm seeing to drag the parker seems very personal
and political and our children should not be in the middle of that when their benchmarks are being
met and they are cared for and being shown that they are valued i think time thank you
thank you speaker next speaker please state your name and affiliation for the record
you are unmuted and your time starts now
hello yes we can hear you my name is Leonard towns and i'm a community member please deny the petition
of today's fresh start charter school the school has proven themselves to be completely corrupt
and more interested in enriching themselves in falsifying data than educating our children
i implore upon you to expeditiously deny the petition with our reservation and or condition
thank you thank you next speaker please state your name and affiliation for the record
you are unmuted and your time starts now
good afternoon my name is Tara Booth and i'm a proud Englewood Unified School District teacher
let's give students a fresh start why are the leaders keeping more than three percent in the
reserve it was stated earlier that Englewood schools spend twelve thousand dollars per pupil
while pfs spends nine thousand dollars why don't they use some of that extra money to up their game
and for the record Monroe did not close in 2018 Woodworth Monroe merged it was a merger
Monroe never closed put that on the record and also iusd serves all students all students
and you need to know that there are different levels of special ed not just rsp
there are something called scc that pfs does not provide parents please stop by an Englewood school
and give your child a fresh start thank you thank you speaker next speaker please state your name
and affiliation for the record you are unmuted and your time starts now
yes speaker are you there
okay next speaker please state your name and affiliation for the record your time starts now
yes speaker are you online
yes can you hear me we can please proceed with your comments thank you my name is Jonathan
Chamberlain i'm an iusd school public teacher it's already been stated but i want to state
it again today fresh starts demonstrate that excuse me discriminates against students with
moderate and severe disabilities by turning them away simply because the charter school's parents
have expressed that they do not like special day classes they are not committed to educating all
children like we are and in the end it is the district schools that ultimately bear the
disproportionate impact of serving those who require the most need and attention i've also
seen children return to district schools from today's fresh start and express that they did
not receive the quality education that they deserve or that they have been pushed out of the
school for wholly illegitimate reasons it is offensive to me as a teacher from a school
district that needs all financial support that it can get that the founders of today's fresh start
have continued to take public school dollars intended for the children in our community
enrich themselves personally thank you speaker your time has now ended
next speaker please state your name and affiliation for the record
you're unmuted and your time starts now
my name is stephanie more and i'm calling on behalf of today's fresh starts i've been a member
of the charter community since year one of charters in california longer than any of you
calling in or up there i heartily ask you to approve our charter you want to see resources
you want to see special ed you want to see all of those things they say we don't have
we have more than any school district or any school in inglewood certainly during the pandemic
we did provide for our students every day lunch every day i remember the lady that called a few
and her impassioned plea she was at the last one so apparently they drag her up so she can say
we don't serve lunch we served lunch even during easter break which you all didn't do
if you cared about our students we wouldn't be here today all of us here fighting for our children
listen to the parents of our school 500 plus who want the school to stay open this has been a
against the parkers time please thank you speaker your your time is now up we appreciate
we appreciate your call
speakers on the public comment line we have a number of you still on the line i am going
to ask if you do not wish to to make a public comment to please hang up from this line we're
about to go through the list one by one and ask if you would like to make public comment
hello yes speaker you are in speaker you are now unmuted would you like to make a public comment
is this is me yes it's it's you we oh so sorry hello my name my name is notable
peres i am the ceo chief operating officer for the amazing wood unified school district
i urge this committee to continue to deny tfs it is not a coincidence that iusd laco board and
an array of articles have been reaching exposing the disarray and fraud tcs has accrued physical
misconduct on tfs 2017 irs form 990 they state they have no transactions involving current employees
no transactions with uh family members no transactions with ality entity which is not
only a lie but fraud they should be ashamed to know that they made national news and identified
of the top five worst worst schools the lies continue through this pandemic we have
welcomed our doors to all of tfs students and we continue to do so it is understandable employees
from tfs are calling in to support tfs but the reality is they are only fighting for their job
no worries we will welcome you grab and go meals as well has been given out thank you speaker your
your time i urge you to please deny tfs thank you thank you thank you for calling
yes you are you are now unmuted uh would you like to provide a public comment
hello yes you are now unmuted would you like to provide a public comment please state your name
and affiliation good afternoon board members my name is dr angela i am a middle school teacher
at tfs fts and have been an educator for over 25 years since my arrival at the school i have seen
incredible work done by today's restart and what it does for its students since my arrival i have
seen how education and instruction is personalized for the students and how the school and the
organization offers culturally relevant and responsive education the students not only
learn in class but are also encouraged to participate in extracurricular activities like
sports choir and the french club the fact that students start as early as pk and end with eighth
grade is a testament to the trust and satisfaction of the families we serve the continued enrollment
allows parents and teachers to form bonds that are critical importance to the students growth
and development like any school there are areas for improvement but to rush to close thank you
speaker your time is now up thank you for your call for and disruptive to students and their
thank you thank you
speaker hello yes you are now unmuted please state your name and affiliation for the record please
my name is laraine richards and i represent the california teachers association cta recommends
that the state board of education vote to deny the renewal petition for tfs as recommended by
the cde and the accs for the following reasons fails to meet the academic requirements of renewal
in the charter schools act from 2018 to 2019 the percent of students meeting and exceeding standards
in ela declined for nearly every grade assessed scores declined for ela for every subgroup the
percent of students meeting and exceeding standards for math declined in half of those grades assessed
math scores declined for sped el and hispanic students cde staff does acknowledge that the
tfs is academically low performing as a whole which is certainly not good enough for renewal
considering the numerous concerns authorized hopping ethics issues non-compliance with the
brown act and failure to be held accountable by or even minimally by the authorization
state board should deny tfs thank you speaker you have now reached your time we appreciate your call
thank you
speaker you are now unmuted would you like to provide a public comment
hello yes would you like to provide a public comment oh oh wonderful that's me oh yes i would
thank you please state your name and affiliation for the record yes my name is devlin just i'm
sorry i'm going to make it so this thing doesn't echo if you don't mind okay there you go yes my
name is debora decker and i am a teacher at the inglewood school district i teach the arts my
over the years many charter schools have been welcomed into the school district by
the laco school board therefore there are many schools parents are have to choose from
therefore only those schools with stellar records should be able to continue with their
charter fresh start is not one of those they have had numerous complaints from both parents
and teachers charter schools are publicly funded therefore they need to be highly scrutinized in
terms of student achievement which includes resources for time and thank you thank you
speaker thank you very much your time's up thank you
speaker you're now unmuted if you'd like to provide public comment please speak
uh state your name and affiliation for the record your time starts now
hi my name is miguel and i am an administrator at inglewood unified school district oak street
elementary i am asking you to not renew the petition for today's fresh start the purpose
of charter is to inspire and innovate model schools and to teach those new strategies and share
with with the local districts that was a radical and innovative idea but today's fresh start is
not doing any of that we employees will no longer be quiet while while these entities like today's
fresh start use the students of inglewood to fatten their pockets charter schools such as today's
fresh start no longer are welcomed in our community we demand that our public schools and approved
charter schools be committed to serving all students the lack of transparency the refusal
to require to submit required paperwork the blatant disregard for rules and laws
of this charter school is shocking i'm surprised it's taken this long i'm asking today
to please be with us thank you thank thank you speaker
speaker you are now unmuted please state your uh name and affiliation for the record your time starts
now hello my name is gloria vanegas and i am a proud parent volunteer pta president and a product
of schools within the inglewood unified school district i am asking you to deny the petition
for today's fresh start charter i have four daughters who attended schools within the district
two of which are college graduates and attended schools in inglewood my experience with inglewood
district has been amazing i have never felt the need to drive my daughters to other districts or
charter schools despite being recruited as a parent volunteer i have been able to see the
dedication and amazing work our teachers and administration do and have towards our students
there are a lot of exciting things happening in our schools we have a music program
and other academic programs coming we have a strong school community if it wouldn't have been
for my daughter's inglewood high school program college summit they would have never made it to
college thank you thank you speaker you are now i'm sorry speaker you are now unmuted please
speak your name and affiliation for the record your time starts now
speaker are you available
speaker you please state your name and affiliation for the record you're now unmuted
once again callers if you are on the line you will be asked to make a public comment
please disconnect from the line if you do not wish to make a public comment
caller you are now unmuted please speak your name and affiliation for the record your time starts now
now
yes please speaker
speaker you're now unmuted please speak your name and affiliation for the record your time starts now
hello this is dina wilson from los angeles county office of education i'm pleased to be
here today representing the county board not only does the county board have ample findings
with substantial evidence to deny this charter we had previous experience with oversight
of a tfs charter and did indeed revoke it in 2007 when reviewing this charter the county
board did review academic improvement for all groups of pupils as the most important
factor and found that the tfs inglewood failed to show increases for all groups of students
additionally the charter continues to show concerns of conflict of interest
self-dealing transactions and concerns about brown act compliance they do not show a commitment
to equity as proven in their l cap a review of their most recent l cap shows that they have
failed to properly identify actions and services funded by supplement one concentration funds
principally directed thank you thank you your time we encourage you to uphold recommendations
and deny the charter thank you thank you
speaker you're now unmuted please speak your name and affiliation for the record
record hello yes you are now online please speak your name and affiliation for the record
so you can hear me yes we can hear you please proceed my name is lisa um my name is lisa and
i'm a parent um i'm actually talking i'll be talking about not my uh by articles or anything
over how much money they're spending or not but i will talk about my own experience as a parent
and as a student i went to my row and to woodworth and they didn't provide it any like i went for a
whole year school year with just substitute after substitute after substitute and they're not
they're not they don't care about their students they um they i actually went to either morning
site high school and i had a teacher where she didn't care she let other students ditch
and let them do whatever they wanted i had to repeat my class because of the teachers she
didn't she didn't care and for my kids right now that he's going that he has been going to speaker
thank you your time's up
i'm noticing several are calling back in that have already provided
a public comment once again please please disconnect from the line
speaker please state your name and affiliation for the record you are now unmuted
hello my name is renee hudson and i have two siblings who attend a fresh start i'm quite
satisfied with the academics that are provided by the school i like the teachers i like the
support that they give our kids and i'm recommending that you keep the school open thank you
speaker you are now unmuted please state your name and affiliation for the record
hi this is tora i have a little girl who's been there for about six years now
i've had experience with a child in the inglewood school district and was not happy
none whatsoever the education was was horrible i've had teachers missing i've had you know the
safety of the campus there was no safety none whatsoever so i'm you know i'm definitely in
support of them continuing to open it open it i don't think that any school is perfect
today for a start when my daughter needed her iep they were on top of it we got it done within
a matter of months within a month with the inglewood school district in order to get my
son a 504 plan i actually had to take legal action and it took it took months and i had to
take legal action and was pretty surprised at that so i'm not happy with the inglewood
school district i really don't want to send my child to an inglewood school i'm okay with today
fresh start charter i would love to see a little time but i'm there we're there okay thank you
thank you speaker
speaker clarifying that this is a speaker and not the school on the line
you are unmuted please state your name and affiliation for the record
please confirm this is a speaker and not the school
thank you i am deleting you out of the the queue
speaker you are now unmuted please speak your name and affiliation for the record
good afternoon board members and others on the call my name is judy may and i urge strongly urge
the renewal of the charter for today's fresh start charter school i'm a former director of
education for kaiser permanente i've been a resource specialist for compton unified
and i am a taxpayer most of all i can vouch for today's fresh start they are caring they are
sincere about affording each and every student with the tools they need it's a safe supported
healthy climate and conducive to learning inglewood unified shame on you shame on you we the
taxpayers had to bail you out we're not today's fresh start we're not bailing them out shame on
you we as educators should be working together not separate this is for the student thank you
speaker you have now reached your time limit next speaker you are now i am now unmuting you
please speak your name and affiliation for the record
yes yes you are now now online
yes you're you're online please speak your name
uh
hello speaker you are now unmuted please speak your name and affiliation for the record
yes hello can you hear me yes we can hear you wonderful okay um please renew today's fresh start
um we have everything that needs needs that is needed to be renewed um everything that they're
saying are all lies and just gruntled features with biased newspapers and really it's it's um
it's um please renew today's fresh start we have everything we have fed and accommodated students
we have supplied them with the laptops during covid um we have high reclassifications of the
el this is what matters we give support to our ieps with enrichment classes after school tutoring
emotional support behavioral management um we invest in our students and we empower our students
please renew today's fresh start thank you thank you for the call
speaker you are now unmuted please speak your name and affiliation for the record
speaker
speaker you are now and yes uh you're now in mute unmuted please speak your name and affiliation
for the record this is a call from senator congresswoman diane watson a board member of
today's fresh start charger school i hope the people that are on the call understand
a masterful job of getting the people that need the help and so many people in our community
neglect uh their own health and health conditions and now we're at a time
that we need to come together and fresh start give them a fresh start to do the things that
they need to do they have been super they have been successful and they have served the classes
time thank you
you
speaker you are now unmuted please state your name and affiliation for the record
record
speaker you're now unmuted yes uh you're now
we support uh fresh start uh fresh start school we support fresh start school
thank you all right
yes speaker you are now unmuted please speak your name and affiliation for the record
speaker you're online
thank you that concludes public comment
okay um given that there is no other public comment we'll now close the public hearing
and commence with the board discussion and action and first i'd like to ask ting
our sb liaison if she has any initial comments
um yes i'd be happy to i am wondering though if we feel like i don't want to drag this out
longer the meeting out longer but um wonder if the board members want to take a break
if this would be i think people are taking kind of a rolling break when they need a stretch
or whatever because we have two items after this okay happy okay i'm happy to move forward
so uh all right um again want to thank the public comments and for the speakers to have
waited in the queue to make their comments especially so late in the evening afternoon
as i stated in the other charter renewal item you know these i know that these issues are very
emotional and it is very important that we do hear all of the public and their thoughts on
this this issue so we are considering two charters renewals today with both similarities and
significant differences both have a loyal group of local supporters both have adequate facilities
both have strained relationships with their authorizers and both have varying degrees of
um academic performance um and the varying degrees two varying degrees the the academic
performance of both schools is better than the academic performance of comparison schools
however as i stated earlier although academic performance is the most important factor for
renewal there are other compelling factors that should not be ignored in a renewal decision
um what i see here is the two schools and what i see is a distinguishing factor is that
today's first start input has been in operations excuse me john henry has been uh was seeking its
first renewal today's first start englund has been in operation since 2009 and uh the the today's
first start uh organization has been operating schools since 2003 so a much longer history and
track record i will say that uh i have concerned i have really deep concerns raised in the cde staff
report um particularly for a school that has been operating this long and has had this history
uh i am i'm going to be a bit open for more discussions i know that it was there was a
lot of back and forth at the accs meeting and it is a very confusing given that the the history
of the organization and the and the various schools that have been in operations and the
county charter and all that so what i would encourage um board members to do is refer to
appendix one in the item i uh the department of education has uh provided some clarification
in that appendix one i think that might be helpful um in under for to clarify some of the matters
that have been um discussed so with that uh i will leave it to my fellow board members to ask
questions i'll ask our board members to raise your hand in the window i'm going to try to
manage this and see i assume all of us listened and we have several areas we may want to comment
about um and i guess i would ask member rucker i believe you're on did did you want to start
with any comments
can you hear me yes now we can thank you okay um so i do appreciate board members son
comments to open this conversation and i do have multiple concerns but my concerns are about this
charter are no different from the concerns that i have expressed in the past concerning
previous charters and the issues related to those charters so i need to make sure i i really do want
to make sure that for all of those parents and teachers and community members who called in to
share their concerns and their passions about these schools and these programs it's really
important to recognize today of all days why those passions and those concerns are being
expressed um not every child has an opportunity to go through school not let me change that not
every african american child not every african american parent has an opportunity to see a
school and to see a school program that they actually feel wants and welcomes their child
and they see their child succeeding many times african american parents when the children go
to school and they show up in school and they come home and they're successful and they like school
there's some kind of magic happening so for many of the parents who who have called in to express
their concerns and success and support of the magic that is happening at today's fresh start
i heard you and i understand that for you you have a great deal of support and you really are
vested in the support and the success of your child at this school i equally heard from parents
of students who didn't feel the same way who found the success that they needed in inglewood
so this is not a conversation about where the magic is in public education because there is
a formula or there is a moment a sense of connection that children who are successful
and that african american children who find success and connection can find for many and
multiple reasons whether it's at inglewood which we clearly heard and clearly understand
and the innovations that they are offering both through link learning which i personally have
awareness of and had the opportunity to help start as a field and as an area of study here
in california or whether it's in the shop classes and the art classes that are supported
through many high schools elementary schools and middle schools in inglewood as well as for the
parents who found great success for their children at today's fresh start we sit on this panel and
we have multiple metrics that have to be considered and that need to be considered to bring balance to
this conversation and as board member song pointed out i had great reservation about
the previous school and the reasons for the problems with that previous school and as she
pointed out it is a new school it is a startup and they have a shorter record of time in their
relationship both with their lea and now with the board this school is different this program is
different this charter management organization is different it has evolved it has changed it has
gotten savvy and from and i have concerns about what is in the public record i have concerns
about what is being conflated or what is being changed or what is not being
sunshineed with with the kind of transparency it should have many of my colleagues on the board
have heard me often argue and rail about the importance of the public function about the
implication or the application of the brown act and the need for clear transparent governance
in these charters and i have objected and voted against charters for that reason many of you have
heard me argue about how you balance the consideration about the academic performance
of the school over some of the other equally glaring and concerning problems which are parallel
and important in my mind and under the law and i have voted against those schools so my colleagues
on the board have heard me talk with great reason and rationality i hope about what my concerns are
not just about underperforming charters but charters that are being poorly managed or not
managed with public interest or having that hint of or specter of scandal and so that has always
been my concern and that has been my concern throughout my tenure on this board i have not
been inconsistent in that discussion but there's something further that's being raised today and
that's the issue of race for a lot of the folks who are having this conversation and having this
discussion about race this is not a question about whether or not public schools can serve
african-american children well and it's also not a question about which one of these public schools
the charter or the public schools in uberwood are serving african-american children better so
while race is a double-edged sword that often creeps into these conversations and the needs
urgent concerns of african-american parents and their children is a paramount concern to me
personally and to this board as we venture into a new frontier to talk about equity i think that
the issues of equity have been discussed and argued about passionately by both sides of this
argument by parents who support this charter as well as by parents who did not find their children
were successful in this charter and those parents were african-american on both sides of this table
and the same thing is true for parents who are seeking an alternative because of their
dissatisfaction with the way eaglewood is serving african-american children so as the board continues
their conversation and the discussion here having issues and discussions of race and having a
discussion about the is about how race is being served in this conversation does not serve us
well especially if it becomes politicized and it becomes the hockey puck that's pushed around from
one side to the other as the rationale of justification for us to deal with either our
discomfort or our self-righteous assertion that we have the answer we have the definitive answer
or we know better so that's all i actually want to say thank you eileen for giving me that
opportunity i appreciate that thank you member wrecker thank you very much for your comments
let me ask our member novel
yeah i'll make a couple of comments here
i'm extremely disappointed how we got here i think at the end of the day because of poor district
charter relationships kids get hurt and it it comes down to us to try and sort out this mess
and the truth for me is the petition is confusing it's hard to gain clarity on a multitude of issues
i don't see the relationship being repaired between the district and the charter
and i quite honestly don't see my ability to find the truth in the situation
the revocation of the charter that alleged revocation that today's fresh start would say
is not a revocation the alleged violations of students with disabilities that i'm sure
today's fresh start would dispute the county's description on slide 22 of a conflict of interest
that i'm sure today's fresh start would dispute this is a complex request that doesn't
promote or allow for complete clarity based on the disputed facts and for me
it's impossible to overturn cd's recommendation based on all of this that's all i have to say at
this time so i'll just ask one comment um i'm i'm worried for the kids um this is really challenging
times um for all kids and to face i mean obviously the school we're in the new school year now
in the new fiscal year and um i i just would say i i recognize what the parents said about
wanting a safe place for their kids and worried about starting a new school um and i um i'm
certainly i hear that they're beginning to look for new options but i think we have a responsibility
from englwood and los angeles to reach out to the students and to make their transition
should we not approve it safe and supportive i i worry for the students because i i think that
families and the students have chose it for a good reason and i in the end they're the ones that lose
um are there any other comments from board members
um member sung do we have a motion um well i i did want to follow up on on your your um concerns
and maybe we could ask uh englwood district you had in the prior asked the district uh you know
you know how they would take in the students or if you know if we were to deny this
petition how would the transition work with something like that and are they prepared
what they're looking at doing oh thank you so much for that question and for your comments um
we are extremely excited to welcome all families to the englwood unified school district
um we have 17 schools that we operate we have capacity at each one of our schools
we have amazing programs we have amazing teachers we have amazing principals and amazing classified
staff willing and ready to welcome all families to the englwood unified school district what we are
planning to do is to host a virtual meeting with our today's fresh start family to welcome them
we're offering two open houses that will be conducted at each one of our schools
we're planning for one in july and also one in august these open houses will provide our family
with an opportunity to get to know our amazing principals and teachers and staff so that they
could also learn about the unique programs that our district offers we're going to provide all
of our today's fresh start families a welcome packet we are excited to welcome them and to
invite them to open house activities and we're planning to send that information
to the today's fresh start community also we will provide opportunities for them to visit
the schools of their choice because we are an open enrollment district a district of choice
and so we will work very closely with each family member through our concierge service where we
will contact each family individually and assign a staff member to work with that family individually
to welcome them back to the englwood unified school district and to talk to them about the
programs that we offer to schedule a tour if that's something that our parents are interested in
doing and we're actually going to assign somebody to be the main point of contact for each family
member so that they know who to connect with directly in the event that this charter school
is closed thank you member strouse this is stephanie farland i just wanted to add to that
because we had mentioned in my presentation earlier that a good proportion of the students
from englwood would actually attend la unified schools we did reach out to la unified and they
responded by by saying that they will certainly engage and support all the families and students
who wish to enroll in an la unified school be it regular or charter thank you
can the charter school thank you can today's first start respond
this is a these are just questions for the school district at this point
um to clarify um so members son did we um address the questions that you had yeah the yeah this
board did i mean the school did i mean school district did sorry it's getting late yeah um
um do we have any other clarifying questions from board members before we look for a motion
eileen linda's hand is up
okay um member darling hammon
you're muted
and thanks for thanks for stepping in um i i was going to ask the question about the
the return of the students i appreciate the answer that we got it's first time i've heard
about concierge service for school children i like that concept um all children should have
concierge service i would just um associate my thoughts with those that were made by member
navo on given you know the various statements on both sides but also the concerns that were raised
about conflict of interest and other concerns i would find it hard to overturn the cde
recommendation thank you any other um karen do we have any other hands raised no
okay um members fun do you have a motion that you'd like to introduce yes i i appreciate all
my fellow board members comments and especially those of member rucker
this is a very very difficult decision it's heart-wrenching um because i know it involves
kids um however i am also in agreement with member navo and president linda darling hammon that
um these issues are of such a severity issues that are um severe enough and have been persisted
throughout the the life of the charter which has been very long that uh i have to go with the
department of education's recommendation to denial to deny uh the renewal of today's fresh start
do we have a second second
second by member glover woods um so um any further discussion um so um karen will you call roll call
yes kim
him yes i day yes matt
yes cynthia yes linda yes eileen yes ting
yes jim yes brenna yes and patricia yes okay unanimous vote
all right do we want to follow break for five minutes or are people okay to continue i think
i think we just want to finish the last two items and if people need to stretch or take a quick
break let's do a rolling break if that's okay okay uh do you want me to take the gavel back
thank you very much eileen i appreciate that um so uh at this point uh we're going to move to agenda
agenda item 22 which is the request to ratify the california department of education grant
application to the u.s department of education education stabilization fund um which is the
rethink k-12 education models grant the cd recommends that the state board ratify california's
education stabilization grant application to develop a statewide course access program for
all grade 6 through grade 12 students in california in order to help students be
career and college ready across the state's regional demographic and economic differences
and the item is presented by joseph science science of cde and joe there you are you may begin
hello members of the state board of education my name is joe signs and i'm the federal policy
liaison for the california department of education government affairs division
i'm proud to bring forward this collaborative proposal that is due to tireless work of staff
from the cde the state board of education and the governor's office
um also joining me um who will be answering some of your questions if needed is pradeep kodam
raju who is the director of the career and college transition division within cde pradeep and his
team worked long hours to complete this grant proposal and i also want to appreciate leslie
taylor who worked diligently to pull data in regards to the state's coronavirus burden
thank you sir
um our technology knows it's late too
even the computers are tired
um
perfect there we go um so thank you everyone to the state board um i definitely appreciate your long
hour spent over the last two days so in saying that i will make sure i get to the heart of the
matter um and then whatever questions you have i will along with pradeep will be happy to answer
so our recommendation is that the californ is that the californian department of education
recommends that the state board of education sb ratify california's education stabilization fund
rethink k-12 education models grant um we call it the esf rem grant for short
um that we ratify this application to develop a statewide course access program for all grades
six through 12 students in california as many of you know in response to covet 19 congress
passed the coronavirus aid relief and economic security cares act and it was enacted on march
27 2020 with a 30.75 billion dollars in emergency education funding to states
of a one percent set aside is where the esf rem grant comes from
the purpose of this grant is meant to support state educational agencies and states with the
highest coronavirus burden to address specific educational needs of students their parents
and teachers in public and non-public elementary schools in accordance with the cares act
the three absolute priorities for the grant competition are to provide funding through
micro grants to develop and or expand high quality course access programs or statewide
virtual school or to demonstrate a rationale to address the specific educational needs
of their states as related to remote learning and we're required to take on one of these
absolute priorities in the grant competition for our application
um these grants are peer reviewed by um peer reviewers with a range of experience in education
and background uh they would they will independently read score and provide written comments for grant
applications they're going to be 12 to 14 awards for states with the highest coronavirus burden
estimated funds of 180 million dollars and the range of awards five million to 20 million for
the project approval life cycle is up to 36 months as well and the application required a letter
supporting proposal from the governor the due date for this application was june 29 2020 which
the cde met we also sent in on may 19 2020 the intent to apply before that which was uh
strongly encouraged as part of the application process through collaboration with the cde the
state board of education and the governor's office our application was submitted and the u.s
department of education plans to make awards by august 2020
now we'll go into cd's proposal for the grant application and the application
um
now we'll go into cd's proposal for the esf rem grant for our proposal cd selected absolute
priority number two this priority is to develop and or expand high quality course access programs
the impact coven 19 has had on the california educational environment
can most be seen through the digital divide when it came to offering courses and programs in an
online online environment proactively the cd and other partners have undertaken major effort to
work with public and private partners across the state to increase digital resources the second is
that coven 19 is amplified concern around the inability to optimize learning acceleration
and the impact this has had on students from under-resourced populations and third post
coven 19 educational environment requires that california expand high quality college and career
ready resources and programs in response to these issues the cd is proposing the california open
education project or calif hop-ed project for short by building a statewide learning and teaching
equity platform to increase access to quality college and career distance learning education
to improve learning outcomes for students grade through students grades six through 12 throughout
the state the project builds out the college and career ready infrastructure by developing a
statewide course access platform to increase access to college and career distance learning
curriculum for students and educators and informs parents about the ways in which cal op ed can
provide increased educational access for their students this project is especially important
given students in remote and rural regions that have historically lacked funding
and or capacity to better access high quality digital coursework
so the three primary objectives are to provide a common platform to all public and non-public
schools so teachers and students have access to quality digital learning resources and enhanced
instructional materials also an objective is to create a statewide stakeholder group consisting
of parents community leaders industry partners and educational leaders to identify critical needs
to provide input and third the project will convene regional educator teams to collaboratively
write curate and develop a repository of courses curriculum and professional learning modules and
we believe these last two objectives are extremely important due to the fact that we believe the best
outcomes are had when multiple parties and professionals collaborate to provide the
best outcome for our state students when coming up with this proposal cd and sbe staff wanted
to ensure that it was built with a sustainable outlook in mind meaning that the project not just
be a short-term response to the covid 19 pandemic but must also be focused on building on top of
long-term foundations in order to guarantee equitable advancement for all students even
after the pandemic has ended with that in mind this project aims to increase access to an inclusive
and innovative 21st century education that will prepare students to meet the new demands for
distance learning and the jobs for tomorrow additionally the cal op ed project provides
vital offerings to students from underserved and rural regions it also works to build on and
maximize the current cte online platform which hosts professional learning resources for educators
around the state in the application that was submitted to the u.s department of education the
cd provided a detailed description of responsibilities timelines and milestones that the project would
require in the interest of respecting the board's time i will point members to attachment two and
the item for the detailed breakdown one highlight for this project the cd is requesting over 19
million dollars over three years to fund the project also for note in this application it was
required the state demonstrate its coronavirus burden although the u.s department of education
assigned california one of the lowest scores for coronavirus burden this score was based on percent
of population without access to broadband percent of k-12 students in poverty states percentage share
of covid 19 cases per capita and percent of students who live in a rural area through our
application we made the case that just looking at percentages alone for scoring does not accurately
reflect the state's true coronavirus burden maine which received a top score with over 11.7 percent
of their students without broadband access equates to 21 000 students in raw numbers where california's
8.9 percent equates to approximately 570 000 students also at the time of the proposal even
though the cases per capita was lower in california the burden score did not reflect the aggressive
approach undertaken by governor newsome and our state's leading officials to flatten the curve
through shelter in place and the closing of schools earlier than in other states which increased the
time students spent outside the classroom nor did the u.s department of education score consider the
fluid nature of this pandemic which is evolving each day the application made the point that a
hugely significant burden has been felt by our state and its citizens
continually also the proposal required the cde to sign off on multiple insurances that are detailed
in attachment attachment three of the item this proposal also received a letter of support from
governor newsome as required by the application
so in closing we believe that this is to take a proactive approach for the post-covid 19 pandemic
that it helps our students in both the short and long term as required by the changing educational
environment to distance learning the cde recommends that the sb e ratify california's
esf rem grant application to develop a statewide course access program for all grades six through
12 students in california and with that i will open up for questions thank you very much we're
going to open a public comment line the phone line for public comment members of the public wishing
to provide comment on this item may do so by calling seven one two four three two zero zero
seven five entering access code 651 905 pound wait for the operator prompts to press star six
and then another prompt to press one to enter the queue while we're waiting to see if members of
the public are calling in i want to ask patricia rucker first and then ting sun as our cte liaisons
if they have any initial comments thank you very thank you very much
this is definitely a need in the state and i'm glad for the prospect of some substantial funding
to support our overall state plan for developing career and technical education
in this state now it is worth noting that this project is being led by the cde
and so dr kodem rajan you already know what my question is going to be
when the statewide stakeholder group is organized please tell me there will be
more than one classroom teacher on this statewide stakeholder group
member rucker i i can assure you that there will be more than one teacher in fact
the majority of that stakeholder group will be teachers that's what we use in the ct online
project that we've done we've used uh perconsponse to develop and they're
the ones who developed the modules for that system are teachers and we will
pull it we'll be pulling those those individuals in okay fed i know that we will
go spending some time at tomorrow's meeting talking about this as well so i won't go into
detail on that point but i just wanted to make sure for the record as we are prepared i'm sorry
as we are working to approve this that that information is clear i want to also say i
appreciate the equity lens and i wonder if the majority of historically marginalized students
in california would benefit from a more expansive consideration of equity in the project design and
planning and that's something i just want you to make a note about because i know that the
grant is a living document and we can talk more about the equity issue especially with
the superintendent's new equity officer as we move down the road to implementing the grant
and then finally i just want to say it's really important for us to see as you look at all three
of the attachments in the scoping section of the grant it would seem like it's three projects
but it's really important for us to articulate to articulate that this is part of the overall
program and design for the state plan about career and technical education and so even though the
the community colleges are going to be uppermost in a lot of the planning and the work on scoping
this out the intent really is to create a clear grade 6 through 12 program so i really appreciate
the work the department has done and the effort that was done to as a collaborative project
to prepare this grant and submit it thank you all right ting did you want to add anything
yeah just uh quickly we of course we're ratifying this because there was a such a short timeline
and cde really needed to had a short time period to get the application done and submit it it is an
ambitious project and so in a lot of details will need to be flushed out as member rucker indicated
so i think there will definitely be much more we'll see the shape of this if we get approved
one thing i did want to clarify however the item said that we were asking for 19.19 million
394 and the slide said 19 million 880 something so there was a discrepancy between the item and
what was on the slide so uh staff can just clarify what that is so we know what we're ratifying
members it's actually 19.394 is the amount that we're right ratifying
okay so it is what is in the item yeah
all right thank you all right moving ahead i want to see if there's any public comment
we do have one person
caller you are unmuted would you like to provide comment for item 22 regarding the grant application
no thank you
all right that was short and sweet i guess this is for another item perhaps are there any
other comments from the from the board
let me see if we've got any hands linda i guess has her hand up yeah i'm going to remove my hand
ij would you uh yes i just want to say that uh this is wonderful and um i also i agree with member
rucker about the importance of having teachers represented while here and um you know i hope this
happens great great thank you i see no other hands raised do i have a motion
i will move that we ratify the application and i will second all right thank you very much
all right thank you very much
patricia yes brenna yes jim yes please ting yes eileen yes linda yes cynthia yes matt
yes i day yes kim yes unanimous all right thank you very much and thank you joe uh for both
presenting and for your work on this we appreciate it we're now going to go to waiver request item
16 the request by fallbrook union elementary school district to waive california education
california education comes section 5020 and portions of sections 5019, 5021, and 5030
that require a district-wide election to establish a trustee a by trustee area method of election
cde recommendation is given in unique circumstances of COVID-19 pandemic the resulting
budget problems for school districts and the fact that districts are working remotely in the spring
that the state board make a determination that there is a need to take immediate action on the
waiver the need for action came to the attention of cde and the state board after the agenda was
posted on june 26th the state board makes that determination with a two-thirds vote and the cde
recommends the state board approve the waiver and this item is presented by judy sias and larry
hi it's judy sias chief counsel with the state board linda thank you for explaining this waiver
this is one of our typical waivers to approve the at-large election by trustee area method of
election districts that have an at-large system of electing board members have been facing litigation
under the california by voting rights act to help avoid litigation districts work with their
county committee on school district organization to draw area maps and take action to establish
trustee areas and adopt the trustee area method of election in order to establish the trustee
area and implement this new method as quickly as possible districts will often request a waiver
from the state board that the trust the election method be approved at a district-wide election
if the sbe approves the waiver then there will be an election in the district to elect the governing
board members under the new system this waiver helps districts avoid litigation by moving to
the new system quickly the sb has approved over 200 of these waivers so this waiver is not
controversial this one is a little bit unique because we received a call from the fallbrook
union elementary district last week on july second after the agenda was posted that they realized
that their waiver was not on the july agenda the san diego county registrar of voters told the
district that if they did not put the get a waiver approved in july they would have to have an
election on the election method and that would cost them over three hundred thousand dollars
so i would like to thank larry shirey who quickly worked with work to develop this item so that we
could add it to the agenda we feel like as linda stated at the beginning given the unique circumstances
with covid and the fact that districts were working remotely and the budget crisis you know
we would like to accommodate the district if we could so under since this came to our attention
after the 10-day posting under bagley keen we need two votes so the first vote would be for you all
to add this item to the agenda so you have to make the determination that there is a need to
take immediate action and that the need for action came to our attention after the agenda was posted
like linda said that's two-thirds vote once you make that vote to add it to the agenda
then we will need a quick vote to approve the waiver that that is it thank you very much
and i think we will open the phone line for public comment if there is any
and it's the same notification that we had before and i suspect our last caller was calling for this
item so um do you want to well oh i wanted to ask patricia rucker i'm sorry she's our
waiver liaison if she has any initial comments before we turn to well and i do understand
that we have two votes that we need to take so when we are ready to make those votes i will make
the motions related to both of those votes and for our new board members i do want to explain
one other point that's important about this particular item only the election to establish
the trustee area and the election method will be eliminated by approving this waiver voters in the
district will continue elect to all governing board members and moreover the waiver will not
eliminate any existing legal rights for currently seated board members thank you patricia
okay uh is there any public comment
uh yes we do have um one person in the queue
uh speaker um would you like to provide public comment
okay thank you
that's it no more public comment i guess i guess that was a no uh okay so uh we want to
take those motions in order uh so um are there is there any further discussion before we take
the first motion seeing none um member rucker would you like to make the first motion
i move that the state board of education make a determination that there is a need
to take immediate action on this waiver and that the need for action came to the attention
of the cde and the state board of education after the agenda was posted on june 26 2020
thank you very much is there a second i'll second thank you breanna um karen you want to call the
roll call okay ting yes eileen yes patricia yeah i day yes kim yes breanna yes matt yes jim
yes cynthia yes linda yes okay that motion carries unanimously
all right and now we need a motion on the waiver itself um and so uh member record did you want
to make that motion as well sure i move that the state board approve the waiver request from the
fallbrook school district as recommended in the staff recommendation all right do i have a second
i'll second thank you um any further discussion all right let's have a roll call vote
okay patricia yes breanna yes jim yes ting yes eileen yes linda yes cynthia yes matt
yes i day yes kim yes okay unanimous though all right so i now adjourn our july 20 state board
meeting at 7 37 p.m i want to assure the new board members that this was one of our easier meetings
no we look forward to seeing you again at our september meeting